ButBut we have we have a  a
more fundamentalmore fundamental
which  which is that
we'rewe're all all taking taking
devices devices that that
run  on batterieson batteries
and  and try totry
create  experiencesexperiences
for for them them  that
feel  just asjust as compelling
compelling as as
experiences  for  computers
computers that that
plug into into your  friendly
your friendly
neighborhood power power plant
plant..
AndAnd closing closing that  gap
that gap is is
fundamentallyly difficult
difficult..
So theSo the way way  wewe solve
solve that that with with
day dream is is with with
hardware hardware and and
software  designed in  concertin
concert
with one another another..
We've triedWe've tried  toto
make suremake  thatsure that
every facet facet of the of the
platform
supports  every otherevery other
..
Today I'mToday I'm  going to
going to walk walk you
through you  the developer
developer tools tools that that
we are are going going to be to
be providing providing
that  help you you  take
advantagetake advantage  of
all of it of it..
For usFor us the the foundation
foundation  of
Daydream require great hardware.
You have to have all of the
right parts to ensure ensure a a
high high
quality,,  low latencylow
latency experience experience..
SoSo we've we've insured insured
that everythat every
Daydream phone phone has has a a
low low
persistence display display to
to make make  sure
there's no no ghost ghostinging
or
unnecessary lag lag coming
coming from from  the
display itself itself..
We have a high quality quality S
SOOCC,,
which will will let let all all
of of you you create
create  create  amazing
experiences andexperiences and
render themthem  atat  60 frames
a60 frames a
second.
AndAnd of course of course the
the sensors sensors in the
phone are are super super
critical critical..
We've madeWe've made sure sure
that that they're they're all
all
high  performance,performance,
high high quality quality,,
low latency latency connect
connectorsors so so that that
there's  a  connection between
connection between
what you do you in the do in the
real real world
and what what  you seeyou see
in the virtualin the virtual
world..
Now, ielts notNow, ielts not
actually actually a a single
single
phone  for Daydream Daydream
it's it's  a
standarda  for phones phones
called
Daydream--readyready..
And the greatAnd the great
thingthing  about thisabout this
for for developers
developers,,
it gives you you a a platform
platform you you can
feel  confident aboutconfident
about..
You knowYou know if if you're
you're building building for
the for  DaydreamDaydream--ready
ready  spec,spec, any any
Daydream phone phone will will
run run your your app app
well.
ItIt  givesgives consumers
consumers confidence confidence
that when they they buy buy a a
DaydreamDaydream
app,  it willit will run run  on
anyon any phone phone
they have have as  as long as
it'slong as it's
Daydream--readyready..
GreatGreat hardware hardware
doesn't doesn't just just give
you give  a cents of  presence
cents of presence,, it it
requires great great software
software,, as as  well
well.
Which isWhich is why why we we
worked worked really really
closely on the on the Android
Android team team an an
on  Android N onAndroid N on VR
VR mode mode..
We needWe need make make sure
sure it's it's great great for
for
VR .
And there'sAnd there's a a few
few key key  components
thatcomponents  we've made made
available available to to
developers..
TheThe first first of those of
those is a is a low low
latency  support  forfor Android
Android N
andN  that'sthat's the the
foundation for foundation for VR
VR
and for for presence presence..
We have aWe have  sustaineda
sustained performance
performance
moped  that manages manages the
the hardware hardware
andand  makes suremakes sure
when userswhen  deusers de
decide decide
to  get in in VR VR,, they they
can can stay stay in in
VR  as long as theyas long as
they want want..
With we haveWith we have  high
qualityhigh quality head head
tracking algorithmgorithmss that
that  fuse
allfuse  of theof the data data
from from the the sensors
sensors
in the the  phone andphone
trackand track your your head
movement somovement so  that
lookingthat looking around
around
in the virtual worldvirtual
world is is just just as as
natural asnatural as it  it is
in theis in the real real
world.
But forBut  allfor all  ofof
thisthis,, we we  know
thatknow  your phoneyour phone
is is still
fundamentallyly your your phone
and
you're going to get phone calls
you'reou're going  going to get
textto get text
messages,  so weso we  make sure
make sure  to
portto  key components
components of  of thethe
Android UII  intointo  VR soVR
so that that if if
you get  a calla call or or  you
get ayou get a text text
message , we we render render it
it for for you in you in
stereo and youand you  can
decidecan decide
whether you  want to staywant to
stay  in VRin VR
or leave to to act act  onon
that that
notification.
Now,Now,  if you takeif you take
a a Daydream Daydream
phone running running Android N
Android N and and you you
combine it with with a viewer a
viewer,, you
get anget an incredible
incredible sense of
presence.
You feel like you're somewhere
sense
else.
But toBut to a certain a certain
extent extent,, all all you you
can  do  is lookis look  around.
around.
You know,You know, I I spent
spent much much of of my my
career as a gameas a game
developer developer..
And IAnd I developed developed a
a deep deep respect respect
for the powerpower of of
interactive interactive ity.ity.
You know,You know, when when you
you think think about about
the things we we learn learn,,
really
early really  in life life,, in
infancyin infancy,, the the
firstfirst thing thing we we
learn learn is is  how to
lookhow to  around..
AndAnd then then we we learn
learn how to how to use use our
our
hands..
WeWe  learnlearn  how to reach
how to  out andreach out and
touch thetouch the world world..
We learnWe learn about about
ourour heads heads and and  our
handsour  together..
InIn Daydream Daydream  we sawwe
saw an an
opportunity  toto  provide
accessprovide access to to
both heads  and handsand hands
in in VR VR..
WeWe  did thatdid that  through
thethrough the creation creation
of the Daydream Daydream
controller controller..
This controllerThis controller
is is simple simple enough
enough
that  anyone can can use it use
it,, even even
while they're in in VR VR and
and can't
actuallycan't  see their their
hands.hands.
ButBut  we've alsowe've also
made itmade it
expressive enough that
developers can use it to develop
rich, amazing interactions.
enough that
It's precise  enough thatenough
that you you can can
use it as a laseras a laser
pointer pointer..
ButBut it's it's also also
responsive responsive enough
enough
to  use ituse it to to swing
swing  it as ait as a
tennis racquet.
We'veWe've added added a a
clickableclickable touch touch
padpad  so thatso that  you can
you can  both grabboth grab
and interactnteract with with
virtual virtual
objects as well asas well as
effortlesseffortlesslyly
browse  the media media
collection.collection.
There'sThere's  an appan  button
app button which  which isis
totally under thethe developer's
developer's
control  andand  a homea home
button button which which
we reserve for for  critical
usercritical user
interactions like returning
returning to
thehe Daydream Daydream home
home screen screen..Now
Now, we, we know know that that
for for developers developers
stable
platform..
You need inputYou need input
that that you you can can rely
rely
on.
So we'veSo we've designed
designed the the viewer viewer
and
theand  phone to to go go
together together,,
literally ,  and we'lland we'll
require require
every user to to have have the
the Daydream Daydream
controller  when we we  enter VR
enter VR..
ThatThat way way when when
someone someone launches
launches
your Daydream app app,, you  you
know
exactlyknow  what  controller
they
have inhave in their their hand
hand..
AndAnd  we believewe believe
that that this this
combination  of Daydreamof
Daydream--readyready
phones with  dayday     Daydream
Daydream users users and and
controllercontroller will will
allow allow incredible
incredible
incredible,      rich,, immerse
immerseive ive VR VR
experiences..
ButBut that's that's not not
just just a a theory theory..
We've beenWe've been working
working with with some some of
of
the best developers in in the
tworld the  make thatmake that a
a reality reality..
I'd like toI'd like to welcome
welcome a a studio studio to to
the  stage whose whose known
known for for
continually  pushing the the
bounds bounds
of what'swhat's  possible in
possible in  realtime
graphics..
One of theOne of the most most
invasive invasive
developers in the the world
world,,  - --
innovateive ive T Tcreators
creators T  creators
Tcreators of  of thethe  in
inreal engineinreal engine..
We've beenWe've been  working
withworking with them them on on
Daydream.
ToTo talk talk more more about
about the
partnershipartnership I'd I'd
like to like to
introduce theirtheir  CECEOO,,
KimKim la la
Barry.
[Applause.]
Thanks, NathanThanks, Nathan;; .
.
AndAnd hello hello Google Google
I IOO..
To giveTo give developers
developers immerse immerse ive
ive and
visually and  impressive
experiences experiences
with  fantastic  performance
performance on on
all the  platformsplatforms that
that we we
support.
We'veWe've been been creating
creating VR VR
experiencesexperiences for for
many many years years that
not that  only push push visual
visual fidelity fidelity
but  inputinput,, interaction
interaction,,
character s and and game game
play play
mechanics..
EveryEvery project project that
that we we work work on on
extends theextends the
capabilities capabilities of of
un un
unreal   engineengine and and we
we give give these these
back to developers on a on a
daily daily
basis  through Github Github..
TodayToday we're we're very very
,, very very proud proud to  to
be part  ofof new new chapter
chapter in in VR VR
history  and we've we've been
been eg eg eager    eagerlyly
preparing for thethe arrive
arrive arrival        arrival of
of
Daydream  and we're we're ready
ready to to let
you let see a a project project
we've we've been been
working on so so you you  can
seecan see this this
awesome new platform platform
and and what what
developers  can do  itdo it on
on real real
engine 4.
CheckCheck out out video video..
>> For>> For years weyears we
made made  video gamesvideo
games
where you'd sit sit on the on
the  other
sideother  of the glass glass..
NowNow you're you're inside
inside the the real real 3- 3-DD
feeling offeeling
presence..
>> >> DaydreamDaydream's's an an
exciting exciting new new
mobile VR platform platform and
and what what it it
does  is take take some some of
of the highthe high VR VR
features  we've seen inwe've
seen desktop in desktop
VR applications applications and
and brings brings them them
to Android so so that that we we
can can really
up the really level of fidelity
in ourin our
mobile VRVR experiences
experiences.
>> >> What'sWhat's especially
especially exciting exciting
aboutabout Daydream Daydream is
is that that you have you have
complete freedom of movement.
You don't have a cord tangling
you up.
You also have this amazing of
movement
lets lets you you
interact .
ItIt lets lets you you  throw
thingsthrow things..
It letsIt lets you you choose
choose  where youwhere you
want towant to  movemove..
>> >> SoSo when when people
people think think about about
mobile  VR you you generally
generally think  ofthink of
of, you knowf, you know,, look
look,, aiming aiming,,  are
yourare  hands lockedhands
locked to your to  headyour
head??
AboutAbout with with the the
Daydream Daydream
controller , it's it's a a
whole newwhole new
ball game..
You canYou can  freely interact
freely interact with with the
the
world  in a naturalin a natural
way way  andand that that
feels  reallyreally  good.good.
>>
>> The The Daydream integration
Daydream  wasintegration was
unrealnreal..It
It works works out out of the of
the box box  forfor all all
the interfaces you're you're
already already
familiaramiliar with with..
There's nothingThere's nothing
new new to to learn learn..
YouYou can can jump jump in in
there and there and  start
createstart ing experiences
experiences  with thewith the
tools.
>> We're excited excited about
about Daydream Daydream
while everyoneeveryone  has ahas
a phone phone,, this this
really takes VR VR to to the the
mathmath..
ItIt gives gives you you the the
ability to haveability to
the samethe same kind  kind of
experiencesof experiences you
you
have on really really  highhigh
VR VR systems systems
but now completely completely
immerseimmerse iveive and
with and  this beautiful
controllerbeautiful controller..
AndAnd we we know know that that
it it will will power power
some  actually amazing amazing
incredible
experiencesincredible  there..
>> >> TheThe this this isis
a a sample sample  project I
project
madeI  with assets assets from
from the the
marketplace .
I'm reallyI'm really excited
excited to to see see what what
you guys doguys  withdo with
Daydream Daydream and on and on
[Applause.]
>> Kim>> Kim:: Thank you Thank
you..
Pretty amazingPretty amazing..
MobileMobile  VR isVR is going
going to look to look that that
good .
It's amazingIt's amazing..
This isThis is barely barely
scratch ingscratching of of the
the
surface  ofof what's  what's
going to begoing to be ibleible
TheThe Daydream Daydream
controller controller is a is a
major advancement advancement in
in terms terms  ofof
how you can can craft craft
mechanics mechanics,,
explore a a mobile mobile world
world  all onall on
your mobileyour mobile device
device..
Natural inputNatural input made
made for for VR VR is is
hugely important important in
terms in terms of of
makeing youmake ing you believe
believe that that you've you've
been  transported to to  another
placeanother .
AndAnd what's what's better
better is is that that if you if
incorporate motion motion
controls controls,, you you
reallyeally,, really feel a
really feel a high high level
of  emotion.emotion.
DaydreamDaydream empower empower
ss you you to to  create
rich,ich, deeply deeply
interactive interactive content
content
for mobilemobile..
AndAnd we we can't can't wait
wait to to see see the the
awesome  contentcontent  andand
games games and and
demosdemos  and alland all the
the amazing amazing things
things
that are going to to follow
follow using using
Daydream  and unand unrealreal
engine engine 4. 4.
ThanksThanks very very much.
much.[Applause.]
[Applause.]
Back to NathanBack to Nathan..
>> Thanks,>> Thanks, Kim Kim..
ThanksThanks  so muchso much..
>> So>> So,, it's it's so so
cool tocool to see see what what
already make ing for for
Daydream .
ButBut  I'm sureI'm sure many
many of  youof you are are
wonderingondering::  When  When
can Ican I  be abe a
Daydream developer??
AndAnd I'm I'm really really
proud proud to to say say that
that
you can do do  that rightthat
right now now..
For those ofFor those of you you
who arewho are  C++
developersC++  and we we know
know that that many many
ofof our our core core VR VR
developers developers love love
just launched an an N NDDKK
NDK for Daydream that that gives
gives you you
direct  low level level access
access to to all
of the features features of of
our our hardware hardware
and softwaresoftware  platform
platform..
And weAnd we know know that
manythat many  ofof you you
actually  like to to use use
game game
engines likelike  unity andunity
and un unrealreal..We've
We've  got yougot you covered
covered,, as as well well..
If you'reIf you're  a unity
developera unity developer,,
we're really really proud proud
to to say say that that
there'sthere's  aa plug plug--in
in available available
today andtoday and we'll we'll
have have a a  native
integration coming coming up
this up this
summer..
IfIf you're you're  anan un un
realreal developer developer,,
you canou can start start tod
today,ay, right right now, now,
version version of of  UnUn
UnrealUnreal 4.12. 4.12.
ForFor  allall of of this this
information information
about how how you you can be can
be a a Daydream Daydream
developerdeveloper,, including
including how  how to
buildto  your own own Daydream
Daydream
developer kitit  checkcheck out
out
developersdevelopers..google
google.com.com//VRVR..
AndAnd I'm I'm going to going
hand to hand it it over over to
to
Lindsay Metcalf,, one of one of
ourour
team's lead designers designers
toto show show
you  the Daydreamthe Daydream
experiences andexperiences and
what they'll look look like like
for for our our
users and how how we're we're
going to
helpgoing to  them  discover the
experiences experiences that
that all all
of  you will will create  create
..
Thank youThank you..
[Applause.]
>> Thanks>> Thanks..
Thank youThank you..
Thanks, NathanThanks, Nathan..
We've learnedWe've learned so so
much much about about
design ing  good VRgood VR..
AndAnd we're we're looking
looking forward forward to to
sharing  it with  you allyou all
at at I/O I/O
this weekweek..
So I'llSo I'll walk walk you
through you through
Daydream home and tell youhome
and tell how you how
wee designed designed the the
experience experience to to
really connectconnect people
people to to the the
best  VR contentVR content..
Then I'mThen I'm going going to
take you to take
through you  a couple of thea
couple of the app appss
that we've designed designed
and shareand share
some of the the  thingsthings
that we'vethat we've
learned that that will will help
help you you
create your very very own  VR
appown VRs apps..
This is DaydreamThis is Daydream
home.home.
ItIt  comes withcomes with every
every Daydream Daydream--
Daydream-ready     phonephone
and it'sand it's
the firstthe first th thing that
ing that people people will will
their
Daydreamtheir  VR experience
experience..
And forAnd for  VR,VR, craft
craftinging the right the right
environment is so so important
important for for
facilitating presence,, so so
for for
Daydream home,, we we really
really wanted wanted
to create a welcomingcreate a
welcoming space space that
had a bit a bit of of wonder
wonder and and delight delight
inside  ofof  it andit and it it
was
somewhere was  that you'd you'd
want to want
stop and hang and hang out out
for for a bit a bit
beforebefore you you embarked
embarked on on your your next
next
experience .
Daydream homeDaydream home is
also is also  your
experienceyour  launchlauncherer
..
This is whereThis is where you
you  can seecan see and and
launch  your favorite favorite
app appss,,
access play play store store to
to get get new new
content and  also accessalso
access system system
settings .
But DaydreamBut Daydream  home
isn'thome isn't just just a a
list ofof  appsapps..
SoSo up up here here on on the
the top top row row,, these
these
are discovery windows windows..
AndAnd  discovery windows
discovery windows  are whereare
where
we're going to to promote
promote and and cure cure
curate the very very best best
content
thatcontent  you create  create
..
DiscoveryDiscovery windows
windows,,  we've
designed,,  with a sensewith a
ofsense of depth depth
and parapara  lacks solacks  you
so  canyou can really really
get aa sense sense of of peak
peakinging into into a a
newew 3-D 3-D world world..
You canYou can  step up tostep
up to a a discovery discovery
window andand peer peer in in
and and really really
get  a sense sense of the of the
world itworld  willit will
teleport you you to to..
AndAnd using  Androidusing
Android  deep linksdeep links
you you
can  add intent intent filters
filters  toto these these
discovery  windows and they will
they will
take users direct directlyly to
to content content
inside  of your your  appsapps..
The importanceThe importance of
of this this,, it it means means
that if you if you add add a a
newnew episode episode or or
level to your your game game,,
it it means means
that you can can promote promote
it it,, or or them them
them, andand you you don't
actually don't
havehave to  to have ahave a new
new app app..
UsersUsers  can alreadycan
already have have the the app
app
installed  on their their phone
phone..
NextNext  let's takelet's take
a looka look  atat  play
store  in VRin .VR.Play
Play store  willstore will
connect connect people people
to all all of of your your app
appss..
AndAnd since since this is this
is play store, it
means we're starting with play a
largea  developer community
developer community.
AllAll of of you you out out
here here..
And itAnd it also also means
means that that we have a
global payments and distribution
we
support support
things like in inopo p purchases
purchases  from
day one.
We  designed storedesigned store
to to make make it it
easy to  browsebrowse for for
app appss and and
games in VR VR by by showcase
showcase inging
collections  of cure cureated
ated content content
as well as make makeing it ing
it easy easy to to
navigate by  swipeswipe ing
throughing through the the
content  with the the Daydream
Daydream
controller.
NowNow I'm I'm going to going
dive to dive into the into the
Google street view view app app
in in play play
store VR VR an and taked take a
a more
detailed more  look..
HereHere we've we've  added VR
added VR--specificspecific
features to help help you you
promote promote
your app appss..
SuchSuch as as 360 photosphere
360 photosphere previews
previews
that  you can can preview
preview all all  around
youaround  instead of of just
just  flat staticflat static
screen shots..
And inAnd in VR VR,, even even
with with the the  most
excitingmost  gamesgames,, it's
it's really really
important  to  make suremake
sure we're we're
design ing comfortable
comfortable
experiences .
SoSo  we've addedwe've added a a
motion motion
intensityintensity rating rating
to to  help peoplehelp people
find content content that's
that's right right  for
themfor .
AndAnd let's let's be be
realistic realistic here here..
No matter how awesome VR is,No
matter how awesome VR is,
we're still going going to spend
to spend most most
of our  time in thetime in the
real worldreal world..
SoSo for  for the timesthe times
that that you're
awayyou're  from your your
Daydream Daydream viewer viewer,
,
our  Daydream mobileDaydream
mobile app app will will
makeake it it really really easy
easy to to discover discover
and  cuuee  upup  content to
content to try try it it
later.
So whenSo when  you're on the
you're on the  go andgo and you
you
have somesome  time to vowstime
to vows      browse browse but
but you you
don't have your your viewer
viewer on on hand hand
you  can queuecan queue  them up
tothem up to watch watch
later .
Or you'reOr you're at  at a
friend'sa friend's house house
and you hearhear about about a a
an an
incredible  newnew VR VR game ,
game,  you canyou can
download the app app from from
your your
mobile phone and and the the
game game  will
be therethere  next timenext
time you you return return to to
Daydream  homehome..
YesterdayYesterday we we
mentioned mentioned that that a
a VR VR
version  of YouTube YouTube is
is coming coming..So
So now now  let's takelet's take
a a look look..
With stauroscopicWith
stauroscopic  VRVR video video
through 360 livelive streaming
streaming and and
spatial audio we've we've built
an built
awesome an  foundation for truly
for truly
immerseive video video with with
YouTube YouTube..
YouYou  can stepcan step inside
inside a a video video and
havehave  it allit all around
around you you and and you
can you  really feel feel like
like you're you're
there .
Including hangingIncluding
hanging out out with with great
great
white Sharks Sharks which which
in in VR VR is is
actually pretty scary scary..
YouTubeYouTube is is also also a
a huge huge part part of of
discovery for  VR.VR.
I thinkI think many many of of
us andus and many
people have had their first
experience many with  Virtual
Reality
here in in YouTube YouTube so so
we've beenwe've been
working with with our our
friends atfriends at  you
you tub to bringto bring this
this all all  together
intogether  a stand alone alone
VR VR app app..
.
I'mI'm  sharing thissharing this
with with you you
because webecause we think think
YouTube YouTube is is
going to beto be one one of the
best of the best Waze Waze
for you  too reach reach users
users and and show
off show your app sapps..
A lot ofA lot of  us areus are
already already using using
YouTube toto share share
development
tips and and tricks tricks..
Now withNow with the the VR VR
video video creation creation
tools  that the the YouTube
YouTube team team is is
hard at  workwork on on,, it it
will will also also be be
an incredible  way for youway
for you to to
connect  with your your audience
audience and and
build a community community.
SoSo you'll you'll be be  able
able to to up uploadload 360
video 360 , trailers trailers,,
game game  play,play,
basicallyasically everything
everything that that you'd you'd
really
excited about thethe content
content that that
you're going to to  create .
create
SoSo,, we've we've designed
designed the the Daydream
Daydream
experience by help helpinging
people people
connect  to your your content
content and
continuecontinue  to reto re
engageengage with with it it
over  time.
But more than anything wh what
we'rewe're really really
excited aboutexcited about is is
seeingseeing what what you you
all areall are going going to
create .
And we we know know  thatthat
arethat there are
thousands of  undiscovered
thingsundiscovered things
left to explore explore in in VR
.VR.So to
So to help help,, whatever
whatever we we learn learn
from performance  optimizations
optimizations
toto user user experience
experience,, we we want want to
to
share that  with youwith you..
So todaySo today we're we're
excited excited to to
introduce  Daydream labs labs..
DaydreamDaydream labs labs is is
where where we're we're
going to experimentto experiment
and and share share
what we've we've learned learned
with with the the
world.
We'reWe're  hard athard at work
work right right here here in in
and  we're explorewe're explore
exploring everything from from
usability to  hardware to
hardware to new new
user experiences experiences
for Virtual
Realityeality..
AndAnd as as part part of of
this this  effort,effort,
we're rapid prototype prototype
inging  to seeto see
what  makes VRmakes VR use use
fulful,, fun fun and and
also  sometimes bad bad..
So,So, so so far far we've we've
been been building building
about two app app experiments
experiments a week a week
for a while and and today today
we're we're
going  to start sharing sharing
these these
lessons with everyone everyone..
We'llWe'll give  give you access
you access,, first first
we'll start by by giving giving
you you  access
toaccess  our Daydream Daydream
design design
playground to  get youget you
started
develop ing for the for
Daydreamthe Daydream
controller.
We'll give youWe'll give you
access access to to all all the
different the  types of
experiences
that we've created so far we've
created so far and and
from  flippingping pancakes
pancakes to to
playing  tennis,, we have we
have  about 15
differentabout  Waze to to
interact interact with with
the controller  that wethat we
thought thought
of so  far.far.
We'reWe're also also giving
giving another another  talk
thistalk  morning on on lessons
lessons learned learned
fromfrom Daydream Daydream  labs
labs..
This isThis is focused focused
on on our our rapid rapid
prototypeing initiative
initiative..
AndAnd we're we're going to
going to start start sharing
sharing
all of of this this regularly
regularly on the on the
Google VR blog blog..
We'reWe're so so excited  to
excited to  join thejoin
conversation,, and and we we
can't can't wait wait
toto see see what what everyone
everyone  individuals
individuals.individuals
I'dI'd now now like to like to
hand hand this this back back
to clay..
Thank youThank you..
[Applause.]
>> CLAY BAVOR:>> CLAY BAVOR:
One  One of  of the
prototypesthe  you'll getyou'll
toget to see see as
part of the session Lindsay
mentionedmentioned is is a VR a
VR watering watering can can..
We took aWe took a Vive Vive
controller controller and and
jammed it it in the in the front
front of of a a
watering can..
AndAnd it it turns turns  outout
it's it's very very
natural to water water things
things in in  VR
whenVR  you have aave a watering
watering can can..
SoSo,, anyway anyway,, stay
tuned stay tuned  for thatfor
that..
May beMay be even even better
better than the
pancakes.
So than hopefully this this all
all gives gives  you
an idea ofidea of how how some
some of  of the partsthe
of Daydream Daydream come come
together together,, from from
the  Daydream--readyready
smartphones smartphones
and  the VR VR optimization
optimizationss as as part part
ofof N N,, the the controller
controller,, the the viewer
viewer
viewer.
AndAnd  some of thesome of the
tools tools that
you'll that have accesshave  to
access to  as
developers..
LikeLike the the discovery
discovery windows windows where
where
youyou can can push push new new
experiences experiences and
and
so on to to  users asusers as
part ofpart of
DaydreamDaydream home home..
But of courseBut of course the
the smartphones smartphones,,
the operatingthe operating
systems systems,, the the
headset tcontrollercontroller,,
it's it's not not
what  VR is is  about.about.
It'sIt's about about the stuff
the  thatstuff that you you
can do,, the the experiences
experiences..
AndAnd we we hope hope you're
you're going to
create many of thosecreate many
of those..
AndAnd  fromfrom the the begin
beginningning,,  from
early onarly on with with
Daydream Daydream,, we've we've
been very very focused focused
on on makeing make ing it it
really  easy for for developers
developers..
AndAnd one one of the of
companiesthe companies that's
that's
been at the forefrontthe
forefront of of VR VR
development is  UnityUnity..
And JohnAnd John  Rick anRick an
tell tell oh oh,, their their
CEEOO  has beenhas been one one
of the of the earliest earliest
support ers have have what wha
we've we've been been
doing with Google Google and and
VR VR and and
Daydream and and he he gets gets
what
Daydream is about and I think he
and I'm and
delighteddelighted to  to have
himhave him here here to to
say aa few few words words..
SoSo,,  John,John, please please
..
[Applause.]
>> John>> John:: So So thanks
,thanks,  ClayClay..
It's anIt's an incredible
incredible honor honor to be to
be
here.
And IAnd I want to want to start
start by by just just make
making make a simple observation
observation..
Google andGoogle and  UnityUnity
are deeply are deeply
aligned on our our values values
,, in in
particular  about thethe way way
we we see
Virtual Reality, see how we see
see VR VR..
Now, theNow, the mission mission
of of
democratization has been at the
been at the
core of  UnityUnity technology
technology since since
our founding about about 10 10
years ago years ago..
DmomDmom rat rat
dem democratizationization..
WhatWhat that that means means
is is putting putting the the
power of technology technology
the hands ofthe hands
users afford affordablyably
whether whether they they
can  afford afford it it or or
not not..
AA  reallyreally  bigbig day day
..
Google  VR underVR under  Clay
Clay is is about about
mobile, leveraging leveraging
the powerthe power of  of
the CPPUU  literallyliterally in
in billions  ofbillions of
pockets around thearound the
world world..
Everyone'sEveryone's included
included..
That's anotherThat's another
type of type of democrat
democrat
it ization  it's at theit's at t
valuehe value that  that
we're fundamentally alignedly
aligned..
Now,Now,  from thefrom the begin
beginningning our our
orientation towards supporting
supporting
the  developer has has brought
brought us us a a
fairly sizable audience audience
..
AsAs you can see you can see
behind behind me me  5-1/25-1/2
million developers,, that's
that's  a lot
of people usingpeople using a a
game game
management or game game
technology technology..
TheseThese developers developers
,, in in aggregate aggregate,,
produce games that aregames that
are down    down
downloaded 6 to 76 to 70000
times per times per
secondsecond,, 1.6 billion times
per1.6 billion times per
month.
And if youAnd if you want to
want to think think about about
that  as an an aggregate
aggregate audience audience,,
it's aboutit's about 5 500
million D00 million DAAUUss of
of
games  built on on  UnityUnity,,
so so this this
development communitydevelopment
community,, all  ofall of
you,ou, is a is a very very,,
very very big big  thingthing..
If you thinkIf you think about
about it it,, perhaps perhaps
you'd say that that
democratization democratization
across  5 million developers is
developers is
very  serious scale scale..
Now, unityNow, unity,, as as
clay hasclay has
mentioned , from from the the
begin ningbeginning
has been makeinghas been make
ing  big investmentsbig
inin VR VR..
Some of youSome of you  may have
seen ourmay have seen our
version of theof the met met
averse averse
creatingcreating VR VR from from
within VRwithin VR..
That certainlyThat certainly got
got a lot of a lot of
people lit up up on on YouTube
YouTube and and in in
our  community..
And we're also also very much
very much aware aware
of Google Google's's roadmap
roadmap in in VR VR..
AndAnd we we intend intend to b
to be ande  areand are
there every  step of thestep of
the way way..
Now,Now, as as part part  of
thatof ,that, we're we're
announcing  support for for
Daydream Daydream..
Surprise.Surprise.
We'll beWe'll be there there..
We areWe are there there..
It'llIt'll be be native native
inside inside of of  UnityUnity,
,
very easy to to use use..
And we'reAnd we're also also
providing providing support
support
for vulcanvulcan  which we're
which we're launching launching
next quarterquarter..
SoSo the the core core
fundamental fundamental
technologyiestechnology ies that
that you you need will
be right right out out of  of
the boxthe box  ready toready to
use from  UnityUnity but but
beyond beyond that that,,
simple announcement..
We're hereWe're here..
We'reWe're ready ready..
GetGet on on board. board.
I gotI got two two things things
I I want want to talk to talk
about briefly..
Two ideasTwo ideas..
TheThe first first of of  them
them really really is is that
that
I think mobile think mobile is
is going going to be to be
driven by mobile mobile -- --
excuse excuse me me//isis
going to bebe driven driven by
by mobile mobile..
WeWe envision envision a a world
world where where
literally billions billions of
of people people
have access to to VR VR..
AndAnd the the fact fact that
that there's there's really
twice astwice as  many people
many people with with mobile
mobile
devices as PC PCss makes makes i
it
obvious.obvious.
It's just  mathjust math..
SoSo mobile mobile's's going
going to to drive drive this
this
in the fullness the fullness of
of  time.time.
And againAnd again we're we're
there there to to support
support
that .
AndAnd the the second second
idea idea that that I I want
want
to get acrossget across is is I
don't believe I don't believe
that VR is is going going  to be
to be about about
games  oror simple simple shop
shoppingping app appss..
I thinkI think it's it's
literally literally going going
to
extend the the human human
experience experience..
You knowYou know,, imagine
imagine  in ain a world world 10
where you you blink blink
andnd  you're standingyou're
standing in the in the  Taj
Mahal.
OrOr  you blinkyou blink and and
you're you're in in New
York City New .
Or youOr you blink yet blink yet
again andagain and
instead of being being in in  a
silver
tube flyingtube flying 40,000
40,000 feetfeet,, you're you're
soaring on the  won the winging
tips tips of the of the
plane and experience experience
inging flight flight
like you've never  never seen
beforeseen before..
OrOr you're you're on on stage
stage with with your
favorite your  band..
NotNot in in front like front
like  all ofall of you you are
are
are, but rightbut  thereright
there  involved in
ainvolved  way that that feels
feels intimate intimate and and
connected toconnected to the the
people people you you  idol
idolizeidol  .
OrOr  blink againblink again..
You're in aYou're in a classroom
classroom taking taking a a
physics  class from from your
your favorite favorite
professorrofessor at at  Cal
Tech.Cal Tech.
Or you'reOr you're inside inside
a a game game in a in way a way
before before..
Or perhaps perhaps you're you're
talking talking to to
your best friend friend and your
and best your best
friend is thousands thousands of
of  miles
away..
ButBut they're they're sitting
sitting next next  to you
into you  your couch couch in a
in a way way that that
feels intimate,, full full and
and fully fully
present.
These willThese will all all
happen happen..
Imagine if youImagine if you
want want another another one
one..
ThinkThink about about that that
old old silly silly movie movie
fantastic voyage .voyage.
You'll beYou'll be in in that
that capsule capsule
traveling  to the the
bloodstream
frombloodstream  the brain brain
and quiteand quite
possibly through to to the the
end end of of
it  in the bowel the bowel..It's
It's all all going going to be
to be possible possible..
MaybeMaybe you you don't want
don't want tha that lastt last
experience,  but thinkbut think
about about shop shop
shopping     online..
ExceptExcept it'll it'll be be
social social and and you
can try try the the clothes
clothes on on against against
ann  avataravatar that that
matches matches your your
body's  dimensions..
AgainAgain,, all all  a lot
closera lot closer..
WalkingWalking alongside
alongside  thethe surface
surface of of
Mars  with awith a future future
astronaut astronaut
except unexcept unlikelike  hehe
or or she she which which
will  probably be be stuck stuck
there there for
the  rest of of their their
lives lives,, all all you
have you  to do do  is takeis
take  off theoff the H HMMDD
HMD and     you're homeyou're
home..
SoSo th the holodecke holodeck
will will happen happen..We've
We've all all seen seen Star
Trek Star Trek..
ThatThat level level of of
presence presence is is going
going
to happen..You'll
You'll be be  closest toclosest
to your your near near
nearest    and dear dearestest..
MyMy two two daughters daughters
live live in in  citiescities
away from me me..
I'm lookingI'm  forwardlooking
forward to to con con
connecting with them them in a
in a much much
moremore,, I don't know I don't
know,, close close way way
that  makes me me feel feel like
like I'm I'm
right  there..
I'veI've already already
experienced experienced that
that in in
some VR  chat developmentchat
development  that's
prettythat's  amazing..
And at the coreAnd at the  of
core of all all this this is is
we built built the the  Unity
Unity engine engine to to
support 3-Dupport 3-D
development development and and
quitequite naturally naturally
to to support support
Daydream .
We've gotWe've got 5 million
developers 5 million developers,
,
all  of you you ready ready to
to  jumpjump on on
board.
And allAnd all of of you you,, I
I hope hope you're you're
dreaming  about all the all the
ideas ideas I I
lay out andand many many,,  many
moremany more..
DreamDream them them,, .
Build them.Build them.
LifeLife will will never never
be be  the samethe same..
ItIt will  will be onebe one
heck heck of of a a lot lot
better.
AndAnd  with thatwith that,,
ClayClay,, you're you're back
back
on stage stage..
[Applause.]
>> CLAY BAVOR: Thank you so
much>> CLAY BAVOR: Thank you ,
John John..
As As JohnJohn said said,, we're
we're just just deeply deeply
alignedaligned on on this this
idea idea of of  democrat
democratizing VR VR the the
create create inging of of
it  and consumption consumption
of of it it so so it's it's
been a a natural natural
partnership partnership from
from
the beginningbeginning..
I want toI want to thank thank
John and all theJohn and all the
folks at  UnityUnity who have
been so
supportive of of what we're what
we're  doing.doing.
Now,Now, John John talked talked
about the
future.
And that's where I want to end,
as well.
And one of the Waze of figuring
out what's going to happen in
the future is to the look back
on the recent past and recent
progress.
So he want to look back to last
year's Google IOhave and a
couple things we talked about
there.
The first is something called
expeditions.
Expeditions, if you remember, is
this tool for teachers that make
it possible for them to take
classes on field trips to
anywhere.
From coral reefs to Machu Picchu
And for the last school year,
expeditions has been on the road
And in just this school year,
we've taken over 1 million
students on expeditions.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
The other thing we announced
last year was something we
called jump.
Jump is a camera system and
processing software that works
in the cloud that makes the
creation of VR video seamless
and very high quality.
We built it because we think the
world is awesome but we didn't
see a great way of capturing it
immerseively in VR.
And we partnered with Go Pro to
build what's called the can
Odyssey.
We happen to have one here.
If you're tuneing in from VR
later, great to see you.
If everyone could wave and say
hi to our.
Great, thanks, thanks for being
here.
So the Odyssey is rolling out to
And the likes of discovery,
paramount, the New York Times.
And people are saying really
nice thing things about it.
The quality.
How fast it is.
How seamless it is.
But I think the best summary of
it was, we were at the New York
Times and one of the New York
Times creative leads, after
seeing it all came together,
just turned to one of the tech
leads of Jump and said "can I
give you a hug"?
So, we took that hug, thank you
very much.
So Jump from the beginning was
built as a platform, meaning the
software, which we call the Jump
Assembler, the stuff that does
the magic of turning 16 camera
views into Omni directional
stereo
stauroscopic video.
We built it to be flexible to
support multiple camera
architectures.
There's two new ones we'd like
to introduce today.
The first is from ye technology.
Yi is a Chinese company with a
strong presence in Asia.
They're going to be using their
4 K action cam to build a Jump-
Jump-ready camera that will be
available later this year.
We've got a lot of interest from
And that's from Hollywood.
Hollywood is asking us for a
cinema-grade Jump camera.
We're going to build them one
with Imax.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
I'm excited about that.
So Imax, of course, is known
around the world for incredibly
immerseive capture and audio and
their decades of experience in
camera design, optics, sensors
and more to Jump and we're just
incredibly excited about what
we're going to be able to do
with them.
So, looking ahead, it's exciting
to think about just where we'll
be in the near future with
Daydream.
By the end of this year, there
will be multiple Daydream-ready
phones out on the market.
And I hope your next phone is
one of them.
The first Daydream-ready
headsets and controllers will be
design.
And by the way, it's not just
going to be partners building
from the reference design.
We, Google, are also going to
build a controller and a headset
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
And beyond that, the technology
just gets better and better and
better.
VR is just going to get better
and better and better.
And one of the Waze that we with
project Tang oh.
Now Tango and Google were in the
same building.
I'll let you extrapolate from
there but we're pretty excited
about what's ahead.
So over the next two days there
are 17 sessions covering all of
this in a lot more detail, about
how to monetize and distribute
the apps, designing with the
controller, everything you need
to build for Daydream and also
for Tango.
And there's some great sessions
on all of this.
So we really hope to see you
there.
Thank you so much for joining us
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
[Music.]
>> Hi, everyone.
How's it going?
Hope you are having a great O/O
O/O so for.
Anyone go to the Kigo concert
last night?
[Music.]
>> Good morning!.
Hello!
[Applause.]
Welcome, everybody, to our talk
today on what's new in Android
developer tools.
It is awesome to see so many
developers here from around the
world.
And in a concert venue.
I just want you guys to know:
This is pretty cool for us.
I'm Stef Cuthbertson.
I'm here today with a wonderful
Tor Norbye and wonderful Jamal
Eason.
We will give you an insiders
tour of Android studio.
And for those of you who are
already real insiders and notice
that Zav is not on the stage
this year, I'm just filling in
for him.
He's on a beach in Hawaii.
So hello, Zav.
When we first started working on
Android studio, you know we
wanted a purpose-built IDE,
which was tuned for our
languages.
That's why we picked IntelliJ, a
native to the Android platform.
Now the Android studio has built
tremendous momentum in a short
period of time.
One.  Things we announced
yesterday is that now 92 percent
of the top 125 apps and games
Android studio.
Since we announced here here at
IO three years ago.
You may remember it was Tor who
did the demo, we've released 131
times across our preview, beta
and stable releases.
And what that reflects is
actually a big part of what's
driving our success.
We have an incredibly engaged
developer community.
Trying all of your o early
builds and giving us wonderful
feedback.
That is what is lessing the team
focus and helping us go very
quickly.
We've been thinking a lot the
past year about what else we
could do to help accelerate
productivity and make your lives
better.
So for those of you in the
audience who don't know Android
studio quite as well, I'm going
to give you a whirlwind tour of
2016 and what we've done so far
just in about 60 seconds.
So I'll bring everybody up to
the same level and then we'll go
on and talk about 2.2 and the
road ahead.
So, already this year, we
launched 2.0.
That fok you used on speed with
instability run and the emulate,
.
We also launched wonderful
emulator, the debugger preview.
Testing and much more.
That shortly followed 2.1 which
we built side by side with N.
And that brings you support
support for all N's features and
APIs.
It blings you emulator so you
can test N.
The new jack compiler so you can
try out Java 8 support and in
par you lar in 2.1 we also
accelerated instant run and the
way we did that by moving our
deck step to happen in process
which gave us wonderful speed
advances.
Now, all of this brings us now
to 2.2.
Which focuses on speed, smarts
and Android platform support.
Now, one of the things that's
wonderful for us about I/O is
this is a developer audience.
So what we're going to do is
spend the first 25 minutes of
today's talk giving you a live
demo of nearly every single
feature in the 2.2 preview which
you can also use.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Now, just a reminder.
This is a preview build.
So expect preview quality.
And then we'll do the normal
thing we always do over the next
several weeks we'll be
stabilizing this as we do as we
move through beta and stable.
After that, Jamal and I will
then take it back and we'll walk
you through design, develop
build and test to give you a
nice structured overview with
screen shots and also take you
behind the scenes to talk about
how and why features were built.
So with that, to take you on a
lap around 2.2, would you guys
please give a very warm welcome
to Tor Norbye?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> TOR NORBYE: All right.
Can you see the screen?
Demo?
All right.
Can we get the demo machine?
Thank you.
All right.
So I'm going to start with
something very small and simple,
but I think you'll like it.
So we released a lot of SDK come
components yesterday.
Once you installed 2.2 and you
go to install them, notice how
we have a background button now.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
So you could keep coding while
you're installing the latest
goodies.
So we spent the last year
focusing on making builds faster
faster.
We know that's a top concern for
all of you.
And so I'm going to show you
where we are with instant run
right now.
So this is the I/O app running
on the right.
And I can go ahead and comment
out some code here and run it.
And when I make that change, you
can see that within about a
second, it reflects that change
on the device.
That would have taken 15 seconds
without instant run.
I can also make some
incompatible changes, for
example, extracting this into a
method.
And making that change is
another second or two to deploy.
So after the demo, Stef is going
to talk more about what it is
we're doing next with instant
run with 2 and 3.
One of the things we had to
figure out with instant run is
figure out what's going on
inside the APK files.
So to do that, we built this new
feature the APKanalyzeer.
So I can open up any APK, or the
one in my project, and now I can
drill into what's going on in
the file.
So I can see, for example,
what's inside the assets folder
or the rest folder or in this
case instant run, the way we're
repackageing application into
slices.
So let me drag in a real
production app, the Chrome APK.
The purpose of this tool,
there's a couple things.
First one is to be able to look
at the download side.
So in some markets it's very
important that you make the
download small and install size
small.
So this lets you look at what is
actually in your app and focus
on whether you can get rid of it
it.
So I can drill into the assets
folder and look at the files.
I can look at the, let's say lay
layout folder.
We decompiled the binary XML
XML into source.
Although we can do a better job
with resource references.
So then we will map those into
resource names.
You can also look at the value
table which has been sort of an
opaque file to look at before.
Now I will have a viewer.
So you can go ahead and see just
what's inside.
And last but not least --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Yes.
And last but not least this lets
you look at the decks files.
So you're probably all aware of
the 64 K method limit.
Et's not actually method limit.
It's method plus reference limit
limit.
Now you can drill into it, what
is it you're declaring and what
it is it you're referencing so
you can get below that 64 K or
turn on multidecks.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
So if you ever looked at a
manifest file in the build
outputs, there's a lot of stuff
in the manifest file that you
did not right, write?
Where did it come from?
We have a new Ed to are in 2.2
the manifest editor.
This is the XML tab.
You can see there's now a merged
manifest tab.
And when I click on that, you
can see that we now give you a
full merge, updated live
whenever you make edits.
There's a legend on the right
which tells you where stuff is
coming from.
So, for example, I could see now
the permission --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
-- is coming from play services.
I can go in here and navigate to
the line that is the source for
the merge.
So hopefully that will help de
de demystify what's going on
with the manifest process.
Speaking of gradele.
We don't want you to have to
learn how to build if files in
order to complete your project.
We're in the rewrite middle of
the rewrite process.
All we've done is dependency,
though arguably it's probably
the hardest part.
So my favorite part if the new P
PSD is the messages Payne pane.
So what this shows me is
suggestions the ID is making.
You can see here my project
happens to be using Jcenter for
dependencyies.
They're saying hey, there's a
newer version of this dependency
available.
I click on this update link and
using the latest.
I can click update all to take
all suggestions.
This is not just looking at
local repositories for you.
It goes out and searches remote,
as well.
If I switch to the den dencyies
viewy can drill into the
dependencyies either by module
or I can look at the overall
dependencies for all nodules
across the project and I can
drill in and see, for example,
the transitive dependencies to
see basically how I'm reaching
certain dependencies in my
project.
I can also go and add
dependencies.
So we have a nice UI now where I
could go and search.
Again, just like with the up
updates, with the update
suggestions, this looks at
remote repositories.
It also looks at local
repositories.
It shows all the available
versions.
And it even helps me tweak the
scope string in the dependency
list.
So you can turn this on today in
the experimental settings if you
want to play with it and we'll
try to finish that in the next
couple of releases.
[Applause.]
Next let's talk about C++ so
last year we showed you that we
have really great editing
supports.
This is the Cline, C++
functionality from Jeff brain
stef stead.
And we integrated.
However it required the
experimental plug-in.
The big news for 2.2 is that we
now added support for external
build systems.
So you can actually use Cmick to
build your native code.
You just declare it like so with
a stable plug-in.
And now you can build C++.
And for C++, we will have the
wizard in the next couple of
builds, so you can very easily
go in and add C++ support to
your project.
And when you do that, you end up
with a sample project that looks
exactly like this one so you
have the main activity that
loads the native library and
then you have a sample hello
world native library string.
So let's set this up.
First of all set the breakpoint
here in the C++ code.
This main activity is just
showing the default layout that
has a string in the middle.
So let me go back and change
that string to show the value
from C++.
So we'll do text view.
Text view = find view by ID.
Then we'll hookup that ID.
We go to cast it.
And then we will call set text
on that text with the call from
C++.
Now let's also set a breakpoint
here.
So now I'm going to launch the
debugger, this front, which
builds everything, packages it.
And in a second, this app should
be running on the emulateor.
There it is.
We hit the break breakpoint.
We can be looking around at the
manifest state.
Activity state.
If I resume the debugger now.
You can see now we're in C++ and
I can drill around.
[Applause.]
So that's the hybrid debugger
and the Cmick support.
The last thing I'll show you in
the build system area is
something on the command line.
So let's say that you've gotten
the project from a co-worker or
maybe you did a Git pole poll.
And somebody changed something
on your project.
And then you build and you hit a
message like this one.
You don't have build tools 0221
Twhat you do is open STK manager
and install it.
Well, in 2.2 alpha1 we now have
an experimental flag you can set
set.
And when I run the build, if
I've already agreed to this
license, gradele will just go
and download it for me on the
fly as you can see right here.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
So that should also make
configureing continuing
integration servers a lot easier
easier.
Let's go to the extreme of
command line to visual editors.
So let's take a look at our new
layout editor.
Actually, I shouldn't call it
layout editor because it does
more than layouts.
So first of all, I can open up a
menu file.
Here's a menu.
I can drag and drop design menus
now.
We can also open up --
[Applause.]
Preference files and I can drag
and drop preference files.
Obviously there's component
spectre.
[Applause.]
>> Did a really nice job on this
this.
>> TOR NORBYE: Of course lay
layouts are a big part of this.
You can see component inspector
on the right.
You can see the important
attributes for the selected
component text view in this case
case.
So, for example, for text view,
we show you the text appearance.
Notice how there's some gray
text here in the component
inspector?
Even though I haven't set the
text appearance, we're showing
you what it actually is going to
be at run time so I can see the
font will be 14 SPes, for
example,.
If I switch to something else,
it will compute what that should
be.
Now, we only have a subset of
the properties here to make it
simple to find but if you need
anything else, the full set of
properties is just a full click
away up here.
So on the design surface, we
have blueprint mode.
So blueprint mode is basically
showing the structure.
It's like an extra of what your
app is doing.
I can have blueprint mode and
design mode on side by side.
One new thing we have which you
asked for is this is the scroll
view and I can scroll the design
surface directly.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Now, blueprint mode is
particularly useful for the new
constraint layout.
So let's take a look at
So first of all, I'm going turn
off auto connect mode.
So let's drag in some components
components.
So put a text view here.
We'll put an edit text.
Another text view.
And another password field,
maybe.
And then we'll add some buttons
on the bottom right.
So you can notice I'm being kind
of sloppy because after the fact
fact, I can go in and I can make
a selection.
I can right click and say hey, I
want to align these things on
the bottom.
I want to align all these things
on the left.
Maybe I also want to pack them
vertically
.
So here I have my design.
Now let's see what happens if I
go to landscape mode.
That's not good, right?
So I have buttons off screen.
So let's try to fix that.
So there's this little light
bulb icon for infer constraints.
Notice what happens when I click
it.
I now have these constraints
where it's tried to guess what
we probably mean here.
And when I try to resize this
now, you can see the buttons are
moving correctly.
[Applause.]
So, normally you're actually in
auto connect mode.
So if I want to drag in a button
here, you can see that the
second I drop it, it actually
goes and adds these constraints
for me.
And if I don't like them, of
course I can delete the
constraint by just clicking on
them.
I can also drag new constraints.
And we sort of show you preview
of what it's going to do when
you commit to it.
And the constraints can also
have strength.
So as I'm dragging, you could
see it auto snaps to a quarter
or specific percentage.
So someone asked yesterday if
this also works from XML editing
if that's what you prefer.
Yes it does.
Here we are in XML.
I can continue to play with the
constraints over here.
And you can see the XML Eddied
editing works very well.
[Applause.]
Thank you.
So this is a very powerful
constraint solveer.
And what that lets you do is
flatten your layout hierarchies
and that's very, very, very good
for performance.
So we've added a feature to help
jump start that.
So let me open this other layout
layout.
This one.
Let me switch to blueprint mode
so you could sort of see what's
going on.
So here's a layout that is
actually a set of nested linear
layouts.
And if I now go and say "convert
this linear layout to constraint
layout" it offers to flatten the
whole thing.
And as you can see, visually it
looks the same now except we
have constraints.
On the left you can see a single
flat list.
[Applause.]
Let's go look at editing.
So in Ted iting area we'veedded
ed
we've added a couple of
features.
First of all there's the
Firebase integration.
If you're trying to accomplish
something with Firebase, crash
reporting, open the assistant
window.
Pick the task you want to do.
For example, crash reporting.
You drill into this.
You can see you get this
step-by-step set of instructions
that sits next to your stores
editor.
If you, for example, see that
you want to perform these lines,
you can just drag it into your
source code to make that edit
for example.
If you are trying to figure out
how to use an API.
Let's say you heard you should
use the job scheduler.
Yes, you should use the job
scheduler, you could right click
on it and say find me some
sample code for this.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
So as you can see it basically
goes to the server and finds
recommended samples so that you
can then drill into and right
click and say open this in a
browseer and let me learn more
about this.
2.2 is based on IntelliJ 16.1 so
we have a number of new features
for that, as well.
So one thing we got is support
for editing bidirectional
strings.
So this is something our
international audience has been
asking for for a while.
So here we have some Arabic text
texts and you can see the source
editor is now more than happy to
handle this correctly.
I know this has been a big pain
point.
So finally we've got it, thank
you IntelliJ.
So IntelliJ 16 also comes with a
bunch of new inspection this is
the editors.
And on top of that, we've added
to a number of new inspections
that are Android-specific.
Let's take a look at those.
So first first of all, I hope
everybody knows that it's really
really, really bad practice to
solve the problem of passing
data from activities by makeing
your field static.
That's a no-no.
And now lint will flag it for
you.
Not just because it's a leak but
it makes instant run very happy
when you do this.
This is also not as simple as
just this case.
For example, we have if I make
these other fields here static,
app data 1 is no problem but app
data 2 turns out that one has
instant state that is a context
about you now there's a static
reference to it, which is bad.
[Applause.]
So let's look at some of the new
support and notations we
released the support library
yesterday and there's some new
good ones.
So first of all you can finally
say hey, this method even though
it's inside of a worker thread
class, this one is thread safe.
You can call it from any thread.
For a while we've had API check.
So lint will look at the
platform APIs and compare them
to your minute SDK.
We have a quick fix where you
can say okay, insert the check
for me.
However, what you can now do is
you can say, sorry.
You can say I expect my method
to require this API.
So you're passing on the
responsibility to call the API.
So you can now get API check for
your libraries to client.
So you can see now these other
calls even though they're
calling your API, it's the API
check is applied.
The next thing I will do is show
you the dimension resource.
The dimension antotation.
This one says this integer
represents.
There's various you can apply.
Pixel is important.
Most operate in pixel space so
we have a new annotation to say
just pixels.
So that's at PX.
When I do that, you can see
we're now flagging incorrect
usages where you're passing a
dimension resource that should
be a dimension.
So hopefully that will be useful
useful.
And the last annotation I want
to highlight is the keep Anno
Annotation.
So you can do keep on your
classes.
[Applause.]
Yes.
So as of gradele plug in 2.2 we
now automatically make sure if
you use pro guard or the new
incremental shrinker, these
methods will not be reproved
removed at release time.
So if you like the support anno
annotations, we have a feature
that I think will make them even
more useful to you.
That's the new inference.
So IntelliJ has for a while had
this analysis action to infer
nullity.
Well we have a new feature, it's
behind a flag, you can try it if
you want torques support refer
annotations.
So when I run this on the
current file, it does a bunch of
alliances to figure out a lot of
new annotations based on usage
in your project.
So if I go back into my file
here, all the new dif annotation
dif annotations, that will
hopefully jump start annotations
and help lint find more bugs in
your code we have auto e we've
also been collaborateing with a
research team at Oregon state to
work on permissions.
So this is still a work in
progress.
But when this is done, this will
let you migrate your app to
enter and end permissions.
So here I can invoke this action
action.
It'll help me perform the right
requests and handle callbacks
for enter and permissions.
[Applause.]
We also have a refactoring to
remove unused resources.
So if I add some resources that
aren't actually used, I can now
just go to retrackry menu and
say remove unused resources.
And the IDE will find them and
nuke them for you, which helps
make your app leaner.
[Applause.]
All right.
So now last thing I'm going to
show you is the Espresso test
recorder.
I'm hearing oo in the audience.
[Laughter]
So to do that, all I have to do
is go into my project and go to
the run menu and say "record
Espresso test" notice it's
Espresso not expresso.
And so when I do that, you can
see that it actually builds the
app.
And it starts this event
recorder on the left here.
And on the right, we have our
app running.
So now I can, for example, go
and click on this category over
here.
And you can see it records an
event for that.
I can click on on the back
button.
And then I can go down and let's
say click on the music tile.
Notice as I'm clicking it's
recording the events over here
and it tries to make sense of
what it is I'm clicking.
For example, when I click on the
are red button, it's recording
that I clicked the fab quiz
button.
So another cool thing I can do
while I'm recording.
I can add assertions.
So I'm going click on the add
assertion button here.
And it's now pulling down a
screen shot in view hierarchy of
what's going on in the app.
And I can now, you can see I can
move around in the logical
structure of the app.
And if I click, for example, on
the question who was the
youngest beatle, it pulls it
down and suggests an assertion
which is hey, at this point,
when the Tess is the running, we
expect this search to be who was
the youngest beatle.
[Applause.]
So then I press save assertion
and I keep going.
So does anyone, I'm going click
some wrong answers until you
stop me.
So, still wrong.
Still wrong.
George is right.
And I'm going to finally click
on the submit button.
And you can see that that was
the correct answer.
And I think that's probably good
enough for the test recording
part.
So now I'm going to say complete
recording.
When I do that, it's asking me
what class I want to save the
test as.
Accept the default.
And here we have our Espresso
test.
So notice that I clicked some
wrong stuff in the beginning.
I can now edit this Tess if the
I want.
For example, I can take out the
clicking the wrong tile and
going back.
And then I can run the test.
So let's do that.
So all I have to do is click on
this run button right here.
EnAnd you can actually do cloud
testing, as well.
I don't have time to show it.
But you can sign up for that and
then it will run your UI test
across a number of different
harbor form factors which is
pretty useful.
So let's just run this on the
emulateor again.
So it will build the tests,
deploy and let's look over on
the right here when the app
starts running because it can
click faster than I can.
Installing APK.
Here we go.
Click.
And we have our green pass.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So with that, I'm going to turn
it back over to jammal Jamal who
will be talking about the visual
editors.
[Applause.]
>> JAMAL EASON: So thanks, Tor.
Great demo.
So what Tor showed you is what
we're doing.
I'm going to spend a little bit
of time talking about why we're
doing it and why you might want
to implement it into your work
flow.
So for design, we're thinking
about two main topics.
XML and layouts.
So for comvment ML for XML.
I know a few of you enjoy your
entire in XML.
That's great.
But for me and many others, it's
good to have some visualization
tool to allow you to see how
your app's going to render.
Our team set a goal for
ourselves thinking is it
possible for us to create tool
where no XML is is required?
You can look at it afterwards
but it shouldn't be in the way
to get your job done.
So that was the reason behind
the new layout editor.
As Tor showed, you have a whole
host of new features, including
ways to drag widgets onto the
componentry onto the design
surface or the new blueprint
mode that allows you to peer
behind to see how all the
widgets are together.
And the new properties panel.
In the past it showed all the
different that are available for
view.
Now we cureated those to show
the most impactful ones to use
for your new view layout.
The second is layouts.
So for enter layouts a couple
different.
You have linear layout,
horizontal and linear.
But then you're thinking well
perhaps I need to use the frame
layout or the table layout.
That's not going to work,
actually.
Let's think about using the grid
layout or the relative layout.
Wait.
So which one should we use here?
That's the problem we're trying
to think about because many
times we're thinking about
should I use, which container
should I use for my layouts?
So the constraint layout is the
solution for this problem where
you c think less about the
container and more about the
content and how you lay out your
widgets on your layouts.
So let's talk about why you
might want to use the constraint
layout.
So number 1, it's fast UI
UI development.
As you saw in the demo, we can
actually add widgets pretty
quickly and connect all the
different constraints.
While it's also very important
to think about is that this
helps you have more responsive
design.
Instead of thinking about how
has my screen stood on Nexus 4
or tablet or Nexus 6 device, we
can create constraints which
allows you to respond your
content based on the screen size
size.
And the third most important
aspect is performance.
SoSo as you saw in the
demonstration, we can now flat
flatten your hierarchy for you.
If you didn't know, if you put a
relative layout underneath
another relative layout, that is
slower for the Android operating
system to process.
So all that Nesting can be now
flattened with a new constraint
layout.
And,  lastly, it's backwards
compatible, which means you can
use it obviously for new
projects, but it's a support
library that allows you to use
it for existing projects, as
well.
[Applause.]
And so the third tool that we
demonstrated around design is
the layout instructor.
So sometimes when you're loading
your application, you're
wondering well why is my view
overlapping?
Or perhaps why is one of my
attributes not what I expected
it to be?
So what you can do now with our
roolz is right click and take a
snapshot of your current layout
and visually inspect all
different attributes and look at
the entire view hierarchy of
your layout.
That should be very helpful in
debugging.
Now spend a little bit of time
talking about develop and what
tools we've enabled to help you
with that.
So as we showed in the demo, we
have now a new Firebase plug in.
And this supports a new Firebase
services that we launched
yesterday at Google I/O.
And you can now add things like
Google analytics, adds, client
messaging all in a click of a
button in inside of Android
studio 2.0.
The other cool thing we talked
about is the samples browseer.
And as demonstrated, if you're
looking for an exam of how to
use something, now we provide
the power of all the Google
samples at the click of a button
to make it easier for you to now
look and have a good starting
point for your application
development.
And now with that, I'd like to
talk a little bit about the
build tools and I'll invited
Stef to talk about those new
changes.
[Applause.]
>> STEPHANIE CUTHBERTSON:
Thanks very much, Jamal.
For build, I want to start by
talking about instant run.
Now, as a developer, I think one
of the best feelings in the
world is being in the flow.
And one of our goals for Android
is to make Android development
feel as lightweight as web
development.
So you can make your code
changes and then see them
essentially refresh so that you
can really stay in the flow as
you're coding.
That's why we built instant run.
So I want to talk a little bit
first about how it works.
The IDE swaps your changes in
one of three ways.
For incremental changes, we do
the fastest swap, which is
called a hot swap.
And here what we do is we
instrument your bite code on the
first build and then after that
when you make changes, we just
redirect the code path to pick
up the changed code.
The second type of swap is a
warm swap.
And that's when we need to do an
activity restart.
So that's what you need whenever
you're going to do for instance
resource changes.
Cold swaps are when we need to
restart the app.
And that's required when you do
structural changes.
So examples much those would be
changes to inheritance or if you
change your method signature.
So what I'd like to do is backup
and unpack a little bit some of
the benchmarks that we talked
about yesterday in the keynote.
We benchmarked using a wide
range of different applications
and different tools.
I won't take you through all of
it.
Just one example.
We benchmark with the Wikipedia
app.
It's an open source app.
You can get it on Github.
And I posted here all of our
criteria in case it's
interesting to repeat them.
What you'll notice is that we
benchmark against 2.0 with
instant run disabled.
And you can see in 2.1 with cold
swap it's 4.7 times faster and
hot swap is 10.7 times faster.
Now, what that means if you
think about it is our build
speeds are actually faster than
10 X because we're benchmarking
against 2.0.
And 2.0's faster than 1.5
because of changes we made in
decks.
And we also made ADB push speeds
10 times faster.
So we're underselling a little
bit, but what we care about most
is really that you guys are
getting super fast builds and so
that's what we focused on.
And this gives us a nice apples
to apples comparison in our own
benchmarks.
Let me talk about another type
of benchmarking we do.
So we look at the user stats for
users who opt in.
And we instrument in a bunch of
different very cool ways.
So for all of you guys who opt
in, thank you.
This is an example of a stat we
look at.
This is average run time,
average build time for instant
run on hot swap.
And this is showing across all
users.
So this is worldwide.
All operating systems.
All countries.
All hardware.
And that includes very old
hardware with slow processors
and things of that nature.
What you can see is that most
users are seeing hot swap happen
in 4 to 5 seconds or less.
And our goal is always to push
that graph over.
We're trying to make as possible
as possible this happen one
second.  So what we look for is
we're trying to figure out how
do we drive full build speeds
down, how do we make hot swaps
faster, and how do we make as
possible swaps as possible be
hot swaps?
So we look at things like this.
We look at the distribution of
hot swaps, warm swaps and cold
swaps and full build times as
well as what's causing cold
swaps to happen.
And it was looking at that
instrumentation, really, all of
your wonderful data, that gave
us the clue for one of the big
changes you'll see in 2.2.
So 2.2 includes a change to AAPT
AAPT.
A lot of you guys know when you
change your resource, AAPT
AAPT inserts an ID in the
manifest.
Now, what you may not know and
what we didn't know is that if
you change your resource or add
a new one, AAPT was renumbering
those IDs.
So the impact is you make a code
change but you would get a cold
swap.
We identified this was driving
about, I call it 16 to
19 percent of our cold swaps.
So with 2.2, we've changed AAPT.
So it hold all the resource IDs
constant.
So I'm kind of taking you guys
on an insider view of what will
just occur to you in 2.2 as an
acceleration and instant run
because you will see a lot more
hot swaps.
Another change we made is we're
taking advantage of split APK.
So now when you build, we'll
break your app into about 11 to
12 decks files.
And when you do a full build,
we'll actually only rebuild the
changed code.
We plan to keep driving build
speeds down in multiple
successive releases, not 2.2.
So if any of you guys are seeing
still slow build speeds, the
engineering team would really
appreciate it if you come find
us.
Let me talk next about project
structure.
Now, Tor already gave a
wonderful demo.
So I'm just going to give you
guys the insiders look.
Underneath the project structure
dialogue is some very
interesting changes to the grade
gradele build model.
Now gradele has been wonderful
for us.
It's a very flexible language,
very powerful for Android.
But let's think about it.
An IDE expects structured inputs
and gradele is a programming
Lange language.
So that's pretty complex.
One of the changes we made in
2.2 is we completely rewrote the
gradele parseer from the bottom
up.
So what that means is we're now
much more accurate when we read
in gradele files.
And we're also much more
accurate in the IDE when we
write them back out.
So an example of what you'll see
is, for instance, if you write
variables into your gradele file
file, we will now read those
correctly in the IDE.
And in the future, in the
project structure dialogue,
you'll be able to modify those
in the UI, as well.
[Applause.]
The gradele rewrite of the model
is done already in 2.2.
As Tor mentioned, the project
structure dialogue is partially
complete in 2.2 and you'll be
able to try it under an
experimental flag.
We plan to complete it in 2.3
and at that point it will become
the default.
This is scwhrussate nice screen
shot of the merged manifest
viewer which Tor also showed.
For time I want to skip ahead
and talk a little bit about jack
jack.
Now, the Jack compiler was
integrated with gradele in 2.1.
And in 2.2 we now include anno
annotation processing.
So you can now use annotation
processors on your class pass.
[Applause.]
So this would include such an
dependency and they will be
applied.
Details how to use this is in
our Docs.
One.  Things I wanted to call
out here in I/O is if you're
swhoin is writing tools and
doing preor post processing on
class files, one of the very
nice things about jack is that
it has a structured API for
manipulations.
Now we are going to be looking
to move more and more to Jack in
coming releases.
So please do try this out and
let us know if there's anything
that's missing for you.
Our last topic will be C++
support.
And for this I'm going give you
guys the whole arc of what we're
doing.
I think it's a nice way to just
understand C++ from end-to-end.
The reason we're investing so
much is because we know there's
a lot of you who are doing very
graphics-rich apps and games.
And you've talked to us and told
us that C++ is critical.
We already support C++ editing
and debugging.
And all of that is coming
through IntelliJ.
So one of the new things you're
going to get with 206.1 is also
IntelliJ's improved for C++.
The biggest change you'll see is
Cmick and gradele.
Let me walk through a CMake
example.
You can now reference a CMake
project in your gradele file.
This will build your SO files so
they're packages packaged in the
APK.
How it works is gradele now
shells out to CMake.
And we're getting CMake to admit
more metadata about the project
itself, both how to build it and
what files are in the project.
So that's how, as Tor was
showing you, you're able to see
the cpp files show up in the
project hierarchy and your dot H
dot H files, as well, if those
are in the same folder.
The files themselves will show
up in a note in the project
hierarchy, as well, under
external build file so you can
edit those, as well, from the ID
IDE.
You can run the app, set a
breakpoint.
It will all work as expected.
Setting up NDKBuild works the
same way so you can reference an
Android.mk file from your build.
I'd also like to give you guys a
brief tour of the C++ debugger
enhancements.
So, first, in 2.2 as we
mentioned, you no longer have to
explicitly choose the C++, Java
or hybrid debugger.
You can just use auto and the ID
IDE will automatically select
the right debugger for you.
If you're debugging an N, you
can actually use one single
debugger for Java and C++.
And then a final thing we added
is Watchpoints.
So you can add a variable and
you can freeze the process if
those are read or if they're
modified.
Watchpoints can be used on X86
and Nexus 9.
We're planning to bring more
devices online.
For now, a great way if you want
to try them is to try them out
with our emulateors.
We also fixed several
compatibility issues with
Samsung, S5 and S6 devices.
So that covers C++ and 2.2 and
you should expect to continue to
see enhancements in coming
releases.
The last area we'd like to talk
about is testing.
And so with that, I would love
to bring Jamal back.
Thank youThank you, guys, very
much.
[Applause.]
>> JAMAL EASON: So for testing,
a core feature you need is a
local testing environment.
So we're really excited that we
launched the Android emulator
earlier this year.  If you
haven't tried it, it's a great
tool.
What's great about it is it's
improved the CPU, GPU and IO
IOspeeds so it's even faster
than a device we improved the AD
ADB speeds.
Believe it or not the
bottlenecks between you pushing
your assets in your application
is is ADB.
So that's actually now 10 times
fast we are the new Android
emulator.
We have the new UI.
We do things like rotate, take
screen shots but extended UI, as
well which allows you to control
sensors like taking location.
Makeing phone calls.
All tools allowing you to test
your application.
[Applause.]
So in addition to the local
testing, we also launched the
Firebase test lab inside Android
studio.
So if you click on that cloud
tab that Tor showed in the demo,
it allows you to choose devices
in the cloud.
And now you can run the device
that you may not own and try and
simulate STK to help you test
your application.
And as I showed earlier, we have
the Espresso test recorder.
That's a very cool demo.
Why this is very important is we
found that making tests can be
tedious.
And sometimes not all people
like to do it.
So now you can click on your
device.
We can capture all those tests
and you can now upload those to
the test lab or run them locally
on your machine.
And,  lastly, we talked about
the APX analyzeer.
Again why this is very important
is because sometimes you think
you're done.
You built your application.
And the APK is too big.
Because at the end of the day,
the users that download the
application on Google Play wants
the smallest possible.
This allows you to look into the
APK, your assets and figure out
what might be the problem of why
my APK is large.
The next time we don't have time
to work at every single feature.
IntelyIntelliJ.
We made a big for accessible
accessibility.
This is what we added into
Android 2.2.
So just to recap.
We launched a whole host of
features around design.
A new constraint layout manager
and chorus line designer.
New Firebase integration to help
you code better, enhanced C++
support, build support, and a
test recorder to help you test.
And how to get started.
All you have to do if you're
using and dried studio 2.2 today
today, check for updates and
prompt to the Android 2.2 in the
Canary channel.
And if you're not using Android
studio, anyone?
Let's go to this link here and
download a fresh copy.
And again change the channel to
the Canary channel to download
Android studio 2.2.
And that's it.
Thank you so much.
[Applause.]
[Music.]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Good morning, everybody.
Hi, I'm Ellie Powers and I'm a
product manager here on the
Google Play team.
We have so many different
announcements about what's new
for all of you app developers on
Google Play
that we had to
create one session with a whole
bunch of people to take you
through all of them.
But before we get into that, I
want to take a couple minutes to
talk to you more about why I'm
really excited to work on Google
Play.
I've been on the team for about
4-1/2 years.
And one of the things that
really gets me excited even now
is really meeting each of you
and hearing your stories for
every app and game on the Google
Play store, there's a real story
behind it.
You know, I love hearing "how
did you come up with that idea
for that newer app or game"?
What's really special about it
to you?
And I love trying out all the
different apps and seeing how
they work.
And I love hearing about what
happens after you launch your
app, how it's helping you build
a business and how you're using
that app to really transform
people's lives.
So, before we see what's new in
Google Play, we're going to see
a video and take a look at some
of your stories.
Let's play the video.
[Music.]
>> I started running in marathon
marathons to raise money for
Parkinson's research in honor of
my grandfather.
I always had this idea that if I
could get enough people together
together, then collectively we
would have the clout of a
celebrity and then companies
would want to sponsor us.
>> Being on the Android platform
has enabled us to reach people
all over the world.
They can help raise money for
our charity partners and it's
helped make our movement a
global one.
>> It's been cool to take your
hobby and put it into your
full-time job.
Talk is an Android app that
allows you to see all the
sensors on your vehicle and to
look at the codes.
From the way it's happened on
the Google Play store I've
touched over a million people
with the app.
The community's drag gd me along
with it and told me what they
want.
I've done that for them.
I'm very grateful for where I am
now.
And it's staggering to see that
something I've written for from
my garden shed is liked by that
many people across the planet.
>> It started right after
university.
It was myself, my husband and
his brother.
Making games was our childhood
dream and this is what we wanted
do.
Since we released cooking fever
on Android, it totally clicked.
We realized that this is the way
to go.
And this is the platform of the
future.
We had millions of downloads
within the first months.
When we started, it was just
three of us and now we're a
company of over 100 people
making games that we decide we
want to make.
This has been very successful
dream.
[Music.]
[Applause.]
>> ELLIE POWERS: I really love
watching this video because it
really shows the different
developers we have in the
Android and Google Play
community.
So now let's get on with what's
new on Google Play this year.
Here at Google we found that we
build the best products we're
able to launch and iterate our
products using user feedback,
products like Gmail, Chrome,
maps and Google search are all
great examples of how we've
about enable to do this.
And we want app developers like
you to be able to do the same
things.
So, Google Play has been giving
all of you the biggest user base
base, right?
Access to a very wide range of
people all around the world.
But now it's also become the
best place to optimize your apps
to take on user feedback and to
measure how your app is doing
and to make those little tweaks
to make your app truly great.
So, imagine that I brought a big
team of people to help me
deliver these announcements.
So lightning talk style we're
going to bring each of them on
to share something new on Google
Play with you.
And with that, I'd like to bring
out our engineering director,
Miles Barr.
[Applause.]
>> MILES BARR: Hi.
I'm Miles Barr.
I'm here today to talk to you
about the prelaunch report.
It's an exciting new feature
that we launched at Google I/O
this year.
The prelaunch report is built on
the Firebase test lab.
The Firebase test lab is our
data center of real Android
devices where you can test your
app.
It allows you to test your app
across a variety of devices,
Android versions and languages.
It's already performed over
1 million tests for developers
like you.
You can run your own custom
tests straight from Android
studio or from the Firebase
console.
Beta testing has always been one
of the most popular and powerful
features but we wanted to make
it even better by performing a
comprehensive set of tests on
your app before it goes live.
You can now opt in to generating
a prelaunch report for every APK
APK you upload to the alpha and
beta channels to Google Play.
Releasing a new version of your
app can be an exciting time you
want to make sure everything
goes right.
After about an hour you'll get a
report summarizing any issues we
found when testing your app.
The first thing we look at is
the stability of your app.
We use the Firebase test lab to
run your app on real devices,
telling you on which devices
your app crashed on startup or
if it crashes off a deeper crol
of the April.
This means it won't be the users
finding the crashes and giving
you 1 star reviews.
We also show you what your app
looks like on these different
devices.
You get to see how it looks like
in different screen resolutions,
Android OS versions and
languages.
In allows you to spot any
problems, such as overflowing
text in your translations before
your app goes live, allowing you
to fix them quickly and easily.
The final part of the report
highlights any security
vulnerabilities we find.
This includes any versions of
third-party lie brer whiz known
vulnerabilityies or if you've
accidentally followed any
security anti-patterns.
Previously this information was
only available after your app's
gone live.
The prelaunch report brings all
this information together,
telling you about these
potential issues, allowing you
to fix them before your April
goes to production, ensureing
that you and Google Play give
your users the best experience
possible.
Now, I'd like to bring on stage
Kobi Glick, product manager for
Google Play.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
>> KOBI GLICK:,000, miles.
Hi, I want to talk to you about
beta testing.
Beta testing is the most popular
feature on the Google Play
developer console.
60 percent of the top 1,000 apps
on Google Play are running a
beta test right now.
And users notice it.
After trying the beta test have
higher rating on average.
Last year we made it easier for
users to discover and join beta
programs.
With open beta, it's as simple
as clicking a URL.
We know that you love and use
beta testing and we also get
feedback like you the one you
see from Pocket how beta testing
allows them to connect to their
users, get feedback on new ideas
and make sure the app is ready
to go to production.
To make it even easier for users
to discover and join beta
programs, we will allow users to
join them directly from your
stories theing page on Google
Play.
This will help you grow larger
beta programs and connect to
more testers.
Now, once you have beta testers
you want to get their feedback,
right?
You used to get the feedback
from various so forth and had to
parse a lot of information.
We will allow users to give you
private feedback directly for
Google Play.
This feedback is private.
It goes only to you and you can
see it in the Google Play
developer console.
Private means other users don't
get to see it and it doesn't
impact your app star rating.
Now, we believe that apps should
run in open beta test even
before they go to production.
This is why we're introducing a
new section called early access
on Google Play.
This section will feature
exciting apps and games that are
still in development or running
a beta test and haven't launched
to production yet.
This will allow early adopters
and influenceers to discover
those apps, try them out and
give you valuable feedback, help
helping you find product market
earlier and find you in your
games APIs.
In our first collection, we have
28 apps and games, as you can
see here.
With some pretty cool titles.
For example, read feed, an
Android first online book club.
Or Eva, the founder whose
parents and sisters are deaf,
created this app to help deaf
people and people with hearing
disabilities to participate in
real life conversations.
We have Lego, the kids and
family power brand with the
first-ever in-house mobile game.
It's a 3-D Lego set you can
touch, twist and build just like
the brick sets we all grew up
with.
This is not just for free to
play tiles.
They have ear loan and gorgeous
game evolved by lie media who
researched together with the
Alaska Nateives is coming to
Google Play on early access as a
premium title.
We are sure that those changes
that we're making to beta
testing will help you grow even
bigger beta programs, get
feedback from users, and make
your AP staff and games even
more -- apps and games even more
awesome.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
I'd like to invited invite Wei
Chai, a manager in Google Play.
[Applause.]
>> WEI CHAI: Thank you.
Hi.
I'm here to talk about some new
feature for play apps discovery.
Google Play is the primary
destination for discovering apps
and games on Android.
Today, we provide various ways
in the store to assist users in
finding new apps and to drive
developer outcomes by helping
you get discovered.
Recently, we've been developing
and experimenting with a new way
for users to find new apps,
contextual app discovery.
It targets underlying needs that
drive when and why you might
need new apps.
This could be the ones in our
everyday life such as learn
something new, plan a vacation
or eat at home.
Our users study show that most
users look for new apps at the
time they need them.
Therefore, we want to explicitly
target the needs by building
contextual collections of apps
so that users can find
complementary apps needed at the
same time.
It also makes it easier for
users to find apps or types of
apps. they may not have heard of
before coming to play.
For example, imagine a user is
searching for wallpaper or might
recognize user is interested in
a broader need, personalize my
phone, and show complimentary
apps, including not only
wallpapers but also personalize
able keyboards, themes and ring
tones.
Similarly, -- oh, let's take a
look how it works.
We identify the underlying needs
based on user searches, views,
contests and interests and show
complimentary apps around the
need on such result pages as
install pages or home pages
where it makes sense to do so.
So another example.
If the user is at app install
page for Trulia, maybe he or she
is buying a house and we'll show
great other apps for finding
houses for sale, calculating
your mortgage, and doing
interior design.
If a user is traveling to San
Francisco, we might anticipate
the user's needs for apps for up
upcoming trip and show a
collection of relevant apps for
exploring San Francisco on the
user's home page.
To further demonstrate the idea,
if you look at your play store
home page now, for some of you
based on your interest and
context we are showing a
collection of apps called best
of Google I/O where you can find
nominees of this year's Google
Play awards.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
Now I would like to introduce
Fergus Hurley, product manager
of Google Play.
>> FERGUS HURLEY: Thanks, Wei.
Hi, everyone, my name is Fergus
Hurley, I'm protect product
manager in Google Play I'm here
to talk about reviews.
So, building on top of the
phenomenal engagement developers
have had with the reply to
review functionality, we made a
lot of changes on functionality
and play over the last few
months.
We've added being able to see
your ratings over time, be able
to see ratings breakdown across
country, language, device.
Be able to see the device
metadata for each individual
review so you would be able to
understand what was the ram of
that user on that device?
And even be able to search
within all the reviews.
We've also enabled you to be
able to now get an email
notification when user updates
their review after you've
responded.
We also added highlights.
These are snippets that users
see when they come to your app
listing page on the play store.
And they can be able to see
these to be able to make their
purchase decision.
You will be able to see them in
the play developer console and
you will be able to figure out
which ones are the ones you want
to be able to invest in more and
be able to respond to the
reviews that are happening in
those highlights.
This year at I/O we announced
reviews analysis.
Two parts.
First part is topics.
Topics are unique words that are
relevant to your application.
And we surface them, for
example, for this language
learning app, cling on is thetic
the  the top topic.
You can see there's a volume
distribution for each of these
topics.
We even tell you what is the
effect that each one of these is
having on your overall rating in
the play store.
The next part of the reviews
analysis is benchmarks.
Benchmarks shows you what are
the common topics that people
talk about, your application,
and nearly all other
applications on the play store.
You can be able to see design,
stability, resource usage.
And then you can be able to see
how you compare to the other
apps in your category in the
play store.
We also show you what is the
effect that each one of these
common topics is having on your
rating in the play store.
So you would be able to
prioritize your investment of
your resources and even have
your team be able to go in and
be able to read all the reviews
about design.
For now, reviews analysis works
for English-only.
And only when you have a certain
number of reviews that fall
within these categories.
So, when we have all these
reviews on the play store and we
have this ability to be able to
do reviews analysis on all the
reviews, we said let's have a
look at all the reviews and say
what are all the common topics
that are impacting one star and
five star reviews so they can
get a higher rating on Play?
We found across all the one star
reviews that have a common topic
topic, 50 percent are about
stability.
So really investing in building
a high quality app that does not
crash is really important.
We also found that for when you
want to get your app to 5 star
app and you fix the stability
issues, really investing in
design, performance and
usability and speed of your
application is really, really
important because that results
in 65 percent of the 5 star
reviews.
We also launched at I/O this
year the reviews APIthis enables
you to be able to respond to
your reviews on the play store
with whatever work flow you use
yourself to be able to do
customer support.
We partnered with Zen desk and
conference social on this and
you can launch those tools today
to be to start responding to
your play store reviews.
Now I'm going hand it over to
Riccardo Govoni who is the
engineering manager on Play.
[Applause.]
>> RICCARDO GOVONI: Hello.
So today I'm here to give you
tips on how you can better
understand who your users are
and where they come from.
You're probably familiar with
user acquisition report that we
launched in the play developer
console last year that tells you
how many visitors installed your
app and converted into buyers.
And it does so by breaking the
information down by acquisition
channel.
So you know how many people
discovered your app organic in
the play store versus coming
from different channels like
your website or AdWords
campaigns.
Over the past year we received
great feedback about this
feature, like this one from
Trulia.
And it helped many developers
like you optimize your business
in Play.
So you'll be happy to hear that
we recently announce ad new
feature being able to measure
your user acquisition
performance at the country level
level.
And this is great when you're
entering new markets like
emerging ones like Brazil or
India and really optimize your
app experience for all your
users across the world.
But optimizing your business
performance in isolation is not
really that helpful.
How do you know, for example, if
you look at your organic
conversion rate if it is as good
as it could be?
If you're leaving opportunities
on the table.
So right now it's not that easy.
But we're about to make it a lot
better.
So, soon, we will be launching
another great feature,
benchmarks against your peers.
So you will be able to compare
how your listing conversion rate
is against similar apps in your
category.
First, we'll provide an overall
benchmark about your organic
user acquisition performance.
And this will give you an
indication on how your tool
listing is performing globally.
But, more, you will be also able
to measure your user acquisition
performance at the country level
against the benchmark at that
level.
For example, here you can see
that our app is getting some
traction in Korea, but at
24 percent, we are lagging
behind the benchmark.
This is a moment where maybe you
want to review the quality of
your listing translations or
consider localizeing your assets
.
We'll also give you an
indication on how you're
progressing against the
benchmark so you know if you
still have room for improvement
or if you're really aMong the
best and aim for the top.
And when you're ready to take
action, play developer console
has plenty of features to help
you optimize your tool listing
performance and your original
success such as tool listing
experiments and we'll offer
experiences about those right
next to the benchmarking results
when relevant.
So this is everything I have for
you today.
I believe that we've with
counter, and with benchmarks you
will be able to -- benchmarks
will roll Ucountry breakdowns is
already there.
Benchmarks will roll out in a
couple weeks.
I want to introduce Mona Mona
Vajolahni.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
>> MONA VAJOLAHNI: Thanks,ry
Ricardo.
I'm here to talk about what
we're doing in Google Play for
the next billion users.
Android is growing really fast
in emerging markets.
By 2018, we expect 1.2 billion
new Android users to come online
in emerging markets.
In Google Play, we have been
working really hard to make sure
those users have a great
experience, especially given
some of the infrastructure
challenges in those markets.
One key pillar is to have a
product and an ecosystem of apps
that work well on slow
connections and on low end
devices.
Our user studies have shown over
and over again that connectivity
and data challenges affect all
users in emerging markets
regardless of where they live or
how much money they make.
Connectivity challenges are here
to stay.
By 2020, still 300 million users
in India will be on connection
times that are equivalent of 2 G
G.
And even then when WiFi is
available, it's often patchy and
unreliable unreliable.
So one of the key areas of focus
for us in Google Play has been
to build an experience that is
fast, lightweight and reliable
where every user, regardless of
their connection type, can find
and download apps that meet
their needs.
Over the past year, we have
optimized the performance of the
play store app and they did much
faster on 2 G.
We have also reduced the amount
of data used by the store itself
for key activities like
downloading apps and uploading
apps.
These changes have brought more
users to the store.
They visit the store more often.
And they download more apps.
We also know that our users
everywhere, especially in
emerging markets, want to store
experience that reflect the
local interest and the needs of
their country and their region.
We've been working closely with
local developers in markets like
India and Brazil to make sure
those apps reach their local
audience in the store.
In addition, we have been super
charging our editorial content
in the store to make sure users
are able to easily find locally
relevant apps that meet the
needs of different segments of
user in the market.
And with that, I'd like to bring
up to stage.
>> KUNAL SONI: Who is the head
of business games in southeast
Asia.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
>> KUNAL SONI: Thanks, Mona.
Hi, everyone, I'm her to talk to
you about creating great quality
apps that will work effectively
not just for smartphone users
today but also for the next
billion users as they get
connected in the years to come.
We were seeing incredible
momentum in emerging markets all
around the world.
They're expected to account for
80 percent of total smartphone
growth globally.
In order to be relevant and
successful in these markets,
it's important for us to design
the right app experience aimed
at solving three important
challenges.
Firstly
, while 4 G and LT
LTspevment and other network
technologies will grow fast,
they will still be 1 billion
mobile Internet users in 2020
who will be on 2 G.
That's a sizable segment for you
to think about and solve for.
Secondly, mobile data speeds
vary a lot across markets,
requiring you to tailor the app
experience accordingly.
And, finally, data is expensive
relative to income levels in
several markets.
And therefore helping your users
manage their data costs should
be an important priority.
In order to help you tackle
these challenges and support
your growth, we've identified a
set of tools and best practices
that we believe can help you.
This is what is called the
building for billions framework
focused on three important areas
areas:  Connectivity, device
compatibility, and data cost.
By the way, what I'm covering
here is by no means limited to
emerging markets.
These principles will apply
equally well across the world.
Let's start by looking at
connectivity.
In order to optimize for un
unreliable or intermittent
connectivity, ensure that your
app prioritizes bandwidth
requests, fetching text before
rich media or data.
Ensure that you offer a great
offline experience so that all
your users can interact with the
app at all times regardless of a
connectivity using cacheed data.
Let's talk about devices.
Many devices in emerging markets
have smaller, lower resolution
screens.
In order to ensure a seamless
user experience across devices,
use density independent pixels
while defineing app layouts.
Ensure that your graphics and
text work well on low and medium
density screens.
And adjust your memory for print
dynamically to ensure
compatibility across devices
with different ram
configurations.
Finally, let's talk about data
costs.
The first cost your users will
incur will be related to the
cost of installation of your app
app.
And, therefore, it's important
to keep a tight focus on
reducing the AP gate size.
Ideally well below 10 megabytes.
In order to accomplish this, you
should reduce the number and
size of images within the APK
APK using tools like web P and
scalable vector graphics or SVG.
You can shrink the code size of
APK using tools such as pro
guard which removes unused code.
And, finally, you can consider
multiAPK as an option to create
create APKs split by density so
that users target the right
version of the app that
specifically targets their
device density.
With that, we come to the end of
my session.
If you're interested to know
more, do join us for the session
on building for billions in
Android today at 3 p.m.
Next, I'd like to invite Milena
Nikolic, manager on Google Play.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
>> MILENA NIKOLIC: Thanks, cun
cunnal cun cunnal  Kunal.
I'm here to talk to you about
play console app.
Yes, we have finally launched an
Android app for Google Play
console.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
We have to admit that it took us
a while.
It took us much longer than it
took you guys.
But we've made it.
And we can tell you this app
stuff is pretty sweet.
We really like it now.
Our new app can help you follow
the performance of your app on
Google Play and do time critical
actions on the go.
When you're rapidly iterating,
you need a powerful tool that's
in your pocket all the time.
And we've built play console app
exactly with those use cases in
mind.
Whether you're looking to
quickly reply to user review or
to show off the performance of
your app when running to a
meeting, play console app should
be there to support you.
Regarding an initial feature set
set, obviously you can check
installs and uninstalled of your
app and you can break them down
based on the number of different
dimensions including country,
device, app version and much
more.
In addition to that, you can
check out crash reports,
including hourly data and full
stack races.
You can also follow your app's
ratings and reviews and you can
reply to reviews.
You can also follow the state of
your release as it moves from
beta through stage rollout all
the way to production and much
more.
Oh, also you can get push
notifications when something
important happens with your app.
For example, when your app
update goes live.
App is now available in Google
Play Nthe last 24 hours since we
launched it, more than 10,000
developers installed it and
rated it at
4.85 stars on
average.
If you're not among those 10,000
developers, please go and
install it.
We think you'll find it very use
useful.
Also, we are very keen to hear
your feedback, so please send us
any feedback that you have.
We plan to work on it.
We plan to add much more
functionality in the next couple
of versions.
And if you're still not
convinced, please do come visit
us in the play sandbox where you
can see it in action for
yourself.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
Next I would like to invite sure
sure sure and Shobani Ravi.
>> Thanks, Milena.
We showed you the keynote
yesterday.
Today I want to talk to you
about how to build Android
instant apps and the new
opportunities this could open up
up.
First, let's do a quick recap of
the announcement yesterday for
those of you who weren't around.
So, Android instant answer apps
lets you access apps by simply
tap tapping on links even if you
don't have the app installed.
As a developer e, this means
that this is just at upgrade to
your existing Android app.
This is not a new separate app.
It's with Andrew jelly bean and
up and will reach over a billion
users.
Now, we understand that this is
a big change and we want to get
it right so we will be rolling
this out gradually to both users
and developers over the next
year.
So let's talk about how you'd up
upgrade your app to run
instantly.
As a developer, you start by
telling us the links to your
domain that your app can open.
This is really easy to do with
Android app links which we
announced last year.
Next, if your app is really big,
you may want to consider
splitting it into modules.
This allows Google Play to
download only the parts of the
app that are required on the fly
when the user taps on the link.
Next, we think that users may
have slightly different
expectations of what an app can
do when it's running instantly.
So instant apps will not have
access to some capabilities,
like creating a home screen
widget.
Finally, we're building a whole
new set of features for instant
apps that we want you to take
advantage of.
My favorite is run time
permissions.
Android instant apps will use
run time permissions going all
the way back to jelly bean.
Now, I want to talk a little
about some new opportunities
that instant apps could open up.
We've hacked together a couple
of fun demos that I want to show
you as fun examples.
Can we switch to the demo feed,
please?
Okay.
So instant apps lets you deliver
the same rich and immerseive
experiences to both users who
have installed your app and the
ones who haven't.
So the demo here is, my buddy
Jay created this really cool
photo sharing app.
It can capture panoramas and
display them in a really unique
way.
Now, he sent me a picture that
he captured on his app that he
captured at match you pitch you.
I really want to see the picture
that he installed shared, but
I'm not sure I want to install
the app yet.
With instant app, this is not a
problem.
All I have to do is tap a link.
With one tap, the app opens up,
instantly deep linked right to
the panorama that Jake shared.
It even uses the sensors on the
phone to pan the image as
Shobana moves the device.
Isn't that amazing?
[Applause.]
Thank you.
At the other end of the spectrum
spectrum, instant apps also lets
you create very lightweight
answer that don't even have to
take the user out of con text to
what they were doing.
Shobana and I recently made
plans to go to a concert.
So I booked my tickets, it was a
shins concert and sent her a
message asking her to book hers.
She doesn't have the ticketing
app on her phone.
When she taps the link, the app
opens up instantly.
But it didn't open up as a full
screen app.
It opened up just as a dialogue.
It is all the information she
needs prefilled.
Her seats are right next to mine
mine.
And with Android pay, it's one
tap to pay.
All of this while the hangouts
app is still in the background.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
Shobana -- thank you.
Shobana didn't have to leave her
conversation with me to buy
these tickets.
This can be really interesting
if you want to help the user
complete a simple task with as
little friction as possible.
So those are the two examples
that we have for you today.
Can we switch back, please?
Can we switch back to the slides
slides?
We'll be just a moment.
Perfect.
I wanted you to see the URL so
you can learn more.
So if you go to the website, you
can learn more.
There's a signup form if you're
interested in upgrading your app
to run instantly.
With that, I'd like to introduce
Purnima Kochikar who leads the
business develop development
team on stage.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
>> PURNIMA KOCHIKAR: Thank you.
How many think that instant apps
are amazing.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
You know, I have been so excited
excited.
I was in Uber this morning and
it was on the radio.
And I was like thrilled to bits.
Good morning, everyone.
I am Purnima Kochikar and I work
for you.
My team and I have the great
privilege to work with each and
every one of you to help you
build successful businesses on
Google Play Google Play.
Android powers increasingly new
screens across new markets,
empowering people across the
world.
And it is this scale that allows
Google Play to provide you the
largest app distribution
platform in the world.
Let's look at some numbers.
In 2015, 1 billion monthly
active users across 190
countries drove 65 billion
installs on Google Play.
[Applause.]
Mind boggling, isn't it?
In 2015, the number of game
developers who had a game with
more than 1 million installs
grew by over 50 percent, which
means more people are being
successful.
And if you look back and you say
okay, there is installs.
There is more installs per game,
but are we making money?
In 2015, the average spend per
user across Play grew by over
30 percent when compared to
2014.
So as you can see, we have a
very thriving community waiting
for the things that you create .
These are incredibly impressive
numbers.
But none of it would be possible
without you, our developer
community.
So, where I sit on a daily basis
basis, we see developers across
the world, big and small,
creating apps that change lives
and games that delight.
Each day, my team and I are
inspired and humbled by how you
are taking your personal
passions and converting them
into successful businesses.
I hope the video thately shared
with you was as inspirational to
you as it is to us.
Over the last year, we connected
with 1 million of you across
various channels to help you
understand and access the tools
we are building as well as to
tell you about the market
opportunities that are there in
front of you.
You heard today emerging markets
markets, new ways to build your
business, all these tools really
help you build your business.
Now here's the interesting thing
thing:  Each of those instances
we learned, we figured out how
to improve our products.
So I hope you will take the time
to visit us in the sandbox to
tell us how we can do things
better.
And I'm also excited to see what
you will do with the new
capabilities that we have
announced today.
We also used this opportunity to
get you connected with each
other.
How many of you are sitting with
people that you already know?
Should you be?
So I hope you take this
opportunity to really step out
and meet each other, understand
what everybody's doing.
There are people from around the
globe here today.
It is a unique opportunity.
And therefore I am extremely
excited to announce the very
first Google Play awards this
evening, 7 p.m. at stage 7.
You can't forget that.
7 p.m. at stage 7.
So please come to see the great
apps and games that are being
showcaseed.
Get inspired.
Join us.
Thank you very much for coming.
And here's how you can keep in
touch with us.
We hope to see you this evening
at 7 p.m.
Thank you.
[Applause.]
[Music.]
(Please stand by.  The sessi
on Search and the
Mobile Content Ecosystem will b
egin at the top of the
hour.)
(Please stand by.  The
session Search and the
Mobile Content Ecosystem will b
egin momentarily.)
(Applause.)
>> Good afternoon. I'm
Richard Gingras, head of
News@Google.  In my job I spend
a lot of time working
with publishers and partners a
round the world.  It is
such a pleasure to be here atio
with so many of you
in this exquisite space.  I
wanted to be on this
stage my entire life.
(Cheering.)
>> RICHARD GINGRAS: As you
probably noticed, I'm
not 27.  So what is the lesson
in that?  Don't give  Don't ever
give up!
(Laughter.)
(Cheers and applause.)
>> RICHARD GINGRAS: Google
as you know has apply
applied great focus on people
who use Google to ur content and
your brands.  We continue
to evolve our understanding of
users and their
intentions and interests and
then connecting those
users to the highest quality
third-party content in
services.  We are proud of our
symbiotic relationship
with publishers enable ing
users to benefit from your
products.
It is the Web's rich ecosy
stem of knowledge that
allows products like Google
search to have relevance
and value.
And it is the open platform
of the Web that allows
publishers to easily reach out
to new audiences.  In
that sense I believe that
Google and publishers share
a common cause.  We both desire
a rich and open
ecosystem for media
distribution.
Today we all have s
martphones in our pockets,
smart TVs in our living rooms
and increasingly
computers on our wrists and
cars, woven into the very
fabric of our lives.  People
come to Google billions times
each day to fulfill their daily
information
needs, whether that's catching
up on the Presidential
election, finding near by
concerts or if it's me,
discovering a recipe for a new
cocktail.  Primarily
these needs are fulfilled on
mobile.  In fact more
Google Searches take place on
mobile than on the
desktop.  The mobile momentum,
as you all know, is
only increasing.
By some projections the
world will have 5 billion
people accessing the Internet
by 2020.  5 billion
people.  From the coffee farmer
in Kenya to the high
school student in thigh land to
my geek friends in
this space with half a dozen
smart devices.
We are building Search to
meet their daily needs.
We want all of these users to
have a great Search
experience so that they can
discover and engage with
your content.
If you are a publisher,
Search, I'm guessing, is
probably a pretty important s
ource of traffic.  As
the next billion come online it
is only going to
become more important.
But before I tell you about
all the things that
Google can do today, let's take
a step back and
remember how Google started.
Remember 1998?  You  one of
these sitting in your house.
You
go to Google.com on this
monster machine, type in a
few words and you would get
links to relevant
websites.  At the time the
experience was truly
magical.  The world of
information at your fingertips
fingertips.
Today that experience is
still magical.  When you
recognize that mobile is
fundamentally different than
desktop, one can't simply port
the same desktop
experience over to consumers'
phones.  The needs of
our users and their mobile
behaviors are so different
today.
How many of you have been on
a desktop or laptop
since arriving atio?  Maybe in
your hotel room you
used your laptop or on your
flight here.  Think about
how many times you've checked
your phone today.  On
average?  People check their
phone 150 times a day.
Among those of us in publishing
or tech, it's
probably even more.
We twitch with stolen
glances at our phones, lured
back to the device for another
convenient burst of
digital activity.
These short sessions add up.
We spend 177 minutes
on our phones every day.
Almost three hours.
That
means we are having mobile
sessions that average more
than a minute long, more than
150 times a day.
In these short sessions w
e're productive.  In the
past year along websites in the
United States have
seen a 29 percent increase in
mobile conversion rates
rates.  We've completely
rebuilt Search for this
mobile always connected world.
People want answers
instantly.  We are no longer
sitting at desktop
computers surfing the Web for
hours on end.  We are
whipping out our phones in the
lunch line, airport or
while watching TV.  We are
searching for things
happening right now and using
many new types of
devices.
Let me share a video that
gives a quick glimpse
into Google's evolution over
the past 17 years.
Please run the video.
(Sounds of modem.)
>> We actually went through
thousands of names.
>> The name of the company
has now become its own
verb.
>> Let's Google it.
>> Put the Google.
>> Make simple letters on a
plain white page.
>> Being able to do searches
in any language, any
country.
>> Before you finish the
question, they finish the
question for you.
>> We work on organizing the
information.
>> Our goal is to digitize
all the work.
>> Today Google announce ed
Gmail,.
>> Google is making the
world accessible to people
everywhere.
>> Android is built as open
platform for everyone
to use and build on.
>> This is a faster save er
browse er for the open Web
Web.
>> Google is unveiling what
they call the
knowledge graph.
>> We needed to understand
the world the way you
and I do, as objects and ships
between objects.
>> Today Google got another
useful feature with
Google Maps.
>> We provide answers before
you ask them.
>> One of my favorite is sho
wing traffic to and
from work.
>> Think about how far
Google has evolve ed from the
ten blue links.
>> We asked ourselves: How
can we assist you
right when you need it?
>> Okay, Google, call the Wa
lker art center.
>> It's not desktops, phones
laptops anymore.
>> Okay, Google.
>> Watches with displays, c
ar consoles with
displays., Google, let's go to
the aquarium.
>> How can we help you get
things done and as few
steps as possible.
>> Okay, Google, show me my
photos of Lucas with
the pumpkin.
>> This is the tip of the
iceberg.  We have a long
way to go.
(Applause.)
>> RICHARD GINGRAS: It has
been a fabulous 17
years.  We have completely
rebuilt search for this
mobile always connected world.
And we've come a long
way both in our abilities, our
features, and the way
Google looks.  Google has a few
new moves to go along
with its new look.  Let me call
out several recent
launches.  With our story ies
to read cards in Google
Now we success news stories
based on the reader's
content, context and interest.
Since many of the
next billion users will be on
slow 2G connections we
created searchlight to ensure
that they still get a
great search experience.
Search light uses 90
90 percent less data than
standard search results.
We also started using mobile
for mobile Search
Results.  Searchers can find
high quality and
relevant results that support
great mobile experience
experiences.
Whether it's our election e
xperiences or our
health results over the past
few years we've launched
new features that feel right at
home on a mobile
device.
And that is just the start.
Although the device
landscape has changed, search
plays the same role it
did in 1998.  Understanding a
user's intent and
presenting the best possible
content.
Users have an increasing
number of needs:  Needs
that can be answered by the c
ontent and services you
provide.  With he are creating
the tools and features
that we believe will help users
and publishers make
the most of Search in this new
world.
If you attendedio sessions
over the past few years
you may be familiar with
features such as AppIndexing
he Voice Messaging API.
These features drive new ways
of discovery, whether
it's directing organic search
to your app or reaching
users with third-party Now
cards.  Today is about the
ways Google can help you grow
your audience and your
business.  We'll discuss how
you can preview fresh
realtime content in Search to
drive discovery and
reach.  We will show you how we
are leveraging
accelerated mobile pages in
Search to provide blazing
blazingly fast experiences for
all the great content
you build.  When your site
surfaces in Search, we
want you to be sure it loads
instantly.  Because if
it doesn't, abandonment
increases and opportunity ies
are lost.
Finally, we will show you
the new tools and report
reports we've built to help you
measure impact and
results.  Let's talk about rich
previews in Search.
I'll hazard a guess that you're
familiar with the
image on the left.  Standard
search results.  Since
the very beginning of Search,
these blue links have
been incredibly effective at
driving discoverability
of your content and the growth
of your business.
You probably already know th
at by including
structured data, appropriate to
your content, your
site can enhance its presence
on Search and go beyond
the traditional blue links.  In
this example what was
once links to recipe websites
is now much more visual
and engaging.  We call these
rich snippets.  With
simple mark-up you present a
compelling result with
views, images and more.  When
you look at the results
side-by-side it is clear that
rich snippets are more
entice ing to the user, more
entice ing means more clicks
sneap pets help users
make informed decisions with
greater likelihood of
user satisfaction and deeper
engagement with your
site.  It is a win-win
situation.  Users get much
more engaging Search
experiences, publishers get
increased discoverability and
traffic to their sites.
But we want to use mark-up
to make your content
even more engaging to users.
We want to take it a
step further.
We are beginning to roll out
a new format, rich      Rich
Cards, which makes your
evergreen content more
prominent on results pages.
Rich Cards further enhance
content previews on
Search results pages.  If
you're in the kitchen
desperate for your next sugar
hit, and I'm always
desperate for the next sugar
hit,
a quick Search of
desert recipes will get you
some mouth watering
possibilities.
Remember what I mentioned
earlier.  In the short
bursts of digital actively the
re isn't much time to
grab a user's attention.  The
more visual and
engaging the content, the
better.
For a user like me, I want
to be seduce ed by that
lemon cupcake image.  The recip
e, I want to tap it,
bake it, eat it.  A digitally
driven burst of
culinary activity.
What are Rich Cards?  First,
Rich Cards are built
upon rich snippets.  It's a fu
rther evolution of the , preview
ing richer content on search is
good for publishers and good
for users.  Instead of
links we are able to surface
information about events
events, recipes, and movies in
a highly compelling,
highly visual fashion.  Just
like rich snippets, Rich
Cards use schema.org markup to
enhance the previews
of a site's content.  A Rich
Card is a
compartmentalized template of
information that can
take on multiple forms.
Depending on where they are
displayed.  Let's walk through
a few examples.
Let's say you are waiting
for the subway on the
way to meet your best friend
who is a movie buff.
She is annoyingly smart.  We
all have friends like
that.  You need to learn
something about great movies
so you can be reasonably
prepared for the intense
debates that always happen when
you hang out.  You
type best movies of all time
into search.
On the left you see standard
search results with
links to relevant sites that h
ave top movie lists.
There may be some great
information on those sites,  not
sure.  You can hear the rumble
of the
approaching subway train.  You
have very little time
to get smart.
Now let's look at the right
side.  You can see
results with a rich      Rich
Card from Timeout New York City.
You have a nice visual carousel
with previews of the
listed movies, lots of visual
temptation.  You've
never heard of Ingamar better
man's persona.  Maybe
your friend hasn't either.  You
tap on it and off you
go to the Timeout New York City
website.
These Rich Cards can take on
many different forms.
Say you have a cooking website.
First your Rich Card
Cards can appear as I part of
list of recipes from
multiple sites.  For example,
if you search for pasta
recipes, you might find Mac and
cheese variations
from Epi curious and the New
York Times.  I love Mac
and cheese.  I will do both.
The Rich Cards can list
as a -- appear as a list of
recipes on your site.
All of these tempting waist
line expanding recipes
are from the food network.  Tap
on a recipe, go to site.  Start
cooking.
Users are coming to Google
billions of times each
day with query ies just like
these.  When a publisher's
content appears in more places
in richer, more forms, discovery
opportunity ies increase.
And those who click are more
likely to have a strong
Erin tenth to take action, to
cook that recipe, to
attend an event, to subscribe
to a premium feature.
Today the Rich Card program
is open for recipes
and it is being tested for mo
vies.  In the future
we'll expands to many other
categories of results as
Creating a Rich Card is
simple.  It only requires
structured data markup.  Mark
up your recipe pages  schema,
movie pages with movie schema.
You get the idea.  Many of you
have already done this
markup on your pages.  Then you
add item list markup
on the list page that contains
all the recipes or
movies.
We do recommend that you
submit a site map contain
containing the marked up pages
through the Google
Search console.  This will also
help increase the
discoverability of your
content.
We are just getting started
in this area.  We
would like to thank the publish
ers who participate ed
in early tests.  The effort
just made us hungry for
more.  We are eager to expand
the content of rich
Search.  Users are coming to
soip for more than
recipes, movies, events.  They
are searching for
things happening right now.
Right now, I mean right
this moment.  Not hours ago,
not 15 minutes ago.
Under the current model,
publishers have to wait
for Google to index their
content.  That means the  c
ontent isn't reaching users at
the moment
that matters most.
Take a look at this chart of
searchers during this
year's NFL draft.  At the start
of the draft, query ies
peaked and remained high
throughout the event.  These
users reacted to the live event
and came to Search
looking for fresh information.
Maybe they are on
their couch watching the draft
on TV.  Or sneaking a
look while sitting in a meeting
at work, looking for
the latest draft news.
This is not unique to sports
fans.  People are
coming to Google for realtime
info about all kinds of
things.  The Oscars, the
elections, and of course
breaking news.  During the
world cup, searchers
related to the World Cup peaked
at over 20 percent of
all Search volume.
People come to Google to
find information about
what is happening now.  That
led us to think:  How
can we surface realtime results
more quickly and those realtime
spikes in query ies?  The
question kicked off the
development of our realtime
indexing efforts.  Instead of
waiting for your
content to be crawled and
indexed, publishers will be
able to use the Google
publishing indexing API to
trigger the indexing of their
content.  Users get
realtime result insurance
Search and publishers
increase their reach.  It's an
exciting new area and
we are just getting started.
We launched a pilot
within the next few
months and we'll roll it out to
more publishers over the next
year.
As you know better than I do
, it is not enough to
simply appear on the search r
esults page.  To grow s you need
users to engage.  But far too
users are experiencing pages
that are awkwardly
slow-loading.  We know people
abandon slow-loading
sites.  Those occasions end up
being lost opportunity
opportunities, plain and
simple.  What publisher can
afford that?  In fact 40
percent of people abandon a
website that takes more than
three seconds to load.
With every millisecond users
have to wait for a page
to load, the more likely they
will give up and simply
go someplace else.
The experience of reading
content on the Web today
can be painful.  We've all had
these bad experiences.
There is that slow-loading Web
page, heavy pages       pages
do way too much when the network
connection
or the device simply isn't up
to the task.
You can almost feel the page
straining under the
weight of the data.  Sucking t
he life out of the
battery and bringing your phony
processor to its knee
knees.  All you can do is wait
and wait and wait.
And then there's that page
with the sticky scroll.
You start to scroll.  You get n
othing.  No bullet ter
tery smooth scroll for you.
Your finger isn't strong
enough to scroll that page.
Last but not least, that
page that seems to fully
load, you think it has, and
you're happy ily reading
along with all of a sudden a
late loading ad or some
component pops in.  Shifting the
content you
were trying to read off screen
someplace.
All you wanted was a
compelling read, but apparent
you wanted to play
hide and seek.  An effective
user engagement strategy
strategy?  Hmm, I don't think
so.
It was challenges like these
that were at the core
of the initiative that we t
ogether with three dozen
publishers and tech companies
started last fall  Accelerated
Mobile Pages project.  The AMP
project is an open source
initiative that embody ies
the vision that publishers can
create content once
and have it load instantly
everywhere.
To the benefit of their user
experiences, their
business models, their de
stiny ies.  It has been
amazing to see so many people,
so many companies come
together and build a solution
that would improve the
mobile Web experience for
everyone.  Not only
publish
publishers, but ad tech
companies, Analytics  discovery
platforms, CMS providers.
During the development of the
project, competitors
came together in the same room
and collaborated on a
common cause.
It was really inspires
really inspiring
to see.  This is the way
it had to be.  We felt it was
important that a
solution be driven by the
industry, not just a single
This way everyone is invested,
everyone can
share their expertise and we
can learn from one
another in order to achieve the
best possible outcome
outcome.
Let me share a video that I
think captures this
collaborative spirit of the AMP
project.  Let's check
it out.
(Music playing.)
>> Those of us when we first
started playing with
the Web, the great thing, you
could surf.  You go to  read
something.  Find a link there.
Click,
you're off to the next site.
>> Single best innovation
we've seen.
>> Thanks to smartphones,
everybody has it in the
pockets.
>> It's at odds with what ev
erybody does on the
Web, which is surf, browse,
fast and easy and it cant
cant.
>> This thing that should be
a source of wonder is
a source of frustration.
>> Waiting. Waiting.
>> Not letting me scroll.
>> Now it's loaded.
>> People bounce. If the
page doesn't load within
a couple seconds they move on
to the next page.
>> That is the worst
possible outcome for everyone
involved.
>> Google together with d
ozens of other publishers
and technology companies sat
down to try to find a
solution for this.  Our
solution was the AMP project.
>> AMP is a fantastic
industry clab a rative
approach to make mobile app
better.
>> The first thing you see
is instant speed.
>> Next click is only one
little scroll away.
>> More people will see us.
More people will see
our ads.  More people will be
able to read our
content.
>> We love the ability to
silo our own pages.  A
great opportunity to look and
feel like our brand.
>> With this open phi
losophy, it's unfettered, un
unrestricted.  You can do
pretty much whatever you
like with it.
>> Publishers can maintain
control over their own
destiny ies, control over their
own products, control
over their own business models.
The best way to do with an
engineering project is to make
it an source project.
>> We feel it's important
that there is not a gate
keeper between the publisher
and them reaching the >> The
success of the AMP project is
not based on
the leadership of one.  It is g
oing to be based on
the leadership of many.
>> You have a problem that
is common to others.
You work together to find a c
ommon solution.
>> So it's all of a sudden
everybody jumping in
and doing stuff.  Something co
mes out which is great.
>> Something we needed
needed to do for a loping
time as
an industry.  This is the sp
irit of the Web at its
best.
>> Just give it a try. Show
up
at the GitHub page
page.  Read the documentation.
See what it means for
your pages.
>> We shouldn't be fighting
over what a hyperlink
is anymore.  It's time to tell
the best story ies.
>> Those of us involved with
the AMP project are
involved because we love the
Web and want it to be as d h
ealthy as all of us know it can
be.  We
want it to be fast and
furiously compelling.  We want
to make the Web great again.
>> It's as simple as that.
Can we make the Web
great again?
(Music playing.)
>> RICHARD GINGRAS: Who was
that guy?
(Applause.)
>> RICHARD GINGRAS: Some of
you might have notice
noticed that a couple of people
in that video have
moved on to impressive new
opportunity ies.  I think of
that as another demonstration
of the power of AMP, to
accelerate careers!
(Chuckles.)
>> RICHARD GINGRAS: AMP is
very easy to use, if
you haven't tried it.  Its
underpinnings should be to
anyone creating Web content
today.  We've
invited a lot of familiar fri
ends to this party.  AMP
HTML is HTML with a couple of
extra twists and.
Javascript plays a role with
its library and within
Sandbox components you can
build.  CMS continues to
be at your disposal for
styling.  We brought smart
cache ing into the model.
AMP is based on Web
technologies and Web
principle
principles.  We didn't want to
turn our backs on what
makes the Web the Web.  We
didn't want to build
entirely new technologies
technology stacks.
Instead all it took
was some imagination to smartly
rearrange the exist
existing bits that were already
there.  Simply stated
it's just in time loading of
data, just in time
processing of components, just
in time rendering of
pages.
To be clear, AMP isn't just
about instantly
surfacing content on Google
Search or other discovery
platforms.  It is about
building fast, elegant
websites.
When we bring it all
together we find that an AMP
page loads four times faster
and uses ten times less
data compared to a non-AMP page
.  That doesn't  added perfo
rmance benefits when smart
cache ing and pre-rendering are
brought into the
equation.
Like I mentioned earlier, AM
P is an open source
project.  The activity and
engagement we've seen has
been tremendous and inspiring.
Over 7300 developers
have engaged with the effort.
There have been over
1900 code submissions from
developers.  The project
has put out 88 releases so far,
about two releases
per week.  Not bad for a
project that is about eight
months old.  The velocity has
been incredible.  I
thank each and every one of you
who helped to make
that happen.
From discovery platforms
like Twitter, line,
Pinterest, CMS providers like
Wordpress and Droopul,
to dozens of Analytics
providers and ad networks, it
has been great to see the
momentum behind AMP, but
the proof is in the adoption.
The adoption curve is
remarkable.  We've seen 125
million AMP documents in
domains, from every
corner of the globe.  It
continues to increase every
day.
Just like many publishers,
Google is also making
good use of AMP.  Earlier this
year we launched AMP
news carousels within Google
Search on the mobile Web
Web.  That makes it easier to
get discovered on
Google Search.  With those
carousels users can read
instantly
instantly loaded articles but
swipe between articles
that load instantly.  I'm not a
rocket scientist but
I know we can't expand the
amount of time during the
day, but we can help users
consume more content in
the time they have.
We are expanding AMP both
within Search and across
over Google properties like the
recently launched
Google news and weather app in
the United States   Over the
next several weeks we will be
rolling out the AMP experience
to the osis and Android
search apps as well and we will
continue beyond that.
We are also working to bring
AMP to new types of
content.  We just started to
experiment with
combining Rich Cards and AMP.
When you combine the
two, users get an incredibly
rich and fast experience
experience.  Users can tap on
your Rich Card and view
a recipe instantly.  They can
preview more recipes
instantly by swipe ing left or
right within the
carousel thanks to the instant
nature of AMP.
We are launching this first
with recipes and plan
to support many other content
types soon.  AMP will
be part of the realtime index
ing effort I talked earlier.
Now, let's take a look at
the tools we built to
help you measure the results of
the features I've
talked about.  Search Console
helps you monitor and
maintain your site's presence
on Google Search.  If
you haven't done it so far, we
strongly recommend you
verify ownership of your site
in Search Console.  It
provides many tools to improve
the search experience
for your content.
We've added a new report to
Search console that
will help you understand you
have implementation
errors in Rich Cards.  It will
even suggest which
cards can benefit from
additional markup.  To use the
tool, log into Search Console
and select the Rich
Card report.  The report will
show you the overall
status for your site.  In this
case you can see the
site has done a fine job and
they don't have any
invalid cards.  They do,
however, have many cards on
the site that can benefit from
marking up more fields
fields.  We mark them as
enhanceable cards.
The report will also show
you examples of any
errors down to the specific fi
eld on a specific URL.
It can also guide you to the
updated structure ed
data testing tool.  The s
tructure ed data testing tool
allows you to run a live test
on your pages.  This
can highlight all the errors
and enhancement
opportunity ies you have on
your cards.  This is one of
the most popular tools and is
incredibly useful for
stamping out problems before
they occur.
You can even simulate how
your card will actually
look on the Search results page
by adding the new
functionality.  It should make
the tool ever effective.
The AMP project, by the way,
also provides a  validate AMP
files in Search console we
surface AMP errors in your
crawled AMP content to
make it easier for you to addre
ss any fixes.  This
includes the structured data
requirements for AMP
features like the top story ies
carousel.
We also recently launched an
AMP report that shows
impression, click, and CTR data
for just your AMP   You can try
the feature today by simply
logging into your Search
Console account, go to the
search and Analytics report and
filter to AMP for
search types.  You can even
compare how AMP metrics
stack against other search
features like the search
Search
result links.
AMP has been a fast moving
initiative as I noted.
We want to thank the many AMP
developers who
contributed valuable feedback b
ut also code and help
helped us tweak the tools I'm
talking about here as
the will project evolve ed.
For some hands-on experience
check out the Sandbox
Sandbox.  We have members from
our developer relation
relations and product teams to
answer any and all
questions and show you live
demos.
That was a lot to cover in
half an hour.  I would
like to take a moment to recap
what we talked about
today.  We talked about how you
can preview richer
content in Search for increased
discovery.  We
announced our efforts in r
ealtime indexing to help
connect users with the most up
to date content you
offer.
We showed how AMP can drive
blazingly fast
consumption across the mobile
Web and how we are work
working to bring it to new
surfaces and new content ly we
walked through the new Rich Card
and
AMP reports and the updated
structured data testing
tool.
To learn more check out
these sessions that deep
dive into the individual topics
.  Again, if you are
interested in getting some
hands on time with these  want
to review documentation, please
stop by
the Sandbox, which you can do
at any time during the
rest ofio.
Google Search looks
completely different from 17
years ago.  That's the point.
As you heard yesterday
in Sundar's keynote, Google is
continuing to evolve.
All those -- although Search
may look different,
content discovery is at the
core of everything we do.
Whether that discovery comes
from the search results
page or the interfaces of the
future such as the
Google assistant or Allo or Hom
e, we want to make
sure that living and growing
with Google is possible.
Stay tune ed as you'll have
much more to announce as
more and more features and
capability ies move from
concept to reality.
As I mentioned at the begin
ning, I believe Google
and pubs share a common cause.
-- publishers share a
common cause.  I'm excited to
see so many people come  assure
that the next billion users can
experience the same magic and
universal access to
information that we've all
enjoyed over the first 25
years of the Web's history.
I thank you very much.
(Applause.)
(Cheers and applause.)
(Music playing.)
(The session concluded.)
>
>>
>> May 19,
MW68.
The
Mobile Web:  State of the
Union.Union.
>>
Union.
>> RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: Hello
everybody!  I'm Rahul
Roy-Chowdhury, I work on the
Chrome team and I'm glad to be
here.  Welcome to the mobile Web
state of the Of the Union this
session is all about the mobile
Web, what's been happening,
what's coming up, demos,
launches, case studies, stats
and a lot more.  There is a lot
happening here.
But before
we get into all of that, let me
take a moment to reflect on why
I'm here, why I care about the
mobile Web, and why I think you
all should as well.  The Web is
amazing!  And it's so familiar
to us that
sometimes we take it for g
ranted, but just think about i
t.
About it's easy to discover Web
content through a search engine
or just by sharing a link with a
friend, and because everything
is a link click away, it's very
low friction to interact with
the Web just link a link.  And
the Web works everywhere, from
the earliest PCs and feature
phones to the latest and
greatest Smart Phones and t
ablets, there is one thing that
all of these devices have in
common, they have a Web browser.
The Web has the broadest reach
by far of any platform out t
here.  But perhaps the best
thing about the Web is how it
operates.  It's completely open.
New features, new
functionality are added, debated
and discussed right there in
the
open.  And the Web is
decentralized, no one owns it or
rather we all own it
collectively and it's our
responsibility to be good
stewards of the Web flat form.
We work collaboratively across
all vendor browsers to make sure
we can uphold that
responsibility.  The Web is one
of the most amazing things ever
invented, and Google loves
the Web!
>>
(Applause).
The Web is great for users, the
Web is great for developers, and
it's our mission on the Chrome
team to move the Web platform
forward and to make you all Web
developers successful.  That's
what gets us motivated.  That's
what gets me out of bed every
morning.  That's why imown on
stage.
I'm up on stage.
The Web is more important than
ever before.  Four years ago
Chrome had no preference on
mobile at all, and just last
month, Chrome grew to over 1
billion monthly active users on
mobile
alone..
(Applause).
It's really amazing to see this
kind of growth!  Now, while the
mobile Web, the growth of the
mobile Web has been phenomenal,
we do have to remember that the
Web came of age when computing
looked a little bit more like
this.  And some of you may be
too young to remember the old
school Google home page, but
most computing was done on these
big beefy desk top machines
connected to an ethernet cable
or to a modem and then mobile
came along and changed the rules
of the game.
These devices are small, they
had less power, less memory.
They had flaky networks, they
will touch screens.  Everything
was different.  And to figure
out what would makes a great
mobile Web experience, the Web
platform and mobile Web browsers
had to do
a complete yond up rethink --
ground up rethink.  I'm not
talking a few tweaks here or
there, I'm talking about going
back to first principles and
figuring out what would make the
mobile Web
awesome.
We believe the keys to a great
mobile Web experience rests on
four
pillars.  First, accelerate the
experience.  Make everything
fast.  Make the page load fast,
make it scroll fast.  That's
what gets people in.  And once
people are in, provide an
engaging experience, an i
mmersive experience, a polished
app experience.  That's what g
ets people to stay.
And once you have a fast
engaging experience, you are
going to get a lot of visitors.
The Web does have broad reach,
after all.  And so the third
pillar is just take all of those
visitors and convert them into
loyal users.  This could be by
having users sign up so you can
personalize the experience.  It
could be by completing a
transaction or some other
flow.  And the final pillar for
mobile Web success is once you
have all of those users, you
want to retain them.  You want
to Re-engage with them and bring
them back into the experience
at the right time.  These are
all hard problems to solve and
solving them requires many
changes to the Web platform and
to mobile browsers.  But this
transformation is now largely
complete.
It is possible to build a mobile
Web experience that is fast,
engaging, good at c onverting
visitors into users and good at
retaining and Re-engaging the
users at the right times.  We
call such experiences
progressive Web A pps.  Remember
back when Ajax completely
changed what
was possible on the desktop Web.
Progressive Web Apps are that
same fundamental shift for the
mobile Web.  And as you see,
many people are already d
eploying progressive Web Apps
and seeing success with them.
And I hope that when you all
leave Google I/O, all of you
will go out and do the same.  In
other words, the mobile Web is
open
for business.
(Applause).
So let's dig into what that
means.  Speed is the killer
feature.  If you have your
finger on a screen and you are
trying to scroll and the page
doesn't respond to your finger
right away, it's a physically
unpleasant sensation.  We all
know this intuitively.
Responsive scrolling is not a
nice to have feature as n
absolute necessity.  And there
is data that backs this up.
For example, Facebook did an
experiment where they reduce the
frame rates from 60 frames a
second, which is smooth
controlling to 30 frames a
second, which is slow scrolling
and what they found was user
engagement collapses.  Speed
matters.  We do a lot of work in
Chrome to make it easy for you
to build smooth and fast
experiences for your users, but
sometimes we need your help.  We
need to work together to
provide the best possible
experience.
For example, we recently l
aunched passive event l
isteners.  This is an API that
lets you, the Web developer,
provide hints to the browser
about why you are listening for
touch events.  And using this A
PI, the browser can do a better
job of responding to scroll.
This can make a huge difference.
I will show you a video in a
second but just to tee it up,
you will see two phones side by
side, both running CNN.com.
The phone on the left, your
left, does not have this API
implemented, and the phone on
the right does have this API
implemented.  And if we can roll
the video, as you will see, as
we start loading up both pages,
and scrolling, the phone on the
left has noticeable lag between
when I move my finger and when
the page responds where as the
phone on the right responds
right away as I scroll my finger
up the page.  There is a huge
difference in responsiveness.
And I'm glad to say that CNN is
rolling out this change to all
of their users as we speak so
that's great
news.  It's not only about
scroll r esponsiveness.  Studies
have shown that 40% of users
will a brandon a Web page if it
takes longer than three seconds
to load.  We want to make it
easier for developers to build
websites that are extremely
fast.  That led us to create
accelerated mobile pages or AMP
and if you were here in the
session before this, you have
heard all about AMP, but the
summary high level is this.  AMP
lets developers take
performance to the next level
and make
content experience experiences
fast.  AMP pages load four times
faster and use ten times less
data.  And we launched AMP a few
months ago, and the response
has been tremendous.  There are
currently 125 million AMP
documents out there from over
640,000 unique domains.
And AMP is all about the Web.
AMP content is nothing about H
TML and JavaScript.  It is
amazing that AMP shows the
performance on the Web platform.
We have talked about how to
make experiences fast.  The
second pillar of mobile Web
success is to deepen the
engagement.  This is all about
creating polished app
experiences, experiences that
are resilient to network
conditions whether off line or
just have a flaky network.
Progressive Web Apps enable
engaging experiences through a
key piece of underlying
technology called service w
orkers.  And service workers
provide full clientside control
over fetching and caching, and
using progressive workers and
using service workers and
progressive Web Apps you can
build really polished app
experiences.  Take the case of
g ilanticus, a tech site in
Asia.  And when I tap that icon,
what I see is Gilanicus shows a
splash screen which is smooth
and polished and then it loads
up in full screen mode.  As I
navigate around you can see the
transitions and man nations are
rock solid.  It's a polished
experience.
And if you nts there is no
Chrome UI here.  This is all
G ilanticus's progressive Web A
pp.  Progressive Web  Web Apps
and service workers enable you
to make your app work well off l
ine.  Let's take the example of
flip cart.  They have built an
awesome progressive Web App and
it works well off line.  So if I
go to flipcart.com, and I go
off line, I go off line there.
You will see that flipcart
changes the UI to gray scale to
indicate to the user that I am
off line but the user can
continue to navigate in the app
and view cached content.  It's a
very seamless experience.
Now, progressive Web Apps and
AMP work really well together.
And The "Washington Post" has
put together a really cool
integration as well.  So to show
you this in action, let me
invite up on stage David Merrell
senior product manager from The
"Washington Post."
(Applause).
>> DAVID MERRELL: All right.
Thanks, we are really excited at
the Post to be able to show you
guys today some new investments
we have been making in the
mobile Web space.  As pretty
much everyone here probably k
nows we joined dozens of
publishers and goog  Google this
year with the launch of AMP.
We have been thrilled with
results so far.  AMP has lived
up to his name.  We see the
articles load in 400
milliseconds.  That is a huge
gain over the traditional mobile
Web.  One of the great benefits
of being with AMP right at
launch is we is see the metrics
on our end about the load times
and we can also see exactly how
users are reacting to them, and
not surprisingly, users love it.
They love the speed.
Before AMP, 51% of mobile users
who visited The "Washington
Post" from Google search
returned within seven days.  N
ow, with AMP, that number is up
to 63%.  And we give a huge
amount of credit to the speed of
AMP for that data there.  So we
know that users love speed.  We
know that we love speed because
it's easier for us and because
it makes our users happy, but
the question that faces
publishers today is how can we
build engaging and fast
experiences that will build
relationships with users beyond
the search carousel.  We get
people once or twice a week from
search, we love to convert
those people three or four times
a week, every day using new
experiences.  So we took what we
learned with AMP and we started
working on a progressive Web A
pp.  I am thrilled to be able
to show you guys what that looks
like.
Could we get the phone up on the
screens?  Great!  So I'm going
to find us a Washington Post AMP
article now.  And live demos in
search can be a little bit
dicey because you don't know
what the algorithm is going to
turn up.  But here we go.
Washington Post AMP story here,
we will tap in it.  Everyone can
see it loads really fast.  Now,
what you can't see happening on
the AMP article now is we are
using a service worker to
install a very small piece of
progressive Web App code into
the Chrome browser so that we
can very quickly and seamlessly
upgrade the user to a rich,
engaging experience.  So for the
purposes of the demo, we put a
link to the progressive Web App
at the top of the menu.  In the
future, we are looking at
testing having all links within
AMP open to this progressive
experience because users will
have that app already installed.
We will go into the app now.
Here it is.  You can see that
loaded really fast.  We have got
load times here under a second
when coming from the AMP page.
(Applause).
So once I'm in the app, we
focused on making a smooth
scrolling experience.  So it
feels very native.  We are   We
are on Washington Post.com
domain and as we scroll through
we used ideas and principles of
AMP to make these pages light
and then we added on the caching
ability of service workers on
the progressive Web App to pre
cache pieces the article before
you get there.  And thanks to
that, we have brought load times
within this PWA down to 80
milliseconds for each
article.
(Applause).
We were a little surprised we
got it down that load.  We are
happy about it.  We think users
will love it!  So that p
re-caching that the PWA gives us
let's us solve another
important user experience issue
that everyone faces.  That is
what happens when you go off
line?  Now, lots of people take
the metro to work, metro goes
above ground, underground, you
are in and out of cell service.
So show you what we do there,
let's go to airplane mode.
So now just like regular
website, the article I'm on
still works, but because I have
used the progressive Web to
cache the content around it, I
can keep reading new articles
even though
I'm off line.
(Applause).
All right.  So that is our new
progressive Web experience we
are testing now.  I think it
really brings together the power
of the Web in a great way.  We
have got that lightning fast
first load under AMP followed up
by using the service worker and
the progressive Web App to do a
seamless really fast upgrade to
user experience that we hope
will get people coming back
again and again to The
"Washington Post."  So I really
think this is going to help
bring our journalism to people
around the world and make it
more accessible and we are happy
about that.  So I would invite
all of you to check it out.  You
can get it today on your
phones.  If you go to any AMP
article, either through Google
search or Google news like I did
and go to the menu you can go
to the PWA or go to Washington
Post. Washington Post.com/PWA on
your phones.
>> RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: Awesom
e.  Thank you David, that was
awesome!  I hope you are
convinced that it's possible to
build an experience on the
mobile Web that is fast and
engaging.  And this should get
you lots and lots of visitors
because the Web does have broad
reach.  Let's turn our attention
to the third pillar for mobile
Web success which is now we take
the visitors and convert them
into loyal users.  Now, there is
something you may have noticed
about
mobile, typing on mobile is
hard.  This happens to me more
times a day than I feel
comfortable admitting in public,
but because typing on mobile is
hard, asking users to sign in
is hard and in fact we have seen
that if a user doesn't sign in
correctly the first time maybe
because they mistyped their
credentials, 92% of them will
give up rather than have to
retype their credentials again.
And we do our bit in Chrome to
try to help the users.  We have
a password manager feature and
through the password manager
feature we try to help by auto
filling in sign in fields and
using the password manager
feature we help users sign in
over 8 billion times every
single month.  So that's great.
We are helping our users.  But
we asked ourselves, what if we
could do it better?  And we
realized that, yes, we can do it
better.  We can do it better if
we turn the reins over to you,
the developer, and give you
control over the experience.  So
in that spirit I'm pleased to
announce the launch of the
credentialed manager API which
does just that.
This API let's you interact with
safe credentials inside the
browser and works with fed rated
sign-ins.  One company using
this API is kayak and kayak is a
travel company and it's
important to them that users be
signed in so they can keep track
of travel information across
devices and platforms.  Using
this API Kayak users who have
saved credentials in Chrome will
never need to retype them
again.  And so a user who goes
to Kayak and taps the sign-in
button, will see a prompt to
select the credentials they want
to sign in with and that's it.
They are signed in.  One tap,
and you are in.  It's a really
smooth experience!
What's even cooler --
(Applause).
Yes.  What's even cooler is
that Kayak can remember that
the user used those credentials
to sign in so the next time the
user goes back to Kayak, Kayak
can sign the user in
automatically.  Instead of
launching up the Kayak website
and you will see a little blue
bar at the bottom that is saying
we are signing you in so the
user knows what's going on but
then the user is signed in.  The
user had to do nothing, zero t
aps.
So it's a really smooth
experience.
(Applause).
So now in addition to helping
users sign in we want to help
users complete transactions on
the Web to pay for things on the
Web and to set this problem up
there is just one number you
need to know which
is 66%.  There is a good 66%
and a bad 66%.  So the good news
is that 66% of mobile commerce
happens on the mobile Web is the
mobile Web is critically
important for commerce.  On the
other hand, conversions on the
mobile Web happen a rate that's
66% lower than the desktop Web.
So the mobile Web is critically
important for commerce, but
it's also very inefficient.  And
we all know why that is.
Completing a transaction on the
mobile Web is hard.  There are
many forms to fill out.  There
are many screens to go through
and many opportunities for the
user to drop off.  And, again,
in Chrome we try our bit, do our
bit to help users.  We have
auto fill feature and we try and
fill in form
fields to help the user through
the flow.  And in fact studies
have shown that users on Android
who use auto fill complete
transactions and form
submissions on the Web 25% high
orates than other users.
So that's great!  We are h
elping our users!  But, again,
we asked ourselves what if we
could do it better.  And, again,
we realized, yes, we can do it
better.  We can do it better if
we turn the rains over to you --
reins over to you the developer
and gave you complete control
of the experience.  So I'm
really excited to announce a
launch of the Web payments API.
The new API that brings one tap
checkout to the Web for the
first time ever!
(
Applause).
This is awesome.  One company
that is making use of the API to
streamline flow is shop I few.
shopify.  So here they are
using shopify and they have
items in the cart and ready to
check out.  And when they hit
check out it does an API call to
the browser to fill all of the
information needed to complete
the transaction.  Rather than
user having to go through a
bunch of form fields
and a bunch of screens, the user
sees this, which is everything
they need to complete this
trance x.  And when the user h
its pay, the transaction is
done.  That's it.  One tap, and
the transaction is done.
(Applause).
And this example I showed you
this working with a credit card,
but this API also works with
Android pay so we are bringing
Android pay into the browse ire
with this API as well.  The flow
is exactly the same.  And in
the future, this will work on
all other types of payment
applications
also.  And with all of these
APIs, we are working right out
in the open and collaborating
closely across all of our
different browser vendors as
well.  So we talked about making
experiences fast, making them
engaging, converting visitors
into users, so let's look at the
fourth pillar for mobile Web
success which is how do we then
retain those users and Re-engage
with them at the right times.
Now, one big thing that changed
in the shift to mobile was the
importance of push-based
interactions.  We have these
devices with us all of the time,
and we are allowing push notify
okayings to stay up to date on
the things we care about.  This
is why we are excited about push
notifications for the Web.
These work exactly as you would
expect once a user ops into to
receiving notifications from
your site, they will get those
notifications, and they will get
them whether or not the site is
open or whether or not the
browser is open.  And they show
up exactly where users expect to
see them on the notifications
tray or on the lock screen.  N
ow, one company sha is making
use of push notifications is a
company called Jumia, a large
eCommerce  provider in Africa.
Jumia was trying to figure out a
problem they had have abandoned
shopping carts.  They turned to
progressive Web Apps and they
implemented push notifications
for the Web as a way to
Re-engage those users who had
abandoned shopping carts.  This
is early days, but the results
have been spectacular.  In fact,
Jumia reports that they see a
nine-fold increase in
conversions of abandoned
shopping carts for users who
come in through push
notifications.  So well done,
Jumia, this is the kind of
success we love to see!
companies are implementing and
rolling out push notifications
and seeing
success.  Last November at
Chrome dev summit, we announced
we were sending out 350 million
push notifications every day
across mobile and d esktop, and
today I'm pleased to report less
than six months later, that
number has grown to 10 billion
push notifications every single
day.
(Applause).
And it continues to grow.
Amazing!  So there you have it,
the four pillars for mobile Web
success.  Accelerate the
experience, make it engaging,
immerse sive and polished,
convert visitors into users and
then retain and Re-engage those
users at the right times.  And
to show you an example of a
great progressive Web App, one
that is made very effective use
of these four pillars, let me
invite up on stage swag,
swag.
>> HANNES SCHWAGER: Hi,
everyone, for those who are not
familiar with AirBerlin, we are
Germany's second largest a
irline.  We fly to 147
destinations worldwide including
San Francisco since May, and we
serve over 30 million
passengers in 2015.  As an
airline, we are constantly
working on new ways to improve
the travel journey, right, even
off line.  And it's very
exciting to be here to tell you
or to show you how we have been
building a progressive Web App
to improve the customer check-in
experience.  Like any business,
we know that not all of our
customers will download the app,
especially those who are
traveling just once or twice a
year.  And so I have been
looking quite a long time to
find a solution how we can
improve or how we can make an
easy check-in  via the mobile W
eb.
Because a lot of people check in
via mobile Web.  So that's why
I'm here today to show you what
we have built over the last
month, and, therefore, I booked
a flight going to Rome.  I love
going to Rome, and I booked it a
couple of weeks ago, and
everyone was asking me if I want
to accept push notifications
and I say, yes, why not, give me
a reminder when check-in is
open.  Let's see if it worked.
ready.  It worked out.  There
it is snchts
!  Tapping on a push
notification takes me directly
to a page where I have access to
all of my flight details, where
I can just check in by one c
lick, and that's what we are
going to do.  It really opens up
the page very quickly, and just
by tapping, get the boarding
pass, check-in was successful.
So now I have my boarding pass
right away there thanks to the
progressive Web App, and I can
see, okay, there are some
journey details, check in, done,
boarding 30 minutes, just
checked to be ready for s
ecurity, and snacks and drinks
will be served.  Good to know.
And AirBerlin is asking me at
the home screen.  I think it was
just a great experience what I
had and I'm traveling tomorrow
to Rome, so it's fine to add it
to home screen because then I
have a much faster access to all
of my AirBerlin information.
But it's not only having a cool
and convenient experience with
the push notification for the
check-in, it's more.  It's being
there for the customer
throughout the whole journey.
So as all of you know that often
on airports, the Internet is
very bad or you don't have any
connectivity.  You are in a r
ush.  You are in a hurry, and
I'm not sure if you can have
access to the
Internet.  So, therefore, I go
for airplane mode to say, okay,
I'm off line.  And I will have
the possibility to get back via
the home screen icon in full
screen mode.  So you have seen
it loaded very, very quickly and
I have all of my details there,
all critical content.  I can
explore destination, even in
offline mode can read what I can
do in Rome, get some
information about Rome.  And
most important thing is I have
access to my boarding pass.  And
I think we don't need to do
screen shots anymore of our
boarding pass being sure that I
have it with me, right?  I do
this.  So I think with t hat, we
really can cancel that and be
sure having it right away with
you.
Thanks to this --
(Applause).
So thanks to the progressive Web
App and service work here we
have been able to improve the
journey for all of our c
ustomers, not only those who
have installed our app, and the
check-in is just the first step,
I would say.  It's, we already
are thinking of rolling out the
technology to other critical
parts of the travel journey, and
I'm very happy to say that we
are going to roll out this
version within the next weeks to
our users, and a big thanks to
the team who did a very good job
within the last couple of
weeks.  Thank you.
(Applause).
>> RAHUL ROY-CHOWDHURY: Thank
you.  That was great!  More and
more companies are deploying
progressive Web apps and seeing
success.  Sumo, this is Japan's
largest real estate site and
they recently deployed a
progressive Web App and saw huge
improve wills in speed and
re-engagement.    Sumo reports
they were able to reduce page
load times by 75%, and then when
they added push notifications
as a way to Re-engage users by
sending them information about
new real estate listings they
might care about, they saw a 31%
open rate on those n
otifications.  It's truly
astounding.  This is great
success, well done, Suumo this
is the kind of success we love
to see.  (
(Applause).
Or ache alley express, a l
eading global online
marketplace, they deployed a
progressive Web App as well and
they report increased engagement
across all browsers across all
platforms.  In act, Aliexpress
says the time spend in their app
went up 74% and they saw an 82%
increase in conversions on iOS.
So these investments make
sense across all browsers,
across all platforms, not just
Chrome.
And the momentum continues to
grow.  More and more companies
are deploying progressive Web
Apps and seeing success, and I
hope that all of you when you
leave Google I dlsh /O will go
out and do the same.  We are not
done yet.  The Web will
continue to evolve as the world
of computing evolves, and here
on the Chrome team we are
working on a long list of
exciting new projects.
So let me take the next six
hours and walk through each of
these in a lot of detail.  I see
people heading for the exits.
No, no, I'm not going to do t
hat!  Let me give you two
examples to give you a flavor
for the kinds of things we are
working on.  We are working on
the physical Web.  The physical
Web is a way to bring the Web,
to extend the Web to objects
around us.  Wouldn't it be cool
if you got on a bus and you
could get the bus schedule
available on your phone
instantly right when you needed
it?  This is possible today in
public buses across London using
the physical Web.  And more
generally the physical Web is a
way for objects to broadcast U
RLs to us and for us to use the
URLs to interact with those
objects right on demand when we
need it.  We are also working on
Web assembly.  Web assembly is
an ambitious effort across many
different browser vendors to
define a new low level language,
one that runs at native speeds
but securely and on the Web.  It
is still early days but we are
really excited about the
potential here for unlocking new
high performance cases, use
cases, things from gaming to
media to scientific computing
and who knows what
else.  So as we work on
improving the mobile Web today,
and as we look to the future,
there is one key thing to
remember, which is that we are
all in this together.  My
session is almost over, but this
conversation is not over.  This
conversation is just getting
started.  We are going to have a
series of events throughout the
remainder of this year all
across the world as part of the
progressive Web Apps road show
and there is a dev summit in
Amsterdam next month and a
registration link you can use to
sign up.  And if you can't make
one of these events, we are
active and engaged on Twitter,
on StackOverflow, on github and
we have a developer  portal with
a lot more information.  We
would love to hear from you.  We
would love to work with you.
We would love to help you be
successful.  And, of course, we
work collaboratively across all
of the different browser v
endors.  Ultimately it's up to
all of us, browser  vendors and
Web developers to write the
future of the Web.  So go out
there and build a great
progressive Web App!  The future
of the mobile Web looks very,
very bright indeed.  Thank you!
Applause).
>
>>
>> eb
App,?
>> TAYLOR SAVAGE:
, Taylor Savage,.
>>
>> 5/
1/16.
Polymer and Progressive Web
A pps: Building on the Modern W
eb.
>> TAYLOR SAVAGE: Good
afternoon, everybody, I'm the
product manager here at Google
on will Polymer project.  How
many people are familiar with or
have used Polymer or Web
components before.  Wow!
Awesome!  I don't have to do the
talking.  That's great!  I have
got a lot of exciting new
features, a lot of exciting
product to talk about.  Before I
get started, I want to begin at
the beginning.
We have one overarching goal on
the Polymer project, which is to
build the tools and libraries
using the latest Web platform
features so that you, the
developers can build the next
generation of Web Apps.  If you
have been following Web
development or if you were at
the talk that came right before
mine, you know the next
generation of Web Apps are here
and they are calls progressive
Web Apps.  So the Polymer
project mission is to provide
tools and libraries to make it
easy to use the latest Web
platform features to build
progressive Web Apps but that's
wordy for a vision statement.
So let's make it more concise.
The Polymer project's mission is
to use the platform to deliver
great user experiences.
The key part here is to use the
platform.  On the Polymer
project, we are not trying to
build massive abstractions, not
trying to build mega frameworks.
We are trying to let, you the
developer, use what is cutting
edge in the Web App it accepted
so you can instead of building
massive tool chains you can
focus on delivering great
experiences to users on the Web.
traditionally the Web  platform
hasn't been a great platform for
delivering immersive app-like
experiences.  The lowest level
that you get is an HTML tag.
These  HTML tags you are
provided for things like
headings, paragraphs and lists
work great for document markup,
but they are not so great for c
onstructing immersive app-lick
experiences.  Over the past 20
years that HTML has existed, the
language hasn't evolved much
and user expectations have
evolved significantly.  What has
evolved and what has gotten s
ignificantly more powerful is
JavaScript.  And so to create
the app-like experiences on the
mobile Web we have used
JavaScript as an escape hatch.
We have built meta platforms, we
have built JavaScript run
times, tool chains all in
JavaScript to allow us, the
developers to develop app 450EU6
like experiences.  This might
have been fine on desk top where
we have beefy machines
connected by cables or Wi-Fi,
but there has been a major
change in the Web, which is the
mobile Web.  And the mobile Web
is incredibly powerful.  You
don't have to ask permission
fromin to publish your
application to the Web and then
nearly every single device out
there is going to have a browser
and that user can access your
application.  That's awesome!
The mobile Web has incredible
reach and it reaches into places
where data connections are
limited, where device hardware
is limited, and for the next
billion users coming on line
today, they typically have the
worst combination, slow data
connections, and low hardware.
So building these towering meta
platforms all on JavaScript to
deliver an app-like experience
doesn't fly on the Web.  When
flaky connections are the norm,
you need minimal overhead, min
nail redundancy, maximal
efficiency to be able to deliver
that great experience.  So what
do we do as Web developers?
How do we solve this new
challenge of the mobile Web?
Well, the answer so far has been
more JavaScript.  We keep
piling on more and more
JavaScript so get this to work
to the point where we are
running JavaScript son our
servers so we can representedder
our application we can send it
to the device, we can paint and
we download more JavaScript so
it can rehigh descrait and boot
up and it's more interactive.
And it is frustrating for users
and developers as well.
We think there is a better
solution, which is less
JavaScript.  Use the platform to
build modern mobile Web Apps
use what's already there on your
user's device, the browser.
They have the vast majority of
what they need to run your
application sitting right on
their device.  Use it.  And
thanks to powerful new features
baked into the Web Platte form,
it's increasingly possible.
It's increasingly possible to as
the developer construct using
immersive app-like experiences
using what's baked into the
browser.  We want to make it
easy using tools and libraries
to build less overhead, higher
quality application.
So so far we have focused on two
things on the Polymer project,
using Web components and
building Web components.  Let's
start with using Web components.
We want the browser itself to
be more capable by introducing
the notion of a standardized
encapsulated component into the
platform i tself.  The hardest
part of building a Web
application today is knowing
where to start.  And for just
about any large application of
any meaningful size, chances are
the place to start is to pick a
JavaScript framework.
And by my last count, there are
approximately one million
JavaScript frameworks out there
to choose from, and this is a
really critical decision.  It's
going to be before you write a
line of code you will have to
pick a JavaScript framework and
every single line of code you
write from that point forward
will likely be directly tied to
that decision, to that
JavaScript framework that you
picked.
Now, JavaScript frameworks can
be really powerful.  They can
give you useful features for
structuring large scale
applications, features like
internationalization, making
routing easier and they can also
provide a convenient mental
model to think about how you are
building this application, make
it easier as a developer to
create that large scale app.
There are a couple of very high
costs to using a JavaScript
framework or meta platform to
build your application on the
Web.  The first cost is a cost
that your users pay.  When you
use a meta platform, when you
use this big towering
abstraction JavaScript not don't
only do you have to send the
code to write the application
but you have to send the
JavaScript code to supply the
meta platform.  You need to
execute that platform on the
device before your app can
execute.  This might have been
fine on desktop with big  beefy
medications with cable and Wi-Fi
connections but on mobile,
throw, flaky 3G connections are
the norm, slow devices are the
norm and using abstractions
users pay the cost both in time
it takes to download the meta
platform onto their device and
boot it up and also very
literally they pay the cost in
their data plan of the extra
hundreds of kilobytes or
megabytes of JavaScript that has
to be downloaded so you can run
your application on the Web.
And the second cost of these
abstractions is a cost that you,
the developer, pay.  When you
build a component in your Web
App, it's directly tied to the
framework you chose.  So no work
you do for those components are
useful in alternate frameworks.
So if your next project you
are going to choose a different
JavaScript framework because a
new one has come out you have to
throw away the old component
code.  And if you are a company
with multiple teams and they
have slightly different
framework stacks you can't share
components across teams using
different stacks so though there
are many benefits to using a
large meta platform mega
framework, users pay the cost of
that abstraction and you, the
developer also pay the cost of
that abstraction in terms of
framework lock in.
What if there was a better way?
Every single framework has a
notion of an encapsulated
component.  What if rather than
a framework having to provide
that encapsulated component the
browser itself let you dough
fine your own components and
those components could work with
any JavaScript framework you
might want to use.  You could
pick components off a shelf that
other developers have built in
open source that solve a problem
that you are faced with to use
in your own application.  And
the components would be
compatible no matter what
JavaScript stack you are using.
This is the promise of Web
components.  Web components are
a new set of W3C standards, Web
platform standards that extend a
native component model in the
platform itself.  Because the
Web already has a component
model baked in, the DOM.  The
DOM has DOM nodes which you can
call methods on which have
properties and can send
DOM events.  And they have a
declarative way to construct
that DOM with the HTML language.
But the problem is HTML is f
ixed.  And with Web components,
you can extend the language of
HTML itself by creating new
elements that you can then use
in your application,
encapsulated reusable components
without the cost of this
framework overhead.  And what's
great is with Web components
HTML becomes your
interoperability layer.  Every
single framework if it has to
have an application run on the
Web platform at the end of the
day has to speak HTMLs the
lowest level visual primitive of
the Web.  A Web component
essentially comes another HTML
tab just like your dibs, Ps, L
Is.  So now that we can extend
HTML now that we create our own
HTML  tags we can reuse them
regardless of what JavaScript
stack we are using.
So one challenge is as many of
you know if you have been
following the Web component and
start it's taken a long time.
So the very first version of
this Web component spec came out
in 2012, almost four years ago
to the day.  And these specs
have gone through many changes
and this is the nature of
standards work, the nature of
spec work but I'm extremely
excited that today thanks to
broad cross browser
collaboration we are in the home
stretch for Web component
support.
So Web components is really an
umbrella term for the lower
level primitives, template, HTML
imports, custom elements and
shadow DOM.  Template elements
be broadly shipped across
browser.  HTML imports of
shipped in Chrome and others are
pending 6 module.  The most
powerful primitive is to let you
extend HTML, let you create
your own Web components and
thanks to broad cross-browser
cooperation from the major
browser vendors, custom elements
and shadow DOM specs hit a
major milestone with V1.  V1 is
the latest iteration of the two
specs, why V1 we like to index
by zero in speckland, I'm not
really sure.  But most
importantly all major browser
venders are on board with
driving implementations of these
V1 specs, FireFox, edge,
Safari, Chrome we are all
involved to get to this point
with these V1 versions.  Its aI
high priority roadmap item for
the edge team to implement.
FireFox and Chrome
implementations of V1 are well
under way, and Safari has
working versions of V1, shadow
DOM and custom elements in their
nightly builds.  So with the
Web components right around the
corner, and using the polyfills
that exist today to use thighs
features, many major companies
are already using Web components
in production.  Github today
uses custom elements for all of
its time stamps and emoggy
across the
site.  Twitter just announced
they will be using shadow DOM
for all of their embedded
Tweets rather than the much
heavier wait iframes.  And the
ecosystem around building these
Web components is starting to
accelerate and take off.  Custom
elements.IO which is a major
aggregator, c omponents built by
Web developers across the world
has 2,000 components on it
written by over 800 authors an
more are being added every
single day.  So browsers are
actively building support for
Web components.  Major sites are
already using Web components in
production.  The ecosystem is
already beginning to flourish.
Grued native Web component
browser support is no longer a
matter of if, but a matter of
when, and when could be as soon
as later this year.  So in the
past, when we have talked a bout
-- prep
-
(Applause).
In the
past when we have talked about
Web components they have been on
the bleeding edge of Web
development and now Web
components are just on the l
eading edge of Web development.
So as you saw, Web components
are four lower level specs and
they are great and great to use,
but they can be hard to figure
out how to actually build and
encapsulate a Web component so
we built the Polymer library to
make it easier to create your
own Web components.  We first
announced the developer preview
of the Polymer lib two years ago
at Google  I/O.  We were trying
to see would it be possible to
tie the low level specs together
to make it easier for
developers to create reusable
components.  And the answer,
yes, but it n eeds to be faster,
last year at Google I/O we
announced Polymer 1.0.  It was a
ground up rewrite of the
library focused on making it
fast, lean, ready to use in
production and it was
significantly faster.  Three to
four times faster than the
developer preview version for
element construction.  With 1.0
we want 9 to show the Web
component process was not just
theoretical but you could use
Web components in production
today.  Since this 1.0 launch,
the library has seen in, many
new features and enhancements
and it's gotten even faster so
since this 1.0 release which i
tself was three to four times
faster than the original
developer preview the latest
version is now another 10%
faster on Safari and another 25%
faster on Chrome for element
construction.
(
Applause).
So everything we do with Polymer
we build is open source first
on github in the open and we
pull the latest releases into
Google conversion Tim to Google
teams can use Polymer for their
applications.  Polymer is one
of the fastest growing front end
technologies within Google.
Over 400 Google projects today
are using Polymer with over
4,000 unique components built by
Google teams to use in their
products and Polymer is already
launched in production across
major Google properties,
including Chrome, translate,
play music, You Tube gaming,
Google 5 and the Google I/O Web
App which I'm sure you are
familiar with.  You can see how
serious a strategic initiative
Polymer is for Google and that
it's already being serve in
production to over a billion
users on Google products.  Not
only that, Polymer is being used
outside of Google by companies
big and small.  In fact, Polymer
adoption in the wild has
quietly skyrocketed.  There are
over 4 million Web pages using
policy mer on the open Web and
many large companies are
investing in Polymer and Web
components for the future of
their front end stacks.  I want
to talk about a couple of these
companies today.  The first is
net-a-porter.  Net-a-porter is
a online leader in fashion.
They discovered Polymer at
Google a year ago.  They started
implementing individual pieces
of their products with Polymer
elements.  They have a complete
end-to-end life cycle for all of
the components they use across
all of their sites and pages.
They have their custom Yeoman
for generating net-a-porter
components.
They generate documentation to
make it easier for engineers to
across the team to use other
components other engineers have
built.  And then they use the
components across all of the
different pages across the
net-a-porter site which allows
them to have visual consistency
because it's the same components
and functional consistency.
And this has made it much easier
for the net-a-porter to scale
this very large multifaceted
site by reusing the same
components.  Second company I
want to talk about using Polymer
is BBVA.  BBVA is a
multinational banking group.
130,000 employees, 66 million
customers.  You can imagine with
such a massive operation in so
many countries they are going to
have many, many different types
of applications to build.
Rather than building a unique
one off native app every time
they switched to using Web
technology based on Polymer.
And so they have this internal
catalog that all of the
different components that their
teams build so instead of
building one off applications
they can take component from
this catalog to assemble
applications and when I say
assemble, I mean assemble.  Web
components lend themselves
nicely to drag and drop
WYSIWYG construction
experiences so they have built
these tools to create and
construct and assemble
applications out of the
components they have built.  And
this ease of application
creation has had a very tangible
benefit on their business.  For
the first project that they
switched to Polymer Web
components they saved 70% budget
and 50% time and the
engineering efforts are
significantly more scalable and
easier to manage.  So since 1.0,
Polymer has become faster, more
feature rich, it's seeing
exponential growth in Google
served to over a billion users
and major companies are
investing in Polymer and Web
components.  The Polymer library
is for building components,
major companies,
major Google products are
adopting these components and
building components but they are
not just building components.
They are building applications
out of these components.  So we
get this question asked a lot.
Web components are great but how
do they take these Web
components and construct an
application?  Our answer has
been components can be
arbitrarily complex.  You can
build a component out of other
components out of components,
and  yadda, yadda, you have got
an app.
But, of course, that's not a
very satisfying answer.
Developers wanted guidance on
how to put components together
in a platform idiot mattic way.
So recently as the team has
been growing as the project has
been growing, we have expanded
our focus a bit.  To think not
just about how to build Web c
omponents but also how to take
the Web components and build
full-fledged cutting edge mobile
Web Apps.  And not just any
kind of Web application but
progressive Web App, progressive
Web Apps that took all of the
right viet a viet amins and we
don't want to just build
progressive Web applications we
want to build great progressive
Web applications, great user
experiences.
How do you do this?  How do you
build a great progressive Web
App on the mobile Web with all
of the challenges that that
entails?  Of course, our answer
is to use the platform.  Use the
platform to build great apps.
Use what the broizer gives you
to achief minimal payload,
minimal overhead, design offline
first, and this is a hard
challenge.  So we wanted to make
this easier, to use the
platform to build cutting edge
progressive Web applications.
So I'm really excited today to
announce the Polymer app tool
box.
(Applause).
And the tool box is just a set
of components and tools based
around Web platform primitives
that make it easy to build
cutting edge progressive Web
applications.  So what's in the
tool box?  Well, all of the
things you would expect to build
a large scale progressive Web
App, components for layout,
routing, localization, storage,
and then a command line tool to
tie it together.  So let's go
through each of these one at a
time.  The fist is layout.  All
UI design begins with layout.
It's the visual structure that
makes up the application and a
high quality immersive mobile
app requires high quality app
structure.  It requires the a
pp-like look and feel that users
have come to expect on mobile
devices and those high quality
layout components, things like
Toolbars that will disappear
when you scroll down and
reappear when you scroll up or a
drawer that you open and you
can swipe it closed with
momentum.  These are components
that don't exist in HTML.
So we built it.  Using the
Polymer library, the app layout
elements.  An app layout has a
number of UI components that
make it easier to structure
mobile app like experiences and
they are designed to be f
lexible, responsive and  fast.
So app layout elements have
contained con K30E7B9s for t
hings like Toolbars, drawers and
headers.  You can use them
regardless of what your
application looks like.  They
are responsive by default so
they work across all different
screen sizes.  They make hard
things easy, things like fanly
scroll behaviors that user have
come to expect on mobile d
evices.  They critically help
insure Exhibit which
accessibility.
(Applause).
So let's take a look at a couple
of these
components.  Here is a really
simple example of using the app
layout components.  You have
drawer to the left and middle
section content that scrolls.  A
drawer opens and closes with
momentum.  You can swipe it
closed.  Then you have the
header layout section which is
the main content section that
the user can scroll through.
This is done declaratively in
markup and you are writing HTML
using Web components.  I want to
draw your Ascension to these
two attributes on the app
header, fixed and effects.
Fixed said I want the Toolbar to
remain fix as the user scrolls
and the waterfall effect says I
want a shadow to appear under
the Toolbar when the user
scrolls down so it looks like
the content is water falling out
from the Toolbar.  Nice shuttle
user experiences that make it
feel top quality.  You can get
more complicated.  Here is a
similar example, a little more
markup, and we have a few more
attributes on the app header
here.  The first is condenses.
So you can see when you get to
the top, the
header is expanded and large and
it condenses as the user
scrolls down.  Reveal says when
the user scrolls down below the
header,  hide the header and if
though scroll up slightly, show
the header again and then the
waterfall effect is the same
one.  So really subtle polish
that makes it look and feel like
a first class progressive
mobile Web App.  There are lots
of different combinations for
different attributes so we built
a demo called test drive.
Which literally allows you to
tick off the boxes and let's you
experience what that would feel
like.  So any animation that we
provide if you don't like it,
you can easily build your own
and plug it in to the app layout
components and get a completely
custom look and feel.  We can
lay out our application.  What
if we want  multiple views.  How
do we route between multiple
views?  This is a common
question we have gotten.
What router should I use?  We
have said they are just Web c
omponents, use whatever router
they want.  There are tons of
JavaScript routers out there.
We surveyed the router space and
we realized that most
JavaScript routers have a single
global view of the world.  And
we wanted to build a router that
didn't just work with Web
components but that works like
Web components and that it was
modular and composable, that it
could route from an entire
application down to a single
component.  So we built the app
route component.  Let's say you
wanted to build a typical
application you have three r
outes/item/cart and you want to
route between different views.
You could use the app route
component to have a path that
will match on the royalty.  It
will provide a -- route, it will
provide a property and you can
easily toggle on and off
different views in your
application.  It can get more
complicated than that.  Let's
say you wanted to extract data
from that URL, from that route.
So you have/detail/item ID and
you want to extract that item ID
value to use in your a
pplication.  App route lets you
do that.  And it provides the
value of the item ID as a
property on the DOM node.  And
what's cool about app route is
you could have this at the top
of your document, you could have
it globally like a typical r
outer or you could compose this
app route into the component
responsible for showing this
detail of you.  So you can
delegate the responsibility of
deciding how to use this item ID
value to the component that
actually is going to show that
view.  So the app route is
flexible, modular, composable,
it
doesn't just work with Web
compone ebilities, it can know
about your entire app or it can
be responsible for routing one
small section of your
application.
That's great!  We can lay out
the application.  We can route
between different views.  What
if we want to localize our UI?
What if we want to translate it
into different languages?  A
gain, very common question.  We
have always said they are just
Web components there are a
million ways to localize an app.
Use whatever one is most
appropriate for what you are
building.  We wanted to build an
idio mattic platform embracing
way.  We built the app localized
behavior.  What is great is it
uses the platform.  It uses the
Intel object which is a standard
JavaScript object to provide
localization data.  It's broadly
cross-browser supported and
where it doesn't support it
there is a polyfill.  So use the
app localized behavior you use
it in any in any Polymer
component responsible for  for
translating strings.  To use app
localized behavior you add it
as a behavior to your component
and you give it two properties.
The first is a language
property which will be the
language you want this component
to be translated to and we have
it statically defined here that
you could bind to it to
dynamically switch it.  Then we
will give it this resources
property which is going to be
all of the different keys and
translation strings we are going
to need for this particular
component.  Here again it's
statically defined but we could
easily fetch this off the
network, however, we want to
provide this resources to the
component.  And then to use
these resources to localize the
component, anywhere we have a
string, instead of the static
string, we will bind to the
localize function.  We will pass
it a key at any variable, any
content that will need to be in
that spring.  And so what you
can achieve with it is you can
achieve simple strings but also
localize currencies, numbers and
dates and it supports plurals
and genders.  So a simple tool
that uses the platform to
elegantly solve complex use
cases.
(Applause).
So we are doing great.  We can
lay out the application, we
request route between views we
can localize views.  Let's say
we want to store data and we
want to store data on the Cloud
offer locally on the device to
use in your application.  Again,
very similar conundrum, how do
I connect data to my app.  We
wanted to provide a platform I
DIO mattic way to take  data
from the Cloud and provide it to
the platform.  So we built app
storage.  What app storage is
it's essentially an interest
every face.  It allows you, the
developer to create your own Web
component to connect data from
a service whether in the Cloud
or on the device and surface
that data in a way that the ache
can use.  The way that app
storage surfaces the data is in
an idiot mattic way.  Prescribe
any changes are expressed as DOM
events and conveniently that is
how Polymer's own data mining
system works it uses the
platform mode.  So app storage
provides turnkey integration.
So let's give an example of how
you might use this.  Say you are
building a note taking
progressive Web App you will
want to launch from the home
screen because it's progressive
Web App.  You can add title,
information to your notes and
all of this data you are going
to store in a rest API you have
built in the Cloud.  But it's a
progressive Web App so it needs
to be able to work off line.  So
if we go off line, launch from
the home screen if we are r
elying on getting data from our
rest API, we are not going to be
able to launch the application
at all.  We are not going to
have access to the Internet to
launch that application.  But
app storage makes it easy to
architect your app so you can
support this use case very
simply.  So here is how we are
going to build it.  You are
going to build your own
component that implements this
app storage interface, your
Cloud API component and that
will manage coming up indicating
with your rest API in the Cloud
and then you will use a
component app indem DB mirror
that we have provided.  What
that does is take data that's
passed through it and mirrors it
into a local index DB instance
and that will pass data into
your application.
So here is how it looks when the
data is wired up.  When you are
on line your Cloud API
component has no problem
interfaces with your rest API.
It's going to pipe that data
through the index DB in mirror
component which will pipe the
data to your app.  So you are on
line.  When you go off line,
your Cloud API component can no
longer communicate with the rest
end point, but since we have
been piping that data through
the app index DB mirror
component we have all of that
locally stored on the device so
we can boot up our application
even when we are off line.  But
what if you don't want to build
your own  component?  What if
you wanted to use a database as
a service in the Cloud?
Well, fortunately there is an
element for that the app storage
element with  Polymerfire.
(Applause).
So Polymerfire is actually a
coat of Polymer-based Web
components that the Firebase
team has built that makes it
trivial to communicate with the
Firebase database instance and
to use that data in
your application.  Okay.  We
are d oing great, we can lay out
our application.  We can route
between views.  We can localize
those views.  We can commune
carte with a back end and store
data, but we still need to
deliver the application to our
users.
And, remember, this is the
mobile Web, flaky 3G connections
are the norm, slow devices are
the norm we mean min nail
payload and JavaScript and
maximum efficiency to be able to
minimize time to first m
eaningful action for our users.
This is the great challenge.
So there is the hard way.  We
can use the same old JavaScript
escape hatch.  We can build a
massive tool chain, server side
render, get a fast first paint
with the serve side rendered app
and then  down load, boot it up
and make it interactive.  But
23-Z frustrating to sit and
watch a splash screen.
And time to first flash screen,
time to first spinner is not the
same thing as time to first
meaningful interaction.  So
server side rendering like this
to deliver an application
whether you get an app view or a
spinner is really a poo tem kin
village your user has to wait
for the extraction to load
before the plirks is
application is u seful.  We
think there is a better way,
which is to use the Platte norm
to deliver apps.  The tighter
the platform you can build your
application the faster it will
be especially on slow networks
and devices.  Let the browser be
your application.
And thanks to brand new Web
platform primitives we can throw
out a lot of the old knowledge
about how to make an application
fast on mobile and embrace new
primitives and technologies that
the browser provides.
So there are really three
important primitives for
delivering a modern mobile Web
application, Web components
which allow you to construct
your application out of these
granular dependencies, out of
granular components, HTTP2 and
server push which allows you to
serve granular dependencies in a
granular way to users without
incurring massive round trips
and to most efficiently utilize
the bandwidth and then service
worker which let's you  reliably
cache granular components
components op you're user's
device.  Let's take a look at
how they work together nicely.
We have built the app before, we
have three routes.  Each has a
view, they share similar UI
between the views.
If we built this the old way as
an old skill single-page app,
for each of these views no
matter which route the user hit
we would have none no lithic H
TML and we would send all of
them down to the client and on
the client the framework would
boot up, then the application,
then it would match the route to
the view and render that view.
Obviously very slow, obviously
very inefficient.
Let's take a step back.  We have
three views here, some are
independent, some overlap in
terms of what they show on the
screen.  Let's use the platform
to serve this application as
efficiently as possible.  So
let's split the view down, let's
break it down into individual
Web components, some of these
components will be shared
between views, some will be
unique to a particular view.
Let's say the user requests t
his/route.  The server can know
exactly what components are
needed in order to render that
view and to make it usable on
the device.  And so the Serber
can use HTP2 and Serber push to
push down the min ma'am
components miles an hour mall
components needs to make the
view interactive without
multiple round trips.  We have
that on the device that the user
can start interacting with
minimal overhead and we can take
those granular components and
stick them in the service worker
cache.  Then in the background
as the user is interacting with
the first view the service w
orker can start fetching
additional granular components
from the network and pre-cache
those.  We can get those from
the network and stick those two
in its service worker cache.  So
that if the user then navigates
to the next view slash item
there's is a good comans that
you will already have every
component that you will need to
render that view and make it
interactive already right there
sitting in your cache.  You
don't have to go to the network
at all.  But, of course, it's
not practical to necessarily
cache every dependencecy for
your application so for future
views you can lazily load and
lazily instantiate additional
components you need to render
shows views.  Some of those
might be sitting in your cache
and for those that aren't, you
can use the server to push down
only the minimal set of
dependencies that the user
doesn't already have in their
cache.  So there is a pattern
starting to emerge here.  You
push components that are needed
for your initial route, you
render that initial route and
make it interactive as soon as
possible, you pre-cache in the
background using service worker,
additional components needed
for remaining routes, and then
you lazy load and create future
routes on demand as the user
navigates to them.  We like
acronyms on the Polymer project
so we have been calling this the
purple pattern.  And the purple
pattern is not Polymer
specific, it's just a pattern
for progressively loading and
representedderring a modern
progressive Web App using
technologies and primitives in
the Web platform.  So with the
purple pattern you get min ma'am
payload,  minimal overhead,
minimal time to first
interaction and optimal user
experience and the crux of the
pattern is the ability to break
up application into individual
granular components which
require minimum overhead to
build up.
PRPL pattern, how do we align i
t?  There are different  tools
for building and opt miosessing
component-based applications and
we wanted a maximally simple
tool to make it easier to get
started building an application
using this pattern to develop
and ultimately to build and to
play it.  We built the Polymer C
LI, the Polymer command line
Command Line
Tool.  And the goal of the
Polymer CLI is to stay focused
and simple.  It provides a few
set of commands that can help
support you throughout the
entire development experience
whether building a Polymer
component or an entire
application out of Web c
omponents.  So this includes
Polymer and knit which makes it
easy to  scaffold out a Web
component or an application
built out of Web components and
it will set up the folder
structure needed for these two
and we built starter templates
to get you started with
applications you might want to
build.  Polymer serve will
locally serve your application
or your component so that you
can play with it as you develop,
and what's cool about Polymer
serve is that not only will it
serve your component and your
application, it will also serve
all of the documentation
automatically generated from all
of the components that you are
using to build your application,
so you can develop on a second
browser tab you can have all of
the documentation you are using
to develop.  So it's a great
experience.
(Applause).
Polymer lint will lint your code
and check for common errors
that occur when you are building
with Web components in Polymer
and Polymer build will let us
specify a main entry point and
then an application shell and it
will generate a bundled and
unbundled version of your
application that you can then
serve.  The unbundled version is
perfect for serving with the P
RPL pattern.  We also generate a
bundled version for a fall back
for browsers that don't yet
support HTP2.
And Polymer build also uses a
tool called service worker
pre-cache to generate service
workers that do this p
re-caching, pre fetching and
sticking components in the cache
for you so you don't have to
write a line of service worker
code.  All of it is generated
for you based on your
application.
(Applause).
So that's the tool box.  L
ayout, routing, localization,
storage, and a command line tool
to tie it together.  And you
might be thinking didn't we just
build another stack?  Didn't we
just build another monolithic
stack?  But this stack is
different.  In fact, it's not a
stack at all.  It is just a set
of loosely coupled interoperable
Web components that can be used
piecemeal individually or all
together and it's not a mono
inning  m onolith.  Each
component is a light weight
layer on top of platform
primitives that already exist in
the browser.  So with the
Polymer app tool box, we are
showing that you don't need a
massive meta  platform.  You
don't need a mega framework to
build a high quality Web
application.  You don't need t
ons of JavaScript.  You just
need to use the platform and use
all of the modern primitives
that the Web platform provides.
Now, of course, we didn't want
this to just be a theoretical
exercise.  So we built an app
using all of these techniques.
We call is Shup.  As an e
Commerce application.  It
doesn't actually sell Google
gear so you can't check out and
buy anything so don't expect
anything to show up  at your d
oor.  It has a home page,
product listing view, individual
product pages and it's got a
cart and check out.  And it's
built and served using all of
these components, using all of
these patterns, Web component,
service worker, HTP2 and the P
RPL pattern.  And the Polymer C
I to develop and build.  You can
check out this demo as well as
everything that's in the tool
box and documentation about all
of the things in the tool box at
the brand new Polymer documents
site WWW.Polymer project.
org.  So in summary, the Polymer
project's approach to modern
Web development is different.
It's different than that of a
typical JavaScript framework.
Because it uses the platform, it
uses what's already there in
user's frauders rather  user's
broaders rather than creating
massive abstractions on top.
And thanks to these new powerful
Web platform from time to t
imeitives this is finally
possible as Web developers to
create these ingaging immersive
app-like services on the Web.
So the result of using the
platform is a first class
progressive Web App built out of
interoperable Web components.
So if you would like to learn
more about Polymer or Web
components or the PRPL pattern
there are tons more talks here
good exactly this.  Progressive
performance Polymer is right
after this one is there are two
more tomorrow.  And if you have
a time machine or a You Tube,
you can check out the talks that
have already happened
earlier.  So I'm really excited
by this.  I hope you are too.
And if you would like to learn
more about Polymer, about
progressive Web Apps about the
PRPL pattern, there is a
conference for that the next
Polymer summit which will be
later this year in London.
(Applause).
So you can sign up at this link
to be notified when registration
opens.  If it's anything like
last year's Polymer summit that
we held in Amsterdam.  It's
going to be awesome!  There were
800 developers in a beautiful
vend you.  A full day of talks,
I night of code labs and I'm
excited to do it all again.  So
that's all for today.  I hope to
see you at the Polymer summit
and, remember, use the flat f
orm.  Thank you!  (
(Applause).
(Please stand by for
.
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hello, e
veryone!  Welcome to
Instant Loading: Building
Offline-First Progressive
Web Apps.
It turns out if you put all
the buzz words in your
title they let you have the big
stage.  I'm Jake
Archibald one of the designers
of ServiceWorker and
one of the editors of the spec
as well.  I want to
talk to you about spam phone
calls which I get a lot
of.  You know the sort, have
you been in an accident
in the last 200 years?  Would
you like cars in for
all of wore pets, et cetera, et
cetera?  I actually
get enough of these phone calls
that I started invent
inventing games to play.  My
favorite game is, hmm,
and in this game I become the
most indecisive person
that has ever existed.
It goes like this:  Hello,
Mr. Archibald.  Are you
interested in saving money on
your mobile phone bill?
I reply ...  Hmm, well, I
suppose if ... at this
point the caller usually tries
to hurry things along
but it's very important that
you do not let them.
Well, we've got a great deal
.  Wait, wait, wait.
Do you, hmm ... is it one of
the hmm ... hmm ...
And you get a point for ever
y second that they
aren't talking.  It's a really
difficult game because
the caller gets frustrated
quickly.  You are directly
blocking a conversation which
is a very synchronous
transaction where each person
wants an instant
response and you are breaking
that model.  We expect
the same thing when you get
data from a computer.
Twenty-five years ago the
expectations were low.  If
you wanted to know directions
somewhere, you would
have to go to the room with the
computer in it.  The
room.  Turn it on and the fans
would start whirring.
You get the static crack em as
the CRT would start.
Windows 3.1 would start booting
up.  Eventually you
get your desktop.  Then it did
this.
(Sound of Windows starting.)
(Laughter.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: This is
an era when booting up
was a fanfare worthy moment.
Even after that you had
to find and insert the map
credited and print off
directions, off you went.
These days we don't have
to boot up the one computer we
own.  We have a
computer in our pocket already
booted up and we can
give it directions.
If you have zero
connectivity and you ask the
Internet for something, the Web
's answer is often:
No.  I remember when I first
realize ed how problematic
this is.  A few years ago I was
working at a Web
agency.  I found myself needing
to go to the toilet
following a lunch that my
stomach was unhappy about.
There were five cubicles to
choose from.  In this
instance the first four were
occupied.  That's
usually okay.  Even in this
situation I felt that one
cubicle would be enough for me.
(Laughter.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: But from
previous experience I
knew that mobile connectivity
and the office WiFi
only extended to the first four
cubicles.
(Laughter.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: I thou
ght for a moment and
decided, no, this is not
acceptable.  And I returned
to my desk and I waited until
later despite being in
some discomfort. day that I
discovered that as a human
being I required an Internet
connection in order to
take a dumb due process
(Laughter.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: So this
is a problem worth
solving.  Until recently there
was nothing you could
do about it, especially during
the initial page work
but that all changes with
ServiceWorker.  I was told
this slide wasn't impactful
enough.  It's one of
those management buzz words I
don't really understand
understand.  I did give it
another go and came up
with this.
(Laughter.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Apparently this has branding
issues.  It's got loads of
brands that I don't
understand.
Bruce Lawson, deputy CTO of
Opera he gave it a go
and came up with this.  It's
freakky.  If you stare
at it, it looks like the colors
are changing.  They
are.  It has a filter on it.
But Ben Jaffe, he had a go,
at udacity, he came up
up:
>>: Too long, users have
been left staring at a
white screen.  Too long they
have been let down by
the cruel network connectivity.
Too long we have
been powerless to help.
We have been left waiting.
By no longer.  A new browse
er feature has arrived.
A total game change er.
A feature that lets you
control the network.
Rather than letting the
network control you.
Who is this new feature?
What promises does it
bring?
Introducing the ServiceWorker!
(Dramatic music.)
(Cheers and applause.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's a
bit much, isn't it,
really?  I prefer mine.  It's
got a high fie with a
cat's head in it.  What does
this all mean?  What can
ServiceWorker really do.  We're
going to look
at
emoji joy.
look atEmojoy!  A little
progressive web app you can
find athis URL.  It's a
simple version of Hangouts, but
only lets you enter Emoji. It
started life as a mere website,
but over time it was built up
to a full progressive web app.
And it didn't require a full
rewrite, it was something that
happened incrementally,
This here is V1. It runs at
60 fps It's really simple, so I
didn't use any kind of
framework, so it's only 25k -
loads fast Unless of course
experience isn't optimal.  Or
at least this is what it was
like when I first launched it.
Here's how I fixed itTo
begin, register for a
ServiceWorker . And it isn't
some magic manifest, or a
config file. It's just
JavaScript Why invent some new
thing, then we have a world
full of JS devs.  And loads of
tooling.
Oh, but of course we should
wrap our register call in a
basic feature detect because,
wellThere are older browsers
out there that don't support
SW. And a simple feature detect
prevents them hurting
themselves and others. And in
that scriptI'll just put a
simple log.
Now if I load the
page Open Chrome's Devtools
Console. There it is! There's
our log.
Also in the new application
tab there's a ServiceWorker
section. And there's our
ServiceWorker there!  As you
can see, it was last modified
in 1970.  Meaning this
ServiceWorker predates the
internet .So we're way ahead of
we'll have that fixed soon.
So, how has this changed
things? To find out, let's pit
the original online-only site
against our shiny new
ServiceWorker version. Let's go
tothe compare-inator.  First
First.
Up, the online experience.
So, okay.  Pretty much
the same.  Both load reasonably
quick.  I recorded
these with a
these with a throttled internet
connection.  Or as most of the
world calls it, their internet
connection. I also closed the
browser before clicking the
shortcut. So the load time
includes the browser loading.
What aboutOffline? GO!
Okay, so, both failing.  Now,
you've probably noticed, not
much has changed. Well, one
thing happenedIt logged .
That's how swo weds works.
I'm sick of the magic
APIs.  Compare to Appcache if
we gave Emojoy a --
Compare it to AppcacheIf
we gave Emojoy an Appcache
manifestAnd that manifest is
empty aside from Cache Manifest
which is required to make it a
valid manifest. That would turn
the render of Emojoy from this
to this.
And II can't help feeling
that isn't what I told it to do
Appcache was a bit of a
disaster. It had a very simple
format, but a massive
complicated rulebook. And if
you didn't like any of those
rules, tough .You were
restricted to the way the
designers of Appcache wanted
you to work. And those
designers hadn't created many
offline web experiences.
This gave rise to the
extensible web manifesto,which
most browser vendors are now
behind. Here we acknowledge
that browser developers and
standards developers, are NOT
better at building web sites
than web developers. We should
stop tossing out scraps from
our ivory towers - like
Appcache, like a CSS to do a
reflection in one particular
way. And instead, give
developers full control.  Give
you as much information as we
can, and as many hooks as we
can.
By providing you with this
kind of low-level access, you
can create things we didn't
consider. You can use patterns
we didn't invent.  And those
become evidence for higher
level features that make the
common stuff easier, or faster
. ServiceWorker was built to
this model, so the things I
show you today are just the
patterns I us. But you'll find
your own patterns that work
best for what you're building.
The ServiceWorker is driven by
events. One of these isFetch!
So I've got a listener for
that. With a debugger
statement.  Before I run that,
I'm going update on reload
using this checkbox.  I'll
cover why in a bit.
Now if I refresh the page, I
hit that break point.  The
event object has a request
property. This is the request
for the page itself. The
request object shows me the
URL, headers, type of request.
But I also get one of these
events for every request the
page makes. The CSS, JS, fonts,
images.  I get an event for the
avatars even though they're on
another origin.
By-default requests go from
the page to the network. And
there's not a lot you can do
about it. But once you
introduce a ServiceWorker, it
controls pages, and requests go
through it.  But like other
events, you can prevent the
default, and do your own thing.
So instead of triggering the
debuggerI'm going to call
event.respond.with.  And I'm
going to respond with a
response. It says hello.
Let's give that a spin.
Refresh the page and
there it is.
So instead of going to the
network, the
ServiceWorker took care of it.
This example works
offline.  It's rubbish but it
works offline.  You
don't have
to
You don't have to respond to
every URL the same either. You
could parse the URL. And if the
pathname ends in .jpg respond
with a network fetch for
cat.jpg. Event.repond.with
takes a response object, or a
promise for a response fetch
returns us a promise for a
response from the network. So
they compose really well. So if
we refresh the page and it's
back, but all the avatars are
cats! Instead of doing
something special based on the
request, you can do things
based on the response .
Here I respond with a fetch
for event.request . This tells
the browser to make the same
request it would have anyway,
but fetch returns a promise for
a response. So we can take a
look at it. And if its status
code is 404, we respond with
svg or whatever else return
the
the.
Otherwise we return with the
response we got from
the ne
twork
So refresh the page. Our
avatars are back!  But if I
navigate to a nonsense URL,
there's our 404 message.
ServiceWorker lets you
intercept requests and provide
a different response. And you
can do that based on the
request, or the response of
another request .
But this is just playing
around really. You wouldn't use
ServiceWorker for a 404 page,
you'd let your server do that.
Let's do something practical
instead. A good way to dip your
foot into the SW pool is to
make an offline-fallback page,
something to show to the user
if the page fails to load.
Because the current state of
things is pretty bad. You know
the user comes to us wanting
our content. It's our moment to
shine. But without a connection
we crap ourselves to the extent
that Mama browser has to step
in and defend us by blaming the
user.  Chrome can't display
this page because "your"
computer isn't connected to the
internet.
If we're competing with
native, this is like an
operating-system error message.
We can do better.  So I created
a custom error page.  It's
still an error, but at least
we're owning it . And it's
something we can build on
later.
I want to show this when
there's no connection. So I
need to save it somewhere, and
I want to store it up front.
The ServiceWorker has an event
for doing things up-front install . And I pass a promise
to wait until to let the
ServiceWorker know I'm doing
install work. The install event
is fired the very first time
the browser runs the
ServiceWorker. It's your
opportunity to get everything
you need from the network.
CSS, Java scrip, HTML and
all this stuff
Before you need to start
controlling pages.
For storing these requests
and responses, there's a new
storage API. The cache API.
This cache API specializes in
request/response storage, but
unlike the regular browser
cache, stuff isn't removed at
the browser's whim. So we put
all our stuff in there.  Once
that's done, our SW can move in
and start controlling pages.
So let's do that.  We open a
cache. We can call it whatever
we want, but I'm calling it
static-v1. Then we add the
offline page, and the CSS. If
the cache fails to open, runs
out of space, or one of these
fetches fails or returns a 404.
The promise rejects, signalling
to the browser that the install
failed. If that happens, this
SW will be discarded.
So once we're controlling .
It will never return pages
So once we're controlling
pages, we know this cache
population worked. Note that
both the offline page and CSS
have a version in their URL.
This means we can give them
good caching headers, and we
just change the URL when their
content changes.
You can work around bad
caching with a SW, but it's
much better to work with good
caching. But now we need to use
this cache over in our fetch
event . We'll respond with a
match in the cache, one that
matches this request.Matching
is done similar to HTTP
matching. So it matches on URL,
method, vary headers, but it
ignores freshness headers.
Match returns a promise for a
response.
So if we request the offline
page directly, or the CSS, it
comes straight from the cache.
If there's no match found, it
resolves with undefined.  So we
return the response if we get
get.
So we need to respond to
that
resolves with undefined.  So we
return the response if we get
one or do a regular network
fetch for the content. If the
fetch fails, it'll reject the
promise. So we'll catch that.
And if the request was a
navigation we'll return our
offline page from the cache.
We only want to return our
offline page for navigations.
It won't help if we return it
for images, or javascript, et
cetera. But that's it
changed, but over in the
application tab there's a bit
that shows our caches. There's
static V1, and our offline
page
and CSS If we simulate offline
and refresh. There we go! Done.
Ship it.
We can ship this.
And that's what The Guardian
did on their developer blog. If
you don't have any connectivity
it serves you a sorry page but
also gives you a crossword to
do instead.  I'm no good at
crosswords, but this is a
lovely Easter egg. Actually, I
didn't even look at the clue
when I recorded this.  A
Californian city, 3 letters
then 9 letters. I probably
should have got that one.
Of course, we may want to
make changes to this in future.
Maybe add some things like a
refresh button or some JS that
keeps checking to see if
connectivity returns. And to do
that you need to work with
ServiceWorker's update system,
which we've been avoiding so
far thanks to this checkbox.
Let's take those training
wheels off.  Let's say we
wanted to change the text here
to say "no connectivity" rather
than "no connection."  Well,
we'll change our offline page's
html . But we need to update
our ServiceWorker too. The URLs
are generated from the file's
content. So we'll need to
change the URL for offline
page.  Bingo! There we go.
page.
And we'd make the same
change in our fetch event, so
we're serving up this new page.
We're also going to change the
version of the cache, from 1 to
2. And I'll show you why in a
moment.  But let's give that a
spin. Reload the page to pick
up those changes. Change the
network state to 'offline' And
reload again.
But the text hasn't changed.
It still says connection, not
connectivity. Here's what
happened. We reloaded the page,
which triggered the browser to
check the ServiceWorker for
updates. It fetched the
ServiceWorker and went, huh,
this is different to the one I
have. And it spins it up .
As a new version running
alongside the old version, but
the old one remains because the
new one isn't ready yet. The
new one goes through its
install event. Get all the
stuff it needs, including the
new offline page. Then it puts
them in the cache. That's why
we gave the cache a different
name, so it wouldn't overwrite
the stuff the old version was
using.  By default, the new
version wait. It doesn't take
over while the old version is
in use because having multiple
tabs open to the same site
running different versions Is a
huge source of really nasty
difficult-to-debug stuff.
We could see this waiting
ServiceWorker in devtools, in
the resources panel. We've got
a ServiceWorker that's active,
but we also have a
ServiceWorker waiting. We can
also see our new cache in the
caches view. This new worker
worker.
-- static V2 will be there
as well.  This one will
stay there until the old one is
in longer in use.
When this closes, there's
nothing left to control.
The old version isn't needed
anymore.  It becomes,
well, re-dun Dan
redundant and it goes away.
(Sad music.)
But that means the new
version can move in and start
controlling pages. We can make
that happen by navigating away.
Still in offline mode. Then
clicking back.
And there we go, the text
has changed. We still have that
old cache hanging around,
though, but we can deal with
that. Once the old SW is gone,
the new SW gets an activate
event and we can use that to
perform cleanup and migrate
databases if we want to.
I tend to have an array of
caches I expect to be there.
Then I use the activate event
to go through the caches and
delete the ones that aren't in
that array. It's a slightly
ugly bit of code, but you
can
can.
--
This behavior of one SW
waiting for another is the
default, but it doesn't have to
be this way. Your new worker
can call skip waiting, which
means it doesn't want to wait
behind an older version. That
just kicks the old version out
and takes over straight away.
Just be aware you're now
controlling pages that were
loaded with some older
ServiceWorker.
You can track this happening
from pages if you want to show
messages like "refresh to get
the latest version."  Or maybe
you can get away with
auto-refreshing if the user
hasn't interacted yet.  But for
most of development, I really
recommend update on reload.
This checkbox in the
ServiceWorker panel. This
changes the update flow to
speed things up.
With update-on-reload, you
hit refresh, the browser
fetches the ServiceWorker from
the network. It treats it as a
new version, even if it hasn't
changed. It installs so all the
caches get updated with the
latest stuff.
And once that's done it
kicks the old version out Takes overAnd then the page
refreshe. That's a lot, but the
result is you get your latest
ServiceWorker  and  assets
every load.
Okay, that was a lot to take
in, but how are we doing? We
must return to the
compare-inator.  First up:
ONLINE GO! Well, we haven't
changed anything, but content
is still arriving pretty
quickly.
How about: Offline? GO! Yay,
we're taking responsibility for
network failures. We're
catching the error .We can ship
this .
But we're not quite a
progressive web app yet. We
need to tell the browser we're
ready to offer a native-like
experience. In the head of the
page we can declare a theme
color, which Chrome uses to
style the location bar.  So
that's a quick win, but we want
users to be able to add this to
their homescreen.  And there's
a lot of ways to do that to
cover all the browsers.
You'll need to specify an
icon, and icon, and probably
another icon.  And did I
mention the icon? Most of this
meta crap isn't needed until
the user opts into adding your
site to their homescreen.
Meanwhile it's being sent down
with every page Increasing the
time to first render.
So we got rid of this and
replaced it with a
reference to a manifest.  It no
longer clogs up the
load of every page.
Furthermore it's a great time to
standardize the meat crap.
Once you have this and
the ServiceWorker,
interested in this site. This
icon here comes from the icon
field in the manifest. You can
specify icons of multiple
sizes, and Chrome will pick the
one closest to what it needs.
Here I'm just serving one
512x512 icon and letting Chrome
do the scaling. You should
serve smaller icons if your
large icon is a big download.
But in this case the big icon
is 5 kilobytes. The name comes
from the name property. You see
how this works.
Then, if the user taps "add
to homescreen," they get an
icon on their homescreen. We've
already seen where the icon
comes from, but the text
beneath it comes from the short
name. If your short name and
name are the same, you can omit
short name. Later when the user
launches your app, a
splashscreen is displayed while
the browser is spinning up and
the page is loading.
The icon comes from the icon
list. If you have multiple
icons listed it'll go for one
of the bigger ones. The name
here comes from the name field.
The background color comes from
the background color and the
color of the status bar is from
the theme color.
Then once the page is ready,
the splashscreen goes away. The
page that loaded is the one
listed as the start URL. This
is pretty cool as it means your
site can make use of many URLs
but have a specific starting
location when launched. But
you'll also notice the URL bar
isn't there. That's because
this web app is standalone.
All this adds together to
make the whole experience feel
like a native app. And that's
why it becomes so important
that we, at the very least, own
our own connection errors. We
don't want the default browser
error breaking this native
feel. We can ship this, it's an
incremental improvement. When
developing offline-capable
sites, it's a common error to
start iterating on this. For
example, make it show cached
messages, make it a fuller
offline experience. But that's
an online-first approach, which
works fine if the user is truly
offline.
But zero connectivity is not
the worst thing we face. This
is. I call it Lie-fi This is
when your phone says it has
connectivity, but it doesn't
really.  If you have lie-fi and
you ask for content, the web
says ummmmmmm ummmmmmm. Well
ifummmmmmmmm .
And this is it, it's worse
than offline. With offline you
get a quick answer. But here,
you're just left waiting. You
I'm sure you've had this
yourself.
You
done want to give up.
don't want to give up, just in
case the data arrives in the
next few seconds. But does it?
o!  You're forcing the user
to stare at this, or give up.
And with every passing second,
they hate the experience a
little more.
Our current online-first
pattern works great when the
user has a good connection.
They get the latest messages
pretty fast.  It's great when
the user's offline, because
they instantly get some cached
data, or a failure page.  But
with lie-fiThis is it. Chrome
removes the splashscreen when
the page renders. With lie-fi,
the page never renders. We've
improved things for offline
users, but lie-fi users are in
the same hell as they were
before.
This is the problem with
online-first.  We're giving
users with some connectivity a
worse experience than users
with no connectivity. And this
isn't just down to poor
connectivity on the user's
device. Sometimes you can have
full signal, and still be
experiencing lie-fi.  A lot
happens to get data from the
web. The phone sends the
request to the wifi router or
cell tower. Then on to the ISP,
through intermediate proxies;
potentially across to the other
side of the world And
eventually the request reaches
the destination server.
But that's only half the
journey because the server
responds, and that response
needs to go all the way back
across the world, through
proxies, through ISPs, over the
air, and land safe and sound on
your phone. But if something
along the way runs slowly, the
whole thing runs slow .And
therein lies lie-fi. And you
don't know how good the network
connection is until you try.
And that takes time
There are a couple of APIs
on the web that attempt to
predict
the network, such as
as.
That's interesting.  There
was supposed to be a
slide there.is not part of the
act.  It's just some fun.ALD:
Oh, yeah!
>>Audience: Lie-fi!
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: Lie-fi.
No this entire
presentation works offline.
Maybe I'll unplug this
and plug it back in again?
(Chuckles.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: Do we
have a dodgy connection
here?
Don't present for ... I do
want to present from my
own laptop.
How are we for the -- oh, my
God, it's starting to
work!  This is amazing!  So my
colleagues always tell
me I'm stupid for doing my own
slide framework.
There we go!  Let's see if
this continues to work.
Oh, my God, it's working ag
ain.  Yes!
(Cheers and applause.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: Okay, h
ere we go.  Where was I
I?  There are a couple of APIs
in the Web that
attempt to predict the network.
These are navigate
navigate -- those are weak
signals.  Those APIs only
know about that bit.  They
don't know about any of
the rest.  For instance, when
navigate.online is
false, you have no connection.
That much is certain
when navigator.onLine is on you
have no --
navigator.onLine is true when
you are connected to a
cell tower or router although
that may only be plug
plugged into some soil.
(Laughter.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Navigator.onLine will still be
true.  Anything have that first
hop cannot be predict
predicted.  You have to make a
connection and see.
That takes time.  If user wants
to look at past
messages why should they need a
connection?  Why
should they have to wait for a
connection to fail
just to see stuff already on
their phone?  The great
thing about local data, you
don't need to make an
Internet connection for it.
This is why the gold st
andard is Offline-First.
Offline-First solves these
problems.  You get content
from the network and the more
you get to render bout
a connection, the better.
Think of the network as a
piece of enhancement, an
enhancement that might not
be there.  We need to rethink
our approach a bit here
here.  I'm going to create an
application shell and
that's just a site without
messages.  We'll leave it
to Javascript to populate it.
So we are going to
change the install event so it
caches the app shell,
the CSS and the Javascript.
Meanwhile over in the fetch
event we start by
parse ing the URL so we can
read the component part.
If the request is to the same
origin as the
ServiceWorker and the path name
is slash, the root
page, we respond with the app
shell from the cache.
Done.  Otherwise we'll respond
to cache content and
fall back to the network.  So
all together, we are
going to fetch the HTML, CSS
and Javascript from the
cache and that gets us the
first render.  And that
goes to the network and gets
the messages for us
which gets the render going for
us.  That can show a
error message as well.
Doing all that, what do we
win?  It is time to
return to the compare
inato  tor.
How are we doing?  The onlin
e experience.  Look at
that, we massively improved the
render time.  The
messages are coming from the
sappled old network,
they come because the down
loads starts earlier.
What about offline?  Great, the
app shell opened and
the pages of Javascript showed
no connection error.
What about lie-fi?  So we have
the blank screen.  The
Java discriminate can show a
spinning or something,
but you can see the benefits of
Offline-First versus
online first.  Rather than
improving things for one
connection time, we improved
across the board.  It
has taken us little code to get
there.  We can ship
this.
What about cache ing chat
mess      messages, displaying t
hose
those.  Messages arrive one by
one, the continual
feed of data is request and
response based.  We want
a store that we can add and
remove messages from.
The Web platform has such a
thing.  It is called
index DB.  Index DB has a bad r
eputation among
developers.  It's the worst API
ever designed in the
history of computer science.
Other than that it's
pretty good.  60 percent of the
awful comes from the event
system it uses.  It predates
promises.
If it was invented today it
would use promises.
There is a effort underway to
patch it up.  I prefer
teaching the, IDB is a little
liesh they put together
that mimics the, where it used
promises.  Other than
that you are still using method
names, with 60
60 percent of the awful
eliminate ed.
I much prefer teaching the
web platform rather than
libraries or frameworks, but
I'm going to make a bit of an
exception here. IDB is a little
library I built that mirrors
the IndexedDB API, but it uses
promises where IDB should have
used promises. But other than
that, you're using IDB, just
with 60% of the awful
eliminated.  It's 1.2k, but
there are bigger higher level
APIs out there such as dexie.
This library only eliminates
the worst of IDB.
So, let's build a database
for our messages Messages look
like this: They arrive in JSON
format.  Let's build an indexed
database for them using the IDB
library. Start by opening the
DB, giving it name "Emojoy."  1
is the version number of the
database.
Then we have a callback to
define it's schema. First we
need to create somewhere to
store the messages. Relational
databases call them tables. IDB
calls them object stores.  We
create one called messages, and
tell it our primary key is ID.
We're often going to look up
messages in date order, so
we'll create an index called
by-date on the date property.
And that's it, not too painful.
Now we can take this DB
promise and add messages to it
as they arrive. Say we had a
function like thisA function
that gets called every time a
new message arrives. And it's
added to the page.  We get our
database from the promise,
create a read/write transaction
on our messages store. Then add
the message to the object
store. I don't expect you to
remember all this code. I'm
just trying to show that
IndexedDB can be a little less
scary with promises.
Getting messages isn't too
bad either: Transaction on
messages. Go into the object
store. Get the index where
everything's date ordered. Get
them all. Done.
Of course, we can't just
keep adding messages into the
DB. We'll need to perform some
cleanup. Say we wanted to
delete everything but the
newest 30 messages. Create a
transaction. Get our date
index. Open a cursor. The
'prev' here means we go through
the index backwards . So
starting with the newest
message. Skip the first 30
items, since we want to keep
those. Then loop through the
rest calling delete on each
Okay, this isn't so pretty.
Like I said the library only
adds promises in. You're still
exposed to the rest of IDB's
ugliness. That's still a lot
cleaner than it would be in
standard IDB. Having a database
full of messages means we can
fetch our page shell, js, css
from the cache. Then render
with messages from the
database. We get content on
screen without going to the
network. Then we go to the
network for newer messages and
avatars And update the page.
If the network request
fails, doesn't matter, we're
displaying content .That's a
great offline experience. If
the network request is slow,
that might be okay if the user
is just wanting to check a
previous message.
To see the benefits of this,
we once again must gaze upon
the compare-inator
compare-inator
Fight!
difference! That's huge. What
about Offline? We have content!
Okay, the avatars have failed,
but hey, we've gone from a
total failure offline, to
instant content! This is way
better than the 'sorry' message
we had before. And how about
lie-fi? We've gone from the
most frustrating experience in
the world, the white screen of
eternal misery, to instant
content! We can Ship it!
The only missing bit in
terms of a full offline-first
experience, is the avatars. But
we can fix that. Here's our
current fetch code.  We want to
do something special for our
avatars, so let's rewind a bit.
If the request is to gravatar,
which is where the avatars come
from , we'll call out to
another function,
handleAvatarRequest.
Otherwise, we'll handle the
request as we were before.
So, what does
handleAvatarRequest do? We
could fetch the avatar from the
network and if that fails we
can serve a default from the
cache. We'd cache this fallback
avatar in our install step.
Cool, ship it! Of course,
later, we could do something
even better. when we get the
request for the avatar. Try and
get it from the cache. If we
get a response, send it to the
page! That gives us an avatar
without going to the network.
But we should go to the
network too, not only in case
we don't get a cached response
But also just to update what we
have in the cache. The user may
have updated their avatar.
Showing an old avatar is okay,
but we should update it for
next time.
So off to the network we
go. And if we get a response
back. Put it in the cache .And
that's us done, unless the
avatar wasn't already in the
cache. In that case, send back
the network response. Done!
This is what HTTP calls
stale-while-revalidate caching.
It's an experimental feature in
Chrome, behind a flag .But we
can emulate it in ServiceWorker
so people can have it today.
Thankfully the code for this is
way simpler than describing it.
We start by making a network
request because we always need
to. Sometimes it's just to
update the cache. Sometimes
we'll send it back to the page
too. We use waitUntil to say
we're going to do some work in
addition to providing a
response. And in the additional
work we'll take our network
response and clone it.
The body of a response can
only be read by one thing, but
we're wanting to use it to feed
into the cache, but potentially
also back to the page. So we
need to clone it so we have
two
two.
This is how you can read a
free gigabyte,.
We
of them. We open a cache called
"avatars." Unlike our static
cache, we're going to preserve
this between versions Then put
the avatar in the cache .
Meanwhile we return a
response from the cache, and if
the cache doesn't have one, we
use the network fetch as the
response. Done! Sooner or later
you'll need some code to go
into the cache and look for
avatars you no longer need. But
this helps a lot.
So to see how this affects
things,
For the final time, I
promise, we approach the
compare-inator. First up:
online experience So quick,
full content. Offline? GO! So
quick, full content lie-fi. So
quick, full content. In fact,
the experience is the same
with
(Applause.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD:
In fact, the experience is
the same with every connection
type.The network only matters
when it comes to fetching new
content. Ship it! So we've
achieved network resilience
right? Well, we're doing great
when it comes to sending data
to the user, but less so    When it comes to the user
sending data to us, I hate this
- the user's transaction is
complete. They've said here are
some smiley faces, please send
them to people - done. But no,
we're requiring them to watch
it through to completion.
can do better.
Background sync  landed in
Chrome a couple of months ago.
It's a ServiceWorker event that
you request. You're asking to
do some work when the user has
a connection. Straight away if
the user already has a
connection, otherwise later.
So say we had a function that
was called whenever the user
typed a message and hit send.
We'd add the message to an
outbox. This is a function we'd
write that puts the message
into IDB or whatever. Then get
the ServiceWorker registration.
We register for a sync and give
it a name.
That can fail. So we should
catch that and fall back to our
regular
you-must-watch-this-send
approach.  Otherwise, over in
the ServiceWorker we get a sync
event.We can check the tag name
so we know how to react .We use
our old friend waitUntil to let
the ServiceWorker know how long
things take. Then we get the
messages from the outbox, send
them to the server and remove
them from the outbox. The
effect of this, the user can be
on lie-fi, or totally offline
but they can use the app as if
it were online.
When they send a message,
we can add it straight to the
chat output It says "sending"
"sending".
I can hit some pictures of
cats and it says send
sending therein and in tiny
letters, but it doesn't
have a lot of emphasis.  The
user is free to close
their phone or the browse er.
It doesn't matter.  At
some point later when they reg
ain connectivity, the
message will be September in
the background.
There it goes.
And the user didn't know
this happened, didn't
know it was sent in the
background.  From their point
of view the transaction was
complete.  They said send
this.  The time they get to
know about it is with a
push notification with a reply
from another user.  By
using sync, we get out of the
user's way.  They don't
have to check for new messages.
We tell them about
this.  This improves the user
experience.  If you do
this stuff, I think it's
totally cool to brag about
it.  This is something that the
I/O Web app does,
cache ing complete, this
workings offline.  I think
this is great, but I do hope
that it goes out of
fashion.  I remember those
little site pages that
said this site was built using
CSS2.  Now you say CSS
CSS, well done you
(Laughter.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: I hope
one day this will seem
as ridiculous.  Before that we
do need to build up
user trust.
I don't know if someone has
seen this before.
This is what I'm greeted with
on the bathroom on
board the trains I compute to
work in.  You have to
press D to close the door and L
when it's flashing to
lock the door.  There's braille
there as well.  Even
blind people know they have to
wait for the flashing
light
(Laughter.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: But the
buttons aren't proper
buttons eacher.  They are flat
touch things, horrible
horrible.  I don't trust this.
I don't trust this
because once it failed on me.
And I was slowly
revealed to the carriage like a
bad game show prize.
(Laughter.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD:
Similarly users don't trust
the Web.  Messages do use, all
the epiphany ies I had in
bathrooms.  ServiceWorker used
that.  In
the future weapon are going to
tighten the rules to
try to detect some kind of
offline cable experience.
We want everything on the
Homescreen to be
competitive with native apps.
We want to make the
Web a first class part of the
operating system in the
user's mind.
On that note I want to com
pare the launching of a
native app Google Photos, well
built and well
optimize ed, to Emojoy and
launch them at the same time
time.
Oh, it's really close, like
Emojoy is naught point
two-seconds closer.  200
milliseconds, almost
nothing
nothing.  That's a well built
native app.  That's
starting from cold, the
browse er not in memory at all.
If the user had looked at
the browse er at some
point recently, let's face it
the browse er, fairly
popular app, that's quite like
ly.  This happens.
This is a progressive Web
app.
(Applause.)
>> JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
beating a native app to
content render by almost half a
sepgd.  That's the
power of ServiceWorker and the
power of offline first
first.  It was incremental,
improving the experience
every step for everyone.
Things get faster for users
with decent connections, things
top being frustrating
with lie-fi and impossible for
users that are offline
offline.  A few people today
asked me about Android
instant apps and what that
means for the Web.
Progressive apps are possible
today.  One app across
thousands of devices operating
systems and browse ers,
already beating a pre-installed
native app to render.
ServiceWorker is in the
stable Chrome, Opera and
others now.  Under
consideration by apple.
Progressive enhancement means
you can use it today as
we saw people talking about it
earlier.  If you use
ServiceWorker and things become
faster in Chrome and
Firefox than in Safari, that
gives Apple reason to
use it.  You get to guide the
future of the
ostensible Web.  ServiceWorker
creates great users.
Polly filling network features,
I've gone through a
lot of stuff.  There is a free
udacity course fully
interactive where you take a
website from online only
to Offline-First.  Going into
everything I talked
about.  Don't remember the URL.
Google udacity
offline.  It shows up.
With that, it has been a
pleasure.  Thank you very
much.
(Applause.)
(Cheers and applause.)
(The session concluded.)
indr.  Wayfindr.  Way
finder.
>>
>> Test test test test test test
test test
test
test.
>>
>> 5/19/16
Google.org:  Accelerating
Invasion for people with
disabilities
>>
>> Everyone, lightning! Thanks
for sticking with us through a
long time.  I'm Brigette Hoyer
Gosselink, I'm part of the team
at Google.org.  Yesterday as the
keynote, how many made it flu
the keynote and heard the
closing?  Not bad.  Good job!
If you haven't, I think it's
worth watching.  It's relevant
to content we have today.  He
talked about the power of a
pplying the most cutting edge
computing we have to the world's
biggest  challenges.  At G
oogle.org we fund and support
organizations chough are working
to make that promise, the
promise of technology to have
social impact a reality.
And it was interesting for me
because yesterday's keynote
actually brought me a little bit
full circle back to last year's
keynote.  Last year's keynote
there was a video that profiled
a man from Brazil who is working
on a piece of assistive
technology for his daughter.
The organizations that we are
working with here today that are
here to share their work with
you as well as many of the
organizations we supported last
year actually were working to
tackle a specific set of
challenges facing people with
disabilities.
So first, a quick poll, how many
people here either identify
themselves as having a
disability or know someone who
does?
.  It's a lot of people.  As
many of you probably know one in
seven people in the world have
some form of disability.  It's a
billion people.  It's the w
orld's largest minority.
And we know that technology has
the potential to help increase
independence and opportunity for
people with disabilities for
that billion people.  Something
very exciting is  happening
outside!  And here, which is
great.  So last year at I/O we
announced plans to award $20
million in funding and funding
and support for n on-profit
organizations chough were trying
to help push forward
independence and opportunity.
We launched an open call and we
were blown away by the response
we got.  We had more than a
thousand applications from 88
countries.  One of those
applications was from Carlos.
And Carlos actually proposed to
use natural language processing
and context, a couple of things
we heard about here at I /0 to
improve the assist of
communication software he was
building to his daughter could
communicate.  She has
communicate limitations as
someone with cerebral palsy.  So
he wants the software to be
able to in the morning when they
w akes up suggest on her
picture board breakfast items
because it knows that she is at
home and she knows in the
morning she wants breakfast.
She wouldn't have to navigate in
to find, through several menus
to find options so she can say
she wants oatmeal.
So it was exciting for me to
here Cinder talking about the
promise of those practices and
we are excited to be funding
Carlos to do the work and what
he will be building will be open
source so other assistive d
evices and software can benefit
from the same work he is using.
I'm thrilled to have here today
four other organizations who won
funding through that challenge,
who are all working on really
hard problems.  If you want to
check out any of the other
projects and ideas that we
funded, they are all available,
you can check them out at G.C O/
disabilities.  With that I will
turn it over to the panelists to
introduce themselves and tell
you about their work.    They
will talk about who they are as
people, technologists working on
social challenges.  Hopefully
that's interesting to some of
you, and what the problem is
they are working on  as well as
the approach to try to solve
that problem.
>> ARNON ZAMIR: Very excited to
be here.  My name is Arnon Z
amir, I came from Tel Aviv where
I run an organization named
TOM.  Myself, I'm a software
developer by profession and by
occupational history, but in the
last many years or so I have
been running social technology
involved
projects.  What we do with TOM
is kind he create an umbrella
system for technologies to be
involved in assisting and
empowering people with
disabilities.  We are  looking
for challenges that can and,
therefore, should be addressed
by technology and we are looking
for two main cases, either as a
solution if a challenge does
not exist or where a solution
exists but it is not affordable
to many people due to either IP
rights on the design or other
reasons usually customization
which makes it very expensive.
We are looking for technology
makers that are willing to put
some time into development of
solutions and then people with
disabilities and experts which
we call need knowers, those that
can  describe the need.  We
facilitate the meeting of the
two by making make-a-thons,
marathons of m akers and taking
the products of those into
continuous developing products,
and finally with the assistance
of G oogle.org we are able to
take the pack path to market as
I non-profit organization on an
open source version of
everything that we require and
develop.  That said one line, a
long line.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: Gr
eat,.
>> GINNY GRANT: I'm Ginny Grant
Benetech I'm senior product
manager at Ben  Ben they tech
and I have been a technologist,
a classroom teacher and
volunteer and when I came to
Benetech is a completely
different kind of technology
company.  Like you we look for
opportunities where we can serve
communities that otherwise are
not as well s erved, whether
it's in an environmental sense.
We have tools which allow c
onservationists to report issues
with their ecosystem.  We also
have secure tools that our human
rights advocates are able to
report human rights v iolations
around the world.
And then in the group that I'm
most focused on our global
literacy team, we serve over
400,000 members who are able to
get our books in an accessible
format for their needs whether
it's because they have a vision
impairment or they have lost the
use of a limb, perhaps whether
cerebral palsy or they have
served their country and lost an
arm, had a stroke or they have
a learning difference, a
disability such as dyslexia that
causes the words not to form
properly unless they are served
in multimodal both visually and
auditorially and highlighted.
We are it's exciting we are able
to bring those technologies to
people around the world and I
will be talking later about the
details of how we are doing
t hat.
>> HOLGER DIETERICH: Hello, my
name is Holger Hieterich, I'm
the cofounder of wheel map. map.
org I have a degree in design
and work in product management a
lot.  The problem I have found
with my best friendra usual
friend Rahul who is using an
electric wheelchair is where can
we hang out, have coffee,
mundane things and we think that
inclusion means that everybody
should take part in daily life
equally, no matter if they have
a disability or not.  So what I
figured out is why do we always
go to the cafe in your area.
Why don't you come to my
neighborhood?  So we are from
Berlin, Germany, and we have
lots of old  buildings and what
I didn't know is lots of
buildings have steps in the
entrance so you cannot get in
when you have an electric
wheelchair.  He said I don't
know where I can get in in your
neighborhood.  I'm l ike,io, but
you cannot be the only
wheelchair user in Berlin or in
this neighborhood.  So what
about building an app where
everybody can, you know, look
around and mark places, physical
places like restaurants, cafes,
anything, any public places and
say, yes, they are wheelchair
accessible or no, they are not
wheelchair accessible.  So we
built that like five years ago
and it's now the largest data
set in the world with more than
650,000 marked places and we are
on line in 22 languages.  So
what we do now is we want to
bring this to other l
ocation-based  services and maps
apps so that they can augment
their service with wheelchair
accessibility, but not only our
resources but from other n
on-profits from other data
sources as
as well.
>> UMESH PANDYA: I'm Umesh
Pandya, my full name is Umesh
Pandya.  I have been a designer
for 15 years.  And we work out
of London and I look after an
organization called Wayfindr.
Way finder's mission is to
empower vision impaired people
to navigate the world.  That's
what we do day in and day out.
What we do, we could not create
an app.  We are creating an open
standard for audio-based way
finding.  What that allows
people to do is it allows venue
owners such as transport n
etworks and retailers and
navigation app developers to
have a common language together.
So they can look at the
standard and understand how they
might make their space
accessible for indoor navigation
for blind people.  Now,
currently we are using BLE, so
we are using bluetooth beacons
to allow turn by turn.  We have
done i nstallations over in
London and Sydney and that tells
the user walk straight or turn
right or go down an escalator
and all of the instructions and
guidelines are baked in the
guidelines we published last
week in the open standards.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: Pe
rfect.  Thanks so much for the
overviews.  I think I would like
to start with a discussion
about inclusive design in
general and in specific how we
can think about technology
really being part of the answer
for some of the challenges that
face people with disabilities.
And obviously that's the core of
what you all could do, but I
thought it would be useful for
the audience to give more of the
advice you would have for
designing with this user
population in mind.  Ginny,  do
you want to start off?
>> GINNY GRANT: A number of
things.  The first thing is
start early, think about
accessibility as soon as you can
right with usability.  You
never want to bake it back in
later.  You can't change the i
ngredients.S so much better to
start up front.
So look for all of the design
standards and I know other
people will be talking about
this too, but thinking about t
he, POUR, that's a good a
cronym.  So Google that.  Making
sure that every illustration or
image that's in your, on your
Web page or in your tool is
accessible to all.  Turn off
volume.  Turn own  down the
monitor or try to use an oven
mitt to navigate.  If you had to
use a switch and needed to be
able to mooch around, you can't
assume that people have all of
the dexterity that some others
do.  So work that in from the
very get-go.  There are lots of
other things but work through
standards.  Umy you mentioned
that earlier, try to improve the
standards so that more people
can spread the capability of
technology that is accessible.
I think that's a good starting
point.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: De
finitely.
>> ARNON ZAMIR: I would like to
add to that and that's a very
important part of creating
anything inclusive and anything
accessible is being in a concept
dialogue with the people that
need it.  One of the principles
which is articulated in the s
aying from Holger, nothing about
us without us.  Don't do
anything for someone, always do
with someone.  When we
work-a-thon we define our goal
and methodology as facilitating
meeting points of challenge and
talent.  We bring people that
can donate some of their time
and we sit them in the same room
in the same table with the
people that can understand the
challenge.
So imagine that you were
developing an app, a
productivity app for young
mothers.  The first thing you
would have done is go meet young
mothers and analyze their
productivity challenges.  Right.
That's obvious for every
development team working on
designing the new app.  The same
thick is true for -- thing is
true from wheelchair
accessibility for applications
for people with disabilities.
Just have your client with you.
And another small angle on
that, is that accessibility is
one thing.  Design your
application to be accessible for
people with certain
limitations.  Another angle can
be when you are m eeting with a
new technology or when you are
creating a new technology, one
of the things we found out some
people right away think what can
this technology do for people
with disabilities?  So if we
have a new
visual design or if we have a
contextual engine or if we have
anything new happening in the
big technology world, right away
we think how can this be used
for people with disabilities?
There is no  advancement today
that is not tied with technology
and this is not an
exception.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: Br
ing in as I use case and not an
add on or something you need a
different piece of software for.
I think that speaks to
inclusive nature.  For those who
may be uncertain for those to
get close to the user needs.  It
can feel like a barrier when
developing solutions in this
base.  What advice would you
have for people to get close to
those needs.
H olger?
>> HOLGER DIETERICH: The way we
do it we use build, measure
learn and we use a can sentinel
design in everything we do.  For
example, in some of the
stations we have done we have
worked with users over three
weeks so every station we have
done every installation we have
done 25 users.  We bring them
in, test one to one, we
iterate, that means we get five
iterations of products in one
day, that's amazing.  Over the
course of three weeks we have
something validated.  All of
that information is pushed into
standard and we have an awesome
backlog that we need to attack
in the next round of user
testing.  Having users at the
center is useful.  Prototyping
is a good way to manage
uncertainty.  If you are
developing something and unsure
am I doing the right thing or
should I be doing it this way?
Get users in the room.  Try and
hunt out the actual people that
have the needs that  you can
help support.  If you can't
access them, try to find experts
that can help with that.  The
core thing is bake them into
your process and bake them into
your organization and how you do
it.  You can't do it at a
distance.  It's difficult.  You
have to have them with you at
all times.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: I
think Holger's story of finding
the organization that he found
with Rahul, is the visceral way.
Just hire someone and have
them on your staff but if you
daunt do that, think I what you
suggested is quite useful.  We
mentioned the idea of
experimentation.  And this is
actually beyond this space
something that is interesting in
the social impact sector in
generally.  We actually don't
think a lot, in the same way we
talk about launching an iterate
in Google and many of the
technology that we build, we
don't think as much about it
sometimes when it comes to
social challenges and that's
because there are some real
barriers to that.  It's
something that we encourage in
the work that we support and
fund and a lot of the groups
that are represented here are
trying to do that.  I wonder if
you could get reflections on
some of the difficulties and
barriers to doing that well
given that you are trying to
with your work have great social
impact?
>> Maybe I can give an example.
So there were other non-profit
organizations who try to do what
he we did.  We are finding
wheelchair accessible places and
they are experts in their needs
as we said before, but they are
not experts in building end
read apps or Web Apps or making
it scale.  So our data set is
based on open street maps so we
have to know the access.  You
have to be able to access the
APIs and build around it and
make it stable, maybe interact
with others and have a good
design.  I think where things
come together is to learn from
each other and so that you as an
expert in software development
have a beginner's mind set in
learning about people with
disabilities and vice versa.  So
I think there is always
something people can help each
other
with.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: Um
i did you have anything to add.
>> UMESH PANDYA: What we have
learned because we are a joint
venture between digital products
studio and a charity, so it's a
joint venture between us and
the royal London society for
blind people.  We are learning
both ways.  We are bringing
digital products, design
processes and all of that in,
but what the R LSB are helping
us understand is the user and
the social impact.  Let me talk
about measure and build,
measure, learn, 2 gets expanded
a bit.  When you talk about
measure we can measure
usability, whether the
instructions are correct, how
many people are using it,
regular stuff like that.
However, if you are talking
about measurement in a kind of
social impact space is how do
you measure how someone felt
before they used the Wayfindr
enabled system?  How did they
feel after it.  How we moved
them along the journey to better
well being.  These are i
nteresting challenges that take
us out of the product space and
into a special impact space.
These are exciting times when we
start to unpack these things.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: I
don't know if people on live
stream can here cheering outside
of the tent but this is a
popular discussion.  Getting a
lot of support.  Ginny, I think
you that you have great
experience with the idea of
iterating.
>> GINNY GRANT: Book share and
Benetech have been around before
Kindle.  When we first parted
to make books available online
our mantra was about making
books accessible in the digital
format that she need and people
get it through the Web and we
have been starting as we have
been expanding out to other
countries and other places that
aren't as economically affluent,
and it's been fascinating to
see all of the technology that
still has I E6 people 6 embedded
in it.  And now they are
putting their library of books
on CDs and sending them through
the postal service every month
to their patrons and we are
trying to change socially the
culture as  as well as
technology.  So we are
definitely hitting constraints
where people who may not be as
economically advantaged can't
switch out technology as fast as
we here especially in this
wonderful Silicon Valley think
can happen, but we are trying to
make the strides to get us, get
people to that point again w
orking with and not for.  So
that's been an interesting
challenge.
What are some of the strategies
you have taken to try to deal
with that?  Some is updating
your software to work back to I
E6 so congratulations to you.
>> GINNY GRANT: We had to last
November cut the umbilical cord.
think they are at 8 now.
>> GINNY GRANT: They are out of
the nest now, but they have
other ways of doing it.
Unfortunately there were some
people that were still asus c
omed and some of it is comfort
levels because people have been
accustomed to doing things the
way they have been doing things
so it's been an interesting
journey to work with people and,
again, baby steps of getting
people to try something out,
feel comfortable.  I love the
idea of not just looking at
metrics from a purely objective
perspective but that subjective
nature as well.  It's really
cool.  So I guess that's some of
it is that we are also, we work
with open source as well, so
that we want to make sure that
other people can use pieces that
we built out.  We have a Math
ML club that we are evolving
that people will be able to help
expand and then use the Math ML
that's there in the repository
goes goings what's Math
--
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: Wh
at is Math ML.
>> GINNY GRANT: Imagine you are
looking at a stem book and as a
visual user you can see that
but what if you can't see it,
you have to hear it.  So if it's
spoken out in a markup language
that can be translated and
voiced, chem ML has the name
concept.  So being able to refer
to those different image
descriptions, ways that you can
describe what to a visual person
is just an image makes it
accessible to
all.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: Yo
u touched on something there is
that I guess I touched on in my
intro in talking what Carlos is
doing which is the idea 6 open
source.  One of the things that
we promote as Google.org is the
idea of openness and it's not
just for the principle of it but
because it's really critical to
see some of the solutions come
to scale.  So when we think
about the size of the problems
that people are working on that
these   organizations and others
are working on, how could we
imagine one organization solving
this, and frankly, you can't.
So actually all of these
organizations and most of those
that we support are actually
working to have people actively
adopt what it is that they are
doing outside of sort of the
walls of their organization,
which in many ways is different
than how I think about a f
or-profit enterprise.  In some
ways there is a wall built in
order to protect that and you
ideally don't see a lot of
copycats.  It cuts into revenue.
This is a split model with
what we are working with.
We would love you to explore the
challenges of that.  If you say
there aren't -- we have talked
about them and also some of what
you have seen to be successful
in trying to drive that adoption
beyond your own
walls.
>> ARNON ZAMIR: That's a huge
part of what we are doing.
Imagine you are building a
product and it's relatively
successful, you want it to grow
up and you want to scale it up.
And now imagine that your goal
is not to sell it but to
transform a situation to move
the needle, in our case, our
goal is to move the needle into
accessibility to assistive
technology.  So we want that
every assistive technology
whatever that is for your needs
will be available for you r
egardless of how much money you
have or where you are.
Obviously being a team of seven
people now, three people until
recently, we cannot do that
alone.
So from the ground app, the
whole mechanism behind the work
at home is community engagement.
We actively work to transfer
ownership from our own team to
the teams that are working on
specific projects.  So if we
have, for example, a t
ablet-based accessibility app,
we don't want to direct the t
eam.  We don't want to own the
product.  We just want to
support them as they own the
process and their results.  And
this is through prosthetic arms
that we are doing sometimes
based on open source existing
models or with wheelchair
adjustments or everything else.
And then we actively
incorporate into our system
mechanisms for replication.  We
are building a website that is
going to be an eBay style
experience and m arketplace
experience for people to
actively go on line and download
our material and copy and
transform it, and we are heavily
encouraging teams to do this.
One of the challenges is on one
hand how do we get as many
groups in the world as possible,
take the product, transform to
their local needs and implement
them.  On the other hand, make
sure no one is doing something
unwanted with i t.  What will
something unwanted be?  Use it
for something that we consider
immoral or just irresponsible,
or use it.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: Co
mmercializing
going against your
affordability, for example.
>> ARNON ZAMIR: We are not
against commercializing as long
as you keep the open files
available.  So some commercial
models can work as open source
products.  Some of you might
know, word press and a semi f
amous operation system called
Android you might have heard of,
they are all based on open
source products, projects, or
they are open source projects
and they are relatively p
rofitable.  So that's not
necessarily a contribution, but
then again, if someone tries to
clone what we are doing and not
share it with the world at all
we will have a problem with t
hat.  Organization-wise, we had
a couple of months ago we had a
team in Canada, very strong,
very
enthusiastic about work,
running a make-a-thon on their
own and working on the second
one and building a ground up
operation in a city called
Calgary on the west coast of
Canada.  They went ahead and
organized an organization called
TOM.  And we said, okay, how
do we do that?  And in case
which of you watching the video,
hi.
One approach, the commercial
approach would be this is our
name, you are not going to do
anything with that.  We are
going to protect ourselves
against this infringement, but
then we want the community to
grow.  So it's a constant d
ebate, constant dialogue with
them understanding the limits
and remember that we are very
young.  We have been doing this
for about two years, and there
is no other organization to look
and learn from, almost none.
So it's a concern balancing and
pushing back and forward p
rocess.  Right now, very
challenging, but very
s atisfying.
>> Actually also what we learned
is that, you know, I have a lot
of friends who working s
tart-outs and they say what is
the business model, will you put
advertising on it?  Do you have
API and sell it by the thousand
maps you surf.  But we are a
non-profit organization so we
will never be millionaires.  We
are out there to save the world.
So what we want to maximize is
impact.  The more people that
use it, the better.  If I put a
price tag on this, it will
hinder my goal, and we will
potentially not meet as many
people.  So our apps are free.
We want to encourage that data
is open and free.  At least it's
available in an understandable
format so that people can
understand where to find this
because once you decide that's
your goal, you should put all of
your effort into that.  What we
learned along the way working
also with organizations like
Google and other commercial
organizations is that they
appreciate what we do and want
to help and they help us do this
along the way.  So, for
example, we are doing a project
with a German railway system.
So the railway corporation, it's
an organization with 3  300,000
employees.  You don't want to
get stuck at a train station
because the elevator is not w
orking.  So you need real time
information on  is an elevator
working.  We built a project to
highlight that but there wasn't
a good real time API.  So we
built something on scraping and
stealing from their website to
show them what we could do, and
instead of hatetion us, they
said, hey, let's talk, how can
we make this happen.  We don't
understand.
Now, they have a full-fledged
open data initiative to open
make this  happen and they have
a realtime API which can be
included in all travel planning
around Germany.  That's our g
oal.  And actually now we are
kind of consulting them and they
pay us for this.  So that's
maybe how good things can happen
and we maximize our impact.  So
if we would charge for that, we
wouldn't have this liaison,
this relationship in the first
place.  So it's very different
from, well, in one area also we
need to make, we must not go b
ankrupt, otherwise we cannot
save the world, but otherwise we
need to trust in our cause.
>> I would like to iterate on
both of your points that we
believe that kind of adoption of
the standard directly equals to
the social impact, and we know
that as an organization we can't
do it all, right.  We need to
bring together transport n
etworks or built environment
owner, we immediate to bring
together charts and vision
impaired people.  We need to
bring together the software and
the hardware, guys that work in
the indoor navigation space.  We
need to bring in the
researchers and universities
that are dealing with this and
so we have created the Wayfindr
community where we have a good
amount of members in there now
and we are scaling that up
because we have now kind of the
second part of our standard
development which we released
last week is to now work
together with these
organizations to develop the
standard together.  So our
potential clients or the
potential people that will
increase the adoption are also
baked into the process of
creating the product.  So not
only are users a part of the
process, our customers are part
of the process to send that out
and develop our product.  So we
know we are making something
that's useable and somebody n
eeds rather than something
that's a pure guess.  That's why
it's important to have these
people really close and work
alongside you in a collaborative
manner.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: I
feel like you guys are making it
easy to save the world, which
is great, because we would love
to have more people working on t
his, but I know it's pretty
hard and is that you all have
had a bunch of challenges that
you are experiencing all of the
time.  And I think some of these
are parts of those, but I would
love to hear a couple of
stories about some of the hard
part of this, what has been a
really challenging problem you
have encountered and how you
have sort of worked through that
or the craziest day at work you
had or something like
that.
>> GINNY GRANT: I can do one.
There are many crazy days at
work but that's why we do it.
We love it.  When book share
started there was a concern or
threat felt by the publishing
industry that we were stealing
intellectual property.  If you
think about the shared music
services that there were for a
while, but Benetech is clear on
digital rights management and
policies so we have had to step
up our game there and prove that
we are not trying to share
intellectual property.  The
other thing we have done is we
have worked with the publishing
industry to produce standards
that they will then in turn
start to build out all of the
books and magazines and
literature that with the
standards that will allow,
enable everybody to
use them, accessible, accessible
for all.  So I think it was a
huge challenge at the beginning
and we now have publishers
coming to us saying how can we
get into your group and teach us
how to make the books that we
make more accessible.  So that
has been a huge switch, again,
needle moving.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: Do
you want to add.
>> UMESH PANDYA: We move daily
between kind of granular to high
level.  What I mean by that is
how we develop the product, what
the process is, what the
upcombraids we are going to d o
-- upgrades, to the bigger, how
are we going to change policy in
London.  How do you deal with
that when you are flipping
between these two things and
it's hard because when you are
used to making digital products
which you can evolve overnight
or every hour and then you are
working with a system that
changes over years, how do you
insure that you are going to be
still alive to see the fruits of
your labor, and see whether
it's actually delivered an
impact.  So these are the things
that bounce around in our minds
which is are we using our time
efficiently and where do we push
our e fforts.  Before when we
would work for clients and
products it's like are we going
to push the pixels around and
make it nice but when it becomes
about delivering this change,
it's that some of it can stay
there, don't worry about that.
We need need to deliver this
because this is the impact we
need to deliver.  So it's a flip
for us.
>> HOLGER DIETERICH: Small
thing I can tell you, maybe you
as developers can relate to,
it's like  being a charity is
not an excuse for bad quality.
We, for example, we didn't have
a lot of testing and we were
learning along the way and in
the beginning when you didn't
allow location and you opened
the app you were getting weird
error messages like something is
not working and you have to
click it five times to get rid
of it.  And then you lose
interest or something like that.
So we didn't notice that
somebody would do this because
we didn't think of it, and we
are stupid maybe, but we
immediately got like one star
reviews on the app store for
free app run by a charity on
donor's money and we are like,
what?  We are putting our heart
into this and you are still like
immediately one star, one star.
So but actually it's also good
because it proves a point that
they deserve good quality, and
that we must deliver this as
well, and we are just considered
another app is actually an
achievement, it's not like it's
kind of crappy, but as charity.
It's not anymore.  It has to be
well designed and we worked a
long time on doing this, and you
don't have to have location
enabled all of the time.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: We
have this myth a little bit
that products that are done
through non-profits can be, you
know, fine but not great, or
that d oing this work is
actually easier than harder.  I
think it's both.  It's fun and
you get inspired by it, but
there is also I lot of hard
challenges.  I would love for
you all who have made this move
from being technologists in
maybe a more mainstream
environment for using the
technical skims for good.
Inspire people to do the same
who are listening to you all
speak.  Arnon Zamir this is what
you do every day so I will turn
to you to start.
>> ARNON ZAMIR: Yes, this is
what we do every day, and we
have a very simple strategic
approach, which is do and do n
ow.  We are very open for
technologists and half
technologists and sometimes n
on-technologists to join us and
participate in a development of
some feature in a product.  And
as a person which is partially
our inspiration, John shool from
enable says a prosthetic arm
needs to be diminishingly better
than nothing.  We are good at
bringing together people to
develop solutions that are
diminishingly better than
nothing and then very, very
better than
nothing.  And you are all
invited to join because you
don't need to change everything.
We are not asking people to
stop what they are d oing and
start doing just work for
society.  We are asking people
to donate either three days in
the year or three hours in the
week, and we have a n on-written
agreement with them.  You give
us your time and we will make
sure it's dedicated to something
very good, which is many times
going to sustain and move
forward and grow and change
somebody's life.  And the world
is full with opportunities to do
good things and to marvel in
them, and I'm very happy to
engage everyone online and
offline in activity.  I want
tell a very short story about a
product that you can see in our
booth here.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: In
the access and onlipathy sand
box.
>> ARNON ZAMIR: There is a
product called the grabber.  It
looks like a bear of clamps with
a mouth operated thingy at the
end of the it was created with a
friend named Kim from northern
California.  She was born
unfortunately with no limbs and
she had some difficulties
reaching things that are far
from her side, from her reach by
her mouth and it was created
act life to her measurement, to
her need and relatively
successful.  About a week ago, I
got this video of
what's app showing the same
instrument transferred into
something new, forked like a
software open source software
can be forked.  The guys took it
and on the clamps they put the
hands of a doll and head of a
doll and two bells at the end.
And now it is clapping doll that
is used for a parent which is
disabled from the neck down to
play with his 4-year-old
daughter.  He is holding it and
he can clap the hands which he
couldn't before.  Same m
echanism, different
interpretation.  We could never
have gotten to this without open
source accessibility and
without the community being so
daring and doing stuff we are
never thinking of.  So join us.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: Gi
nny what advice  do you have?
>> GINNY GRANT: Besides making
sure anything you build can be
used with a single oven mitt or
turn off your monitor and your
volume to make sure that anyone
and everyone can use whatever
you are building which will be
great quality.  Of course, there
is always applying to Benetech.
We have multiple jobs open.
But I would say build out your
ecosystem.  Get to know people
who care about this and demand
accessibility
everywhere.
>> HOLGER DIETERICH: What we
learn is if you want to do
something and support a n
on-profit organization like o
urs or like the others,
question, empathy is fine but
what we do need is your
expertise.  One idea is in the
beginning we had on our website,
you want to become a hero, help
us, something like that.
Contact us.  So we got random
people wanting to volunteer.  We
changed it completely.  We said
we need a JavaScript fronted
expert in design like three
months unpaid one day per week
for a non-profit organization as
a volunteer work.  So we are
blunt and up front about this
and we got something like
applications from really cool
people we hired later.  Because
it was sometimes the first
moment when they could say, hey,
I can play with this cool
framework for the first time and
have an impact.  One  story is
that the first was built by the
users that were hating that we
were only an iOS.  And we said,
well, we don't have the means to
pay somebody to do this, and
they said I can bring you
together.  And actually three
people came together to build
this remotely and one actually
quit his day job and became a
freelance end developer
afterward because he had this
reference of a successful app
with a worldwide impact, and
building things like we
completely trusted this person
because there was nothing what
can go wrong?  We have a back
end.  We have an API.  Cool
things can be built, and I
though this is like where you
should come from.  I'm
interested in this framework and
new technology.  I always
wanted to try this and that out
so there are places where you
can Google or where you can
search for like  charities by
the programs language, for
example.  On github we have all
of our source code and we have
issues that have mentored so
that we can bring new
contributors on board and not
say check out the whole thing
and you can figure it out.
Start with something that's easy
and if it it's fun, do more.
As soon as you contribute and
submit a request, and then we
will look at it and merge it and
maybe you do more.  So think of
what you like to work on,
what's fun for you, and then, I
think, the collaboration will
work well.
>> UMESH PANDYA: I think it's
going to be quite immediate.
I'm assuming that most of you
are developers.  I have done
this before.  It might get you
neared   fired or it may not get
you fired.  You are the guys
that implement the code.  Now,
implement and accessibility into
it is not a hard effort, so
start rogue.  Just, your client
gives you a project, start
implementing it in there.  We
have done it before.  You can go
to your client and say I would
like, 70% of your app is
accessible, do you want to make
the rest accessible.  I have
seen that many times before so I
would recommend you do that
immediately.  From a Wayfindr
point of view we are open
standard so we want you guys to
come along and if you can,
contribute towards it, if you
can, share and we would love
your feedback and this is how we
want to grow so hit yourself at
way finder.net/standard and we
would love to hear your f
eedback.
>> BRIGITTE HOYER GOSSELINK: On
e of my favorite parts of my
job is I have the privilege to
meet passionate people who are w
orking to use technology for
social good so I'm glad to have
been able to share that
privilege with you today.